AS WE ARE STARTING HERE TODAY
WE ARE GOING TO BE INVOLVED
ENGAGED AND REMOTE TESTIMONY IN
VOTING- JUST A REMINDER FOR
THOSE OF WHEN WE DO CALLING YOU
WE WILL NEED TO HAVE VISUAL
CONFIRMATION SO I ASK YOUR
PATIENCE IF I DON'T GET VISUAL
CONFIRMATION MAY ASK YOU TO
REPEAT- YOUR VOTE OR YOUR
PRESENCE- JUST TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE AN ACCURATE RECORDS- SO
JUST WITH THAT REMINDER- I
ACTUALLY ASK THAT EVERYONE
LEASE BE PATIENT. AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS AND ENSURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF OUR-
ESTEEMED BODY HAS THE PART
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
FULLY IN OUR DELIBERATIONS
TODAY KNOW WHAT THAT OF TWO
STEPS QUORUM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS FELL. BRADFORD BY ADAM.
DODD THE RYZEN GOT JOHNNY.
LASER GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HELLO
YEAH HUESO HURTADO JACKSON
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MINING
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN I'M BURKE
Y. CASKEY WIENER. THE COURT
THANK YOU A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THEM. YEAH OKAY TELL ME
THE CALL YES ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
REMOTE TO MEMBERS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF THE
REMOTE MEMBERS. BASED. OKAY
WOOD WE DO NOT HAVE AN AUDIENCE
SO I THINK YOU NEED THEM AND WE
YOURSELF CENTER BATES. SENATOR
BATES PRESENT THANK YOU
GORGEOUS WE'RE JUST PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CHIANG. THANK PRESENT
THANK YOU DALLY. THE NEW DELHI
PRESENT THANK YOU GROWTH. IT A
GREAT PRESENT. MELENDEZ.
SENATOR MELENDEZ PRESENT WE DID
NOT GET A VISUAL CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THAT AGAIN. SENATOR
MELENDEZ PRESENT THANK YOU
WARLOCK. SENATOR MORLOCK
PRESENT THANK YOU MORALE.
GENERAL PRESS THANK YOU. WILK.
OKAY I NEEDED AN UNUSED. HOLD
ON A MOMENT- OKAY- CENTER LOCUS
HAVING SOME DIFFICULTY IN
MEETING. OKAY CENTER WILK SHE
CAN WE BRING CENTER WOKE BACK.
WELL LET'S GO BACK TO CENTER TO
WILK JUST HIT THE BUT ONCE GIVE
IT A PROCESS ON MUTE FIRST.
OKAY. HOLD ON WE NEED TO.
THERE'S NO WAY TO REMOVE THEM
RIGHT TO BE. YEAH I KNOW HOST.
YEAH IT'S ON MUTE. OKAY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WE
JUST NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
AND MEET CENTER WILK.
OKAY ALL
RIGHT WE WILL TAKE WILL HAVE
ONE WAIT FOR A MOMENT.
WELL
THAT SECRETARY OKAY YES PRESENT.
OKAY THANK YOU QUORUM IS
PRESENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO EVERYONE COULD
PLEASE- SIT DOWN FOR A MOMENT-
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WE'LL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING L. B.
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY CENTER ARCH
ALETTA. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD THANK A MISPRINT. ON
THE FIFTY S. FIFTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY REVEREND DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR'S MARCH ON
WASHINGTON WE PRAY. BRITISH
PATIENT BROUGHT OF MERCY AND
COMPASSION YOU'RE LOGGED IN
HAILING PRESENTS ARE MADE KNOWN
THROUGH OUR WILLINGNESS TO
COLLABORATE. IN THE SACRED
MESSY WORLD SO MUCH BEAUTY IN
SO MUCH TROUBLE. USE OUR GUESTS
THROUGH THE POWER OF YOUR
SPIRIT. CAN MAKE THE RIGHT IN
EQUITIES AND THEN JUSTICE
JUSTICES THE STEEL PLATE OUR
WORLD. GIVE US THE COURAGE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND SPEAK TRUTH IN
THE FACE OF BLATANT RACIAL
INJUSTICE. R. LEE AND HORRIFIC
POLICE BRUTALITY GIVE US THE
STRENGTH AND DETERMINATION TO
DISCONNECT MANAL AND REORGANIZE
THE SYSTEM STEP PREVENT NEEDED
CHANGE GIVE US THE FAITH TO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE RESPOND. TO
THE FIRST PHIL SPURGEON SHE
HAVE NOW. THIS TIME AS A
BELOVED COMMUNITY WE WILL BRING
RENEWAL AND RESTORATION TO OUR
SOCIETY FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PRESENT AND FUTURE GENERATIONS
AHMET- AND. CENTER FOR YOUR
HAND OVER YOUR HEART. AND
FOLLOWING I PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. ISRAEL ALL. THANK
YOU SO MEMBERS ARE TODAY WE
HAVE SENATORS BATES PORGES
CHIANG DOLLY GROWS JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE AND
WILK PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
PROVISIONS OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. PARTS OF THE
CAN OF COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX. ANYONE ELSE. OKAY YEAH
YEAH NO ANSWER THERE. OKAY I
DON'T ANYBODY OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE ON AND
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING FILE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH EIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT TEN EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE EIGHT BILL SIX THIRTY ONE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO. THE. THANK YOU. THE
BUILDING BUILDING. YEAH OKAY.
GENERAL MOTORS AND- OKAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'LL GO TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. RIGHT
YEAH OKAY WILL BEGIN THEN WITH
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE. MEXI
ONLINE HERE. RIGHT SO. THE FARM
TWENTY ONE IS- CENTER MITCHELL
US SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AND ACTUALLY IN TWO COUNTIES.
CENTER MITCHELL. I GOOD MORNING
ALL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE THE BILL WHICH
WOULD CLARIFY A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND MAY ESTABLISH A
SHARE OF OVERSIGHT BOARD OR
POINT AN INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
GRANT THEM SUBPOENA POWER.
MEANINGFUL INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT INCREASES
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ENHANCES PUBLIC
SAFETY AND BUILD COMMUNITY
TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT SUCHOVERSIGHT MUST HAVE THE
AUTHORITY INDEPENDENCE
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT CREDIBLE
AND THOROUGH INVESTIGATIONS TO
DATE THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
CONFUSION OVER THE ROLE OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS IN ITS
OVERSIGHT OVER A COUNTY SHERIFF.
IN BOTH OF THE OFFICE COUNTY
HERE SACRAMENTO MY OWN HOME
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE. THEY
HAVE BEEN WELL PUBLICIZED
CONFLICTS BETWEEN OVERSIGHT
BOARDS AND THEIR SHARE OF.
THESE OVERSIGHT BOARDS AND THE
WORK THEY DO ARE OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHICH RELY ON
THEIR SHARE OF DEPARTMENT OF
THEIR PRINCIPAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.COLLEAGUES WERE IN THE
MIDST OF A GLOBAL OUTCRY TO
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM OUR PEACE
OFFICERS. WITH THIS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO DEMAND FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. BOTH OF WHICH
ARE ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IF WE
ARE TO CREATE MEANINGFUL
SYSTEMIC CHANGE THIS BILL WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO CREATE MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY BY
SHERIFF'S. SHERIFF'S BY
CLARIFYING THE AUTHORITY OF
SHARE OF OVERSIGHT BOARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU QUESTION
ARE COMMONSENSE MANY FROM THE
FLOOR- WILL BEGIN WITH A CENTER
PORCHES. YOU CAN PLEASE BRING
CENTER BORDERS ON. THE SCREEN
CENTER BORDERS. HELLO MISTER-
PRESENT CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES
IF YOU CAN PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU. WHEN I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CITY COUNCIL IN FRESNO IN ISSUE
CAME OUT RECALL REGARDING THE
CREATION OF THE POLICE AUDITOR.
AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE REASONABLE
PEOPLE I THINK ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE ISSUE AND I ENDED UP
SUPPORTING THE CREATION THE
POLICE AUDITOR. IN THE CITY OF
FRESNO. OVER THE YEARS I WAS
DISAPPOINTED. TO FIND OUT HI
HOW IT PERFORMS. AND REALIZE
THAT. REALLY IT'S GOING TO BE
THE COMMUNITY AND THE LEADERS
IN THAT COMMUNITY THAT DECIDE
WHETHER AN OVERSIGHT ENTITY
IT'S NECESSARY WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. IS WHAT EXACTLY IT DOES I
THINK WE HEARD FROM THE SPEAKER
THAT THERE'S AMBIGUITY OR
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT. THE ROLE
BETTER SUPPORT OF SUPERVISORS
HAS WITH THE SHERIFF SO ON AND
SO FORTH. THAT'S NOT BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE AT THE SUPERMAJORITY
ALONG. THAT IF A COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WANTS TO CREATE
OVERSIGHT BOARD THAT'S THEIR
DISCRETION. IF COMMUNITY ASKS
FOR IT ARE THEY BUY OTHER ME OF
PUTTING IT FORWARD EITHER
THROUGH BALLOT FOR THROUGH THE
NORMAL OF A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
LOCAL LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IN ALL THIS
IS. WHY ARE WE CREATING THIS IF
THE POWERS ALREADY EXIST AND I
BELIEVE THEY DO. THEN WE ARE
BASICALLY PUTTING OUT WINDOW
DRESSING WITHOUT ANY REAL
SUBSTANCE. AND I THINK THAT
ULTIMATELY IS BAD POLICY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S BEING
DONE. DURING A HEATED INTENSE
POLITICAL CLIMATE WHERE WE HAVE
TO BE SHOWN IS DOING SOMETHING.
BUT I WOULD DEFER TO LOCAL
INDIVIDUALS THE LOCAL LEADERS
LOCAL COMMUNITY LEADERS THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WANT. THEY CAN ISSUED IT ON ITS
OWN THEY DON'T NEED OUR
ENCOURAGEMENT. OR OUR TACIT
APPROVAL TO DO SO ULTIMATELY I
THINK THIS IS. NOT GOING TO BE
ANYTHING NEW AND THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY ALREADY EXISTS SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS- THE
NEXT LEADER IS AT CENTER MORE
LOCK YOU CAN BRING CENTER MORE
LIKE TO SCREEN. FOR MORE ON. I
ADDRESSING AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT A
COLLEAGUES I'VE ENJOYED A LOT
OF ROAD WATCHING DEPUTY
SHERIFFS BRINGS. AN
INAPPROPRIATE CULTURE THAT WAS
OCCURRING IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
JAILS. ONE INMATE JOHN DEERE
CHIANG WAS MURDER BY HIS FELLOW
INMATES. LITERALLY IN FULL VIEW
OF TWO DEPUTIES WHO DECIDED TO
WATCH TV AND LOOK AWAY. THIS
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. IT
STARTED ME ON A DIFFICULT
JOURNEY COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
PROVIDE SOME FORM OF OVERSIGHT.
THIS JOURNEY RESULTED IN
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE OF
INDEPENDENT REVIEW. THE MODEL
CAME FROM L. A. COUNTY- IT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THEN SHERIFF LEE
BACA. AND IT WAS- RUN BY BOB
MICHAEL CHEN AKA I WAS A GREAT-
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
TOOL- JUST WHICH LEE BACA WOULD
HAVE FOLLOWED A LITTLE CLOSER.
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER STORY- I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO IS DOING. IN COUNTY
CAN ESTABLISH OFFICES OF
INDEPENDENT REVIEW WITHOUT THIS
LEGISLATION AND COULD KERR WITH
THE SENATOR FROM FRESNO. IF
THERE IS A SERIOUS CONCERN THE
GRAND JURY CAN ISSUE SUBPOENAS
I BELIEVE THE OFFICE OF
INDEPENDENT REVIEW IS THE MODEL
THAT IS SATISFACTORY BUT I
APPRECIATE WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO AND THE
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY AS OF. OF
WHAT IT'S IMPACTING US SO
COLLEAGUES I WILL NOT BE VOTING
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LOCKER AND IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL SEEING NONE OF US
ARE MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MISTER PRESIDENT I
INDEED WOULD THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH. YOU KNOW ALL
COLLEAGUES IT WAS THE THIRD OF
THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY AND
SOLVE THIS GIVE YOU A COUPLE
EXAMPLES AND LET'S BE CLEAR THE
BILL OF PERMISSIVE IT IT ALLOWS
THE COUNTY TO ESTABLISH ONE.
AND IT ALSO GIVE SUBPOENA POWER
BECAUSE THOSE OF US WHO
REPRESENT COUNTY THAT MAY HAVE
A COMMISSION DON'T HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TIED ONE ARM. BEHIND THE
BACK OF THOSE WHO ATTEMPT. ON
TO HOLD A FLASHLIGHT. UP TO
THEIR COUNTY SHERIFF IN THE
DEPARTMENT. FOR EXAMPLE IN MY
OWN HOME COUNTING. DESPITE THE
PASSAGE OF MEASURE OR- FALL
WITHIN L. A. COUNTY WHICH
ESTABLISHES AN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION. THE SHERIFF HAS
REFUSED TO ATTEND HEARINGS IN
CON AND CUT CONTACT BY THE
COMMISSION. IN MAY OF THIS YEAR
HE DEFIED A SUBPOENA FROM THE
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT BOARD TO
TESTIFY ABOUT PULL THAT
NINETEEN IN THE COUNTY JAILS.
IN SIMILAR INSTANCES OF SURE OF
DEFIANCE. OF THEY'VE BEEN
REPORTED IN OTHER COUNTIES.
ORANGE COUNTY SACRAMENTO FAMILY
THIS WILL CONTRA COSTA
PHENOMENA SANTA CLARA PASADENA
ALAMEDA IN LAKE COUNTY. AND
FILL ALL IT'S VERY TRUE THAT
LOCALS CAN CERTAINLY MAKE THE
DETERMINATION IF THEY WANT
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION I THINK
THE PASSAGE OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. IS A STRONG SIGNAL FROM
THE STATE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT THE- ON. I
WILL CHOOSE TO USE THE WORD
RAMPANT INSTANCES. OF WHERE
SHERIFF'S BOMB ARE NOT
COMPLYING WITH THEIR OWN COUNTY
DIRECTIVE AND CREATION OF AN
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION. THIS IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY. TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE TO BELIEVE THAT
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT AT
EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
CERTAINLY LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHO
TAKEN ALL TO PROTECT AND SERVE
ALL EQUALLY. AND WHO BY VIRTUE
OF THAT OLD ARE GIVEN A LICENSE
TO KILL SO THAT COLLEAGUES I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE I VOTE
FOR AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL- SO
JUST THAT FOR A ROLL CALL SINCE
THEIR FIRST ONE FOR TODAY AND
THE NEED CIRCUMSTANCE THE
SECRETARY OF FIRST CALL THE
ROLL THE MEMBERS WHO ARE.
PRESENT ON THE FLOOR ARE WHO
WILL BE VOTING FROM THE FLOOR
FOLLOWED BY THOSE WHO BE VOTING
REMOTELY WHEN WE DID SWITCH TO
REMOTE VOTING- I WILL AGAIN
NEED TO CONFIRM WE GET BOTH THE
VISUAL WILL NEED YOUR NAME THE
ITEM NUMBER WHICH IN THIS CASE
IS AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
THEN OF COURSE YOUR VOTE. IF I
AS WE DON'T CAPTURE ALL THAT
MAY ASK YOU TO REPEAT TO INSURE
THAT WE CAPTURE ALL ALL THAT
INFORMATION- SO WITH THAT-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
WELL FIVE BRADFORD I DON.
TORONTO FIVE GALGIANI FIVE
PLEASE. GALGIANI I DON'T KNOW
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
HILL HI HUESO. HER TADO. NO
JACKSON I LEYVA. MCGUIRE
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I NIELSEN.
PAN HI HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN I.
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WIENER. FIVE
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE REMOTE
VOTING. SENATOR BASS AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE NOT VOTING THANK
YOU. GORGEOUS REGARDING AB
ELEVEN EIGHT FIVE BORDERS
PRESENT VOTING NO. JUST NOW.
CHIANG CENTER CHIANG AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE NOW CHIANG NO THANK
YOU DALLY. GALLEY LEVIN EIGHTY
FIVE NO. DALLY NO. GROWTH YOUR
GROWTH AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE NO
GROVE NO. MELENDEZ. SENATOR
MELENDEZ AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
NOW MELENDEZ AND NOW. MORLOCK.
SENATOR MORE OCT AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE NOT VOTING. MORALE.
OKAY SEVERAL NEED TO PLEASE
TAKE YOURSELF OFF MUTE PLEASE.
SORRY ABOUT THAT OKAY- SENATE
AROUND. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
VOTING NO MORALE NOW. WILK.
OKAY. I AM GOING TO ASK THAT- I
DON'T PLEASE BE PATIENT AND
MAINTAIN THE DECORUM. WHAT. ALL
RIGHT SIR LOW AT THINK WERE AND
WE IN FOR DO NOT HAVE THE OFF
ME YET.
WE NEED TO BRING YOUR
VISUAL BACK- WE HEARD YOUR
VOICE OKAY CENTER LOOK GUYS
SENATOR WILK EIGHTY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE NO. THANK YOU WILK
NOW AND PER. UNIT LEADER SELF
OFF MUTE SO YOU DON'T NEED
YOURSELF AGAIN IS ALSO QUITE IN
YOUR ROOM. OKAY RIGHT. OKAY SO
WITH THAT WE'RE GOOD CENTER
MITCHELL PUTS THE BILL ON CALL.
YEAH. OKAY SO WE'RE JUST GOING
ONE ROUND AND PUTTING BILLS ON
CALL. OKAY. OKAY RIGHT.
ROBINSON THAT. OKAY WE'RE GOOD
OKAY OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO FOR
ITEM TWENTY TWO S. BRADFORD OR
EVEN TO TAKE THIS MATT UP I
DON'T CENTER BRADFORD AS DESK.
OAY ALL RIGHT LET'S ON OF BUT
THERE IS CENTER BRAD. FOLLOW
NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO. SOURCE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SERVE AFTER
APOLOGIZE AT CIGNA DEGREE
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MARK STONE AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD. HOLD ON
MICROPHONE PLEASE OR CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE BY SOMEONE STONE WILL
AUTHORIZE BE DEFENDED AND THE
DEATH PENALTY CASE TO APPLY FOR
AN ORDER DIRECTING A HEARING TO
DETERMINE IN OUR LUXURY
DISABILITY. OVER THE LAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY HAS MADE VAST
ADVANCES. DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE
YET TO MODERN MODERNIZE OUR
LAWS TO REFLECT THESE ADVANCES
THIS MEANS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
USING UNFAIR AND OUTDATED
STANDARD TWIN DETERMINING. WHO
CAN BE EXECUTED. THIS ALSO
MEANS THAT SOME OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PEOPLE
CURRENTLY ON DEATH ROW. BONTA
LIKELY INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE WILL I'LL
UPDATE THE PENAL CODE TO
REFLECT THE PROGRESS THE
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE.
ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE HAVE IT PROSECUTORS.
FROM ARGUING FOR A PERSON TO
HAVE THEIR I. Q. SCORE INFLATED
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE OR SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS WITH SOMEONE TO
RUN IT THEY FAILED TO DO THAT
WHEN INDIVIDUALS WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE OR GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL THEY ALWAYS FIND THEM.
AN ADEQUATE AND A LOT STRONGER
Q. BUT THEY WANT TO RAISE IT
WHEN IT COMES TO EXECUTING
SOMEONE. IN RESPONSE TO THIS
BILL THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
STATED THAT THEY WILL. NO
LONGER ARGUE TO BUMP UP IQ
SCORES BASED ON RACE. BUT SOME
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE STILL
ARGUING THAT BLACK AND LATINO
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
EXECUTION EVEN WHEN THEY'RE I.
Q. SCORE INDICATES. BABBITT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. THIS
IS BLATANT RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION WE KNOW THAT
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
READY IN THE REPRESENTED IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WE
DO NOT NEED AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
FOR THE DEATH PENALTY. AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE ADOPTS THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY'S DEFINITION
AND UNDERSTANDING. OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY ABILITY
AND WILL PROHIBIT THE
ARTIFICIAL INFLATION OF ICE TO
SCORE TO MAKE PEOPLE OF COLOR
ALL DOUBLE FOR EXECUTION.
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR PLACED A
MORATORIUM ON EXECUTIONS LAST
YEAR PROSECUTORS CONTINUE TO
SEEK. NEW DEATH SENTENCES. THE
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
PEOPLE ON CALIFORNIA'S DEATH
ROW REMAIN UNDER A DEATH
SENTENCE AND ARE IN DANGER OF
EXECUTION IF THIS MORE TERM IS
LOOKED AT IN THE FUTURE. WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THE
DEFINITELY KILLS INNOCENT
PEOPLE AND THAT THE RATIO IN
ECONOMIC DISCRIMINATION HEAVILY
IMPACTS HOW IT IS APPLIED. THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT ANYONE
WITH AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
WHO'S CURRENTLY ON DEATH ROW IS
RESENTENCED AND WILL PROTECT
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES FROM BEING
SENTENCED TO DEATH IN THE
FUTURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE CENTERS ON.
ON THIS MATTER. ANYONE OKAY
RIGHT OKAY SEEING AT NINE. ARE
YOU SAYING NO ONE WITH THE
MAKES RAISED- TO RECORD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST IN
CLOSING JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO. PASS A-
COMPLIMENT TEST TO DETERMINE
THAT YOU'RE NOT SUFFERING FROM
DEMENTIA. DOESN'T MEAN THAT
YOU'RE STABLE JANET GENIUS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD- JUST AS A REMINDER OF
WE WILL BE GOING THROUGH THE
ROLE JUST ONCE- AND THEN
PUTTING BILLS ON CALL- SO WITH
THAT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS. WELL FIVE BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I DODD. HI DURAZO. I
GOT JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I HILL HI
HUESO BY HER TADO. HI JACKSON I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONEY I NIELSEN NO HAN BYE AYE
PORTANTINO I. ROSS. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER
FIVE LAKE COUNTY. HI WIENER
FIVE THANK YOU ARE AT BEST JUST
TAKE A BRIEF HIS CENTER PORGES
KNOWS FOR HIM IS BUT WASN'T
EARLY IS THAT JUST FOR VOTING
OR DO YOU ACTUALIZATION THING.
YES I PUT IT UP I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT ACTUALLY GOT ACTIVATED-
BUT I WOULD THROUGH THE CHAIRED
I WOULD. LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS
OKAY THE PROBLEM IS WE STARTED
THE ROLE IN THE HANDLES AND UP
I DO WANNA BE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A LAG THAT I MISSED.
ON THEIR- BUT WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A ROLL CALL. NO THIS
IS BEFORE THE ROLL CALL. OKAY
SO THE RULING IS THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF A ROLL CALL I WILL
PERMIT AFTER ROLL CALL IT'S
CONCLUDED- YOUR OPPORTUNITY ASK
A QUESTION IN THE AUTHOR
PRESENTER COULD. EITHER ACCEPT
OR DECLINE THAT OFFER I
APOLOGIZE- I IF THERE'S A LAG
ON THE HANDS UP. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
YEAH I MEAN WE WERE TRYING TO I
WAS CHECKING MULTIPLE TIMES SO.
MAYBE WHAT I CAN DO IS IN THE
FUTURE. DON'T WORRY ABOUT ALL
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SAN BUT
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WITH
THIS WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
THIS OUT HERE ALL RIGHTS I DO
OKAY SO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
CONTINUE THE ROLE FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY.
FACE TO FACE AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE. NOT VOTING. FOR JUST.
AB WE WILL TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
WE'RE JUST NOT VOTING. CHIANG
TANG AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE NOT
VOTING. DALLY GALLEY AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE NOT VOTING GROVE.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE NOT
VOTING. MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE NOT LETTING.
MORLOCK ORLOK AB TWENTY BY
TWELVE NOT VOTING. MORALE
MORRELL AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
BILLION. WILK. HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THAT WE CAN'T LET SENATOR WILL
KEEP. SINCE OUR WORKING THIS
OUT WE DO NEED TO HAVE A VISUAL
AND AUDIO CONFIRMATION SO WE'RE
LET'S GIVE OUR FLOOR TEAM A
CHANCE TO WORK IT OUT WITH
CENTER WOKE. YEAH.
I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
CAN YES SIR WILK. CENTER WILL
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE HI. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND WILK HI AND
PERHAPS PLEASE PERHAPS TRYING
NOT TO SEE WE CAN JUST STAY ON
NEEDED ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO WE
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE A
EVERYONE PRESENT SO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL FOR IT. HELLO
EVERYONE M. OKAY PART THANK YOU
SO. AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE ITS
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS NO THE
MEASURE PASSES. OKAY THIS CALL.
YES. THIS IS TRUE YEAH. YEAH
THE NAME ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SO LET'S SAID BEGIN
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
ONE FORTY SIX A TWO ONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. PLEASE
READ SORRY CHECK A PLEASE READ
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
BELLS. 293-222-7520.
1-073-373-2805. NINE OH EIGHT
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE NINE OH FOUR NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN
FOUR
OH EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY THIRTY
EIGHT TWENTY FORTY 251-725-2020 SIX SIXTY
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR.
313-733-7230 THREE SEVENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE THIRTY NINE
ONE SIXTY FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWO TEN
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE TWE 255-930-7330
872-319-1280 ONE. TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR TWENTY NINE SIXTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN
THIRTY THREE S
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY THREE ASSEMBLY VOTE.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
781-161-1320. SEVEN FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
NINETEEN SIXTY
200-620-1320. FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE OH ONE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO.
219-626-0620. SIX SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT OH
NINE. 292-030-4330 533-099-3220.
1-031-766-1940. NINE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE TWENTY FORTY
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR. TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU US ORDERS
OR ANY ITEMS THAT WHICH TO
ANYONE WHICH IS REMOVED FROM
THE SENATE CALENDAR. SEEING
NONE SO ARE YOU SAYING NINE
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE WELL I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I DODD FIVE TERRAZZA I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO HI
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL AYE MONNING
AYE NIELSEN. FIVE TEN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. HI I'M BURKE I
LAKE COUNTY I WIENER I. OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS
VOTING REMOTELY. BATES BATES I
CALENDAR AB TWENTY ONE L.
SEVEN. BATES FIVE. GORGEOUS
WE'RE JUST I CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR JUST FIVE CHIANG. THANK
CALENDAR I'D CHIANG FIVE DALLY.
L. E. AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN HI.
DALLY I. CONFIRMING YOUR FOR
THE ENTIRE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THEIR DOLLY YES OKAY I CAN JUST
REPEAT THAT CENTER DOLLY
CONSENT CALENDAR I. CENTER
DOLLY I ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THANK YOU DALLY HI. GROWTH
SENATOR GROWTH I ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GROVE HI. MELINDA'S.
SENATOR MELENDEZ ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MORLOCK. BORROWER CONSENT
CALENDAR BY MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
MORRELL CONSENT CALENDAR HI
MORALE HIGH WILK. THERE WILL
CONSENT CALENDAR HI WILK HI
EVERYONE. OKAY THAT'S RIGHT
CONSENT CALENDAR IS YES IT'S A
GUY'S THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR IT'S PAST NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE SECOND.
SPECIAL K. RIGHT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. AB TWENTY ONE
OWES SEVEN. NO SORRY. OKAY
MOVING ON TO CONSENT SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER. TWENTY
SEVEN. ARE THERE ANY
EXTRACTIONS ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY NINE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS NINETY
SEVEN ONE OR 711-211-9120 ONE
TWENTY SEVEN AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
SEVEN. OKAY US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL HI
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO. I DODD
FIVE TERRAZZA I GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I
JACKSON I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL HI MONNING I NIELSEN I
CAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN HI I'M
BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
WIENER. FIVE RIGHT NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR REMOTE VOTING. FAITH
BATES CRIED ON SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR BATES HI GORGEOUS.
WE'RE JUST SECULAR KERR
RESOLUTIONS HI LARGEST HI
CHIANG. HEY SPECIAL CONSENT HI
CHIANG HI DALLY. DALLY SPECIAL
CONSENT HI DALLY HI GROWTH.
GROSS SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
BY GROVE HI MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MORLOCK. WARLOCK
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. WELL
MORALE HI WILK. WELL SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR HI WILK HI.
OKAY SO THE VOTE IS THIRTY
EIGHT HIS ZEROS KNOWS THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR TWENTY
SEVEN IS OUT PASSED THANK YOU
MONITORING YEAH. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE NOW WILL
MOVE TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. YES YES. SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
HILL AN ACT RELATING TO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS CENTER HILL THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I AM
OVERJOYED TO BE PRESENT IN SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TODAY FOR A
CONCURRENCE VOTE IT'S BEEN A
LONG EMOTIONAL JOURNEY WORKING
ON THIS POLICY THERE'VE BEEN
MANY JOYFUL VICTORIES PAINFUL
LOSSES AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
TO REACH THIS MOMENT. THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY. WHAT IS KEPT ME
MOTIVATED AND STEADFAST IS THE
FACT THAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT PROTECTING KIDS AND
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY HAS A TARGET
AUDIENCE OVER 90% OF SMOKERS
START BEFORE THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN. AND THE AVERAGE AGE
OF A NEW SMOKER COLLEAGUES IS
THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE. THERE IS
A MOM A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE
DEMONSTRATING FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
INITIATING USE OF NICOTINE USE.
WHAT STANDS OUT THE MOST TO ME
IS THE FACT THAT 80% OF YOUTH
WHO USE TOBACCO IN ANY FORM.
SAY THEY STARTED WITH A
FLAVORED PRODUCT. APPLE IS THE
DEADLIEST PRODUCT ON EARTH AND
WE ALLOW THIS INDUSTRY TO HOOK
KIDS WITH CANDY FLAVORED POISON.
BIG TOBACCO HAS LAUNCHED A
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR CAMPAIGN
TO KILL THIS BILL. SO THEY CAN
KEEP PRAYING ON OUR KIDS YOU'VE
PROBABLY SEEN THE DECEITFUL
TELEVISION ADS INOFFENSIVE MAIL
PIECES. ALL PAID FOR BY ALTRIA
AND RJ REYNOLDS THE TWO LARGEST
TOBACCO COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
BETTER ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
DECEITFUL AND DIVISIVE CLAIMS
FIRST THAT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE DOES NOT PROHIBIT. OR
CRIMINALIZE TOBACCO USER
POSITION IN ANY WAY. THE BILL
ONLY RESTRICTS THE SALE OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
SECOND. YES THIS BILL HAS
EXEMPTIONS AND I WISH IT DID
NOT. BUT IT DOES. MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE THAT I'VE FOUGHT
TOOTH AND NAIL TO ADVANCE THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE FLAVORED
TOBACCO BAN. IT IS A FAR FOR
BIG TOBACCO TO RALLY AGAINST
THE BILL NOW BECAUSE OF
EXEMPTIONS. DO NOT FALL FOR
THEIR TRICKS. SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE IS A LANDMARK PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY AND ESTABLISH A
STRONG FLAVORED TOBACCO
RESTRICTIONS THAT WILL PROTECT.
OUR KIDS. LAST WEEK BIG TOBACCO
IS TRYING TO SCARE YOU INTO
THINKING THIS WILL THIS BILL.
WILL RESULT IN CUTS TO PROGRAMS
FOR YOUTH LIKE FIRST FIVE.
FIRST FIVE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AND
COUNT WITH COUNTLESS OTHER
BENEFICIARIES. OF TOBACCO TAX
REVENUE ARE URGING YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HERE'S WHAT
BIG TOBACCO IS NOT TELLING YOU.
THE SMOKING COSTS CALIFORNIA
OVER THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN HEALTH CARE COSTS. IT
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DIE
EVERY YEAR FROM SMOKING RELATED
ILLNESSES. THAT ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS WE NEED TO BACK UP TAX
REVENUE. IN THE FIRST PLACE IS
BECAUSE OF THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION THAT THEIR PRODUCTS
COLLEGE. SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WILL SAVE LIVES AND BILLIONS IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS. CALLING FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS YOU HAVE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THE SURGES
IN USE NICOTINE USED. AND THE
DANGER TOBACCO USE POSES TO OUR
KIDS. WHETHER IT IS MENTHOL
CIGARETTES. COTTON CANDY BAKED
USE. OR BANANA SMASH CIGARS
THESE PRODUCTS ONLY SERVE TO
NUMB THE HARSHNESS OF TOBACCO
AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR NEW
USERS TO GET ADDICTED TO
NICOTINE. THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
SPENDS MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS
OF LOWERING OUR KIDS.WITH SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE. WE AVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND UP. AND
SAY NO MORE NOT OUR KIDS. I ASK
FOR YOU I COLLEGE. THANK YOU
CENTER HILL- QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS CENTER GLACIER.
OKAY THANK YOU A MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I CERTAINLY RISE TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS- AND THIS
BILL GOES A LONG WAY TO-
PROTECTING OUR KIDS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I WANTED TO APPLY
THE GREAT LEADERSHIP OF THE
SENATORFROM THE PENINSULA I
KNOW THAT HE'S COMING INTO THE
FINAL DAYS OF HIS LEGISLATIVE
CAREER. AND I THINK THIS BILL
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF TAKING ON
TOUGH ISSUES TOUGH FIGHTS IN
AND NOT GIVING UP AND
PERSEVERING AND- I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT TOPIC TO A GREAT
CAREER AND I APPLIED YOU A NEW
LEADERSHIP PLEASE TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORITY ON THIS. CERTAINLY K.
I'VE A. THANK YOU CENTER GO
CENTER RUBIO. BRADFORD YOUR
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE I ALSO RISE TODAY TO
THANK MY OF MY GREAT FRIEND AND
SENATOR FROM SAN MATTEO FOR
BEING A CHAMPION IN THIS SPACE
I'M A PROUD CAUGHT THE REST
WELL AND THIS IS LONG OVERDUE
SO I WANT TO COMMEND MY FRIEND
FOR HIS TENACITY AND NOT GIVING
UP AS HE STATED HE WISHES IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT TOUGHER
BY. THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
MASTER AS I CAN A TASK MYSELF
AS A TEACHER MY FELLOW TEACHERS
WE HAVE WITNESSED OUR STUDENTS
SMOKING IN HALLS CLASSROOMS
LIBRARIES IT IS TIME IT IS TIME
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR STUDENTS
AND I WOULD LOVE TO ONCE AGAIN
ASK EVERYONE. FOR THEIR TITLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND I RISE JUST
EXPRESS SOME FIRST VIDEO OF OUR
CONGRATULATIONS TO MY SEATMATE
FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK AND-
MOVING THIS ISSUE FORWARD. THIS
ISSUE STARTED OUT AS A FLAVORED
VAPE BAND WHICH IS NOT A SINGLE
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
WOULD BE OPPOSED TO THAT BUT IT
HAS MORPHED INTO SOMETHING ELSE
OTHER THAN THAT. AND I COMMEND
THE AUTHOR AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS NOT A SINGLE
PERSON IN HERE WHO WANTS KIDS
TO SMOKE. ANY TYPE OF PRODUCT
BUT THE TRUTH AND THE REALITY
IS THERE'S NOT A SINGLE KID ON
ANY HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS WHAT A
PACK OF CIGARETTES IN THEIR-
POCKET TODAY. THEY ALL HAVE
SOPHISTICATED BAKER HANDS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT. AND SO MY ONLY CONCERN
HERE IS THAT. IT IMPLIES THAT
IF YOU SMOKE MENTHOL YOU'RE NOT
SMART ENOUGH TO MAKE A HOPE
DECISION ON YOUR OWN. BUT IF
YOU SMOKE A CIGAR IF YOU SMOKE
A HOOKAH YOU'RE SMART ENOUGH TO
MAKE THAT DECISION. AND I THINK
THAT'S INSULTING IN AND OF
ITSELF WE SHOULD EITHER BAN ALL
THE PRODUCTS BUT NOT
SELECTIVELY PICK AND CHOOSE
WINNERS AND LOSERS WE SHOULD
INSULT INTELLIGENCE OF PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT CHOOSE TO SMOKE
CIGARETTES I AM ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO SMOKING. MY FATHER
DIED IT'LL BE TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
IN NOVEMBER FROM LUNG CANCER.
BUT HE MADE THE CONSCIOUS
DECISION ON HIS OWN FOURTEEN
YEARS BEFORE HE DIED THE STOP
SMOKING CIGARETTES BECAUSE HE
WAS SMART ENOUGH. TO UNDERSTAND
THE HEALTH IMPLICATIONS OF. IF
YOU CONTINUE TO SMOKE. N.
THAT'S ALL I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HERE IS THAT WE TRUST BULLS
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES. HI ADAM OPPOSE SMOKING
JUST LIKE I AM OPPOSED TO
ABORTIONS BUT I STAND HERE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND I
STAND HERE STRONGLY ITH THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO MAKE A
BETTER DECISION AS TO WHAT THEY
PUT IN THEIR BODY. BUT THIS
PERSONAL CONCERN. I STILL
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BUT I WISH
CIGARETTES SHOULD BE. OUR HOPE
IT SHOULD BE PLACED BACK IN
THIS- BAND AS WELL AS CIGARS
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE A RICH GUY OF
FOUR TO TWELVE DOLLARS CIGAR IT
STATING YOU'RE SMART ENOUGH TO
MAKE THEIR OWN HEALTH DECISIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY GONZALEZ. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- AND I
WANT TO THANK THAT A GREAT
CALLING FROM SILICON VALLEY I
KNOW HE'S WORKED SO VERY HARD
ON THIS AND WE'RE JUST VERY I'M
JUST VERY PROUD PERSONALLY TO
BE ABLE TO SEE A CO SPONSOR AND
CO AUTHOR THIS ITEM WITH YOU- I
DON'T TO SPEAK AS A SENATOR BUT
AS A MOM OF THREE BOYS THREE
LATINO BOYS THAT I REYES AND L.
A. COUNTY. WHERE PERCENT OF
THEIR SCHOOLS ARE PREYED UPON
WHERE RETAIL SHOPS THE BAIT
SHOPS AND TOBACCO SHOP 70% OF
THEM L. A. COUNTY ARE NEAR A
SCHOOL AND SO MUCH OF THIS
INDUSTRY HAS PREYED UPON NOT
ONLY MY CHILDREN BUT OUR
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHILDREN IN L.
A. COUNTY AN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND SO I CANNOT RECOMMEND
YOU ENOUGH FOR PUTTING THIS OUT
AND YOU KNOW CONTINUING TO WORK
TOWARDS A GOOD SOLUTION I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
EVEN AFTER THIS. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I WOULD YEAH I WOULD NOTE THAT
FOR THE PEOPLE PROTESTING
ROUGHLY I DO NOT SEE ANY HANDS
UP SO IF YOU WERE PLAYING THE
SAY SOMETHING JUST WANNA LET
YOU KNOW THAT I'M NOT SEEING
RIGHT NOW. CENTER WIENER. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I ALSO
WANT TO REALLY FROM THE BOTTOM
OF MY HEART THANK THE SENATOR
FROM SAN MATTEO- FOR HIS
PERSISTENCE. ON THIS
LEGISLATION IT'S TAKEN SOME
TIME- BUT HE'S- WERE WERE NEAR
THE FINISH SIZE OF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- ON TONIGHT CITY AND
MOVING THIS FORWARD- THIS IS
ABOUT SAVING LIVES- THESE
PRODUCTS AREKILLING PEOPLE-
AND THEY ARE. BEING
INTENTIONALLY USED TO REJECT
CHILDREN. UNTIL LOWERED
CHILDREN AND- TO REJECT- SO
THAT THEY BUY THESE PRODUCTS
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES-
WITH ALL OF THE HEALTH.
CONSEQUENCES AND THE DEATH THAT
OCCURS BECAUSE OF THESE
PRODUCTS. THESE PRODUCTS HAVE
NO VALUE WHATSOEVER. THEY HAVE
NO VALUE. BUT THEY ARE CREEK
THEY HAVE CREATED FOR SO MANY
YEARS AND ALL OF THEIR
ITERATIONS OF CIGARETTES AND
VAPING. A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND IT'S TIME THAT WE TAKE
AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO ATTACK-
THAT CRISIS WHAT I'D- LIKE TO
SEE HOOKAH AND CIGARS INCLUDING
OF COURSE I WHAT I KNOW THE
AUTHOR WOULD AS WELL. BUT WE
ALL KNOW HOW THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WORKS AND SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T GET A 100% OF WHAT YOU
WANT. BUT THIS BILL GETS THE
LION'S SHARE OF WHAT WE WANT
AND IT WILL SAVE LIVES AND I
WANT TO CLOSE BY SAYS NOTING.
THE DESPICABLE MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN THAT'S BACK ON THE
STREET- INFLICTED ON THIS
LEGISLATURE AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. BY COMPLETELY
MISREPRESENTING WHAT THIS BILL
WAS ABOUT SPENDING I DON'T EVEN
KNOW HOW MUCH. CORPORATE
TOBACCO MONEY. TO TRY TO TRICK
PEOPLE INTO THINKING THAT THIS
BILL WAS SOMEHOW. SOMETHING
OTHER THAN A PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPO. THANK THANK YOU A SCENE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SHROOMS NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WITH THAT CENTER HILL
WHICH IS LIKE THE CLOTHES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE- FOR THE
WONDERFUL COMMENTS AND- AND THE
SUPPORT AND IT WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN POSSIBLE TO ADVANCE THIS
BILL WITHOUT THE HELP OF SO
MANY FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE ADVOCATES THAT POURED
THEIR HEART. AND SOUL INTO THIS
EFFORT. YOUR SUPPORT IS BUILT
WITH SUCH PASSION AND
ENTHUSIASM. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT YOU DID I MUST ALSO
THANK OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND
FOR BEING SUCH CHAMPIONS FOR
OUR KIDS. NEXT I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES IN THIS HOUSE YOU
HEARD FROM SOME OF A FEW
MINUTES AGO. AND TO APPROACH
HIM FOR HER STRONG LEADERSHIP
AND GUIDANCE TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND SIGNED ON AS CO AUTHORS AND
JOIN ME SIDE BY SIDE. TO MY
COLLEAGUES VOTED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THOSE WHO DID
NOT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR CONVERSATION AND
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK IF I COULD
BECOME OUR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY. AT A TIME WHEN
INTER. TENSIONS ARE AT THE
HIGHEST. ASSEMBLY STEPPED UP
AND MADE PROTECTING KIDS A
PRIORITY. TO THE SPEAKER THANK
YOU FOR JOINING AS A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR AND FOR ALWAYS BEING
SUCH A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH TO ASSEMBLY
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
WORDS ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THE FRANKLY LEFT ME SPEECHLESS.
TO ALL FORTY FOUR SEVENTY
MEMBERS THAT SIGNED ON TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR MAKING SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TRULY A
BICAMERAL EFFORT. ESPECIALLY
NEED TO RECOGNIZE AND WANT TO
MY ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES FROM
HEALDSBURG IN SACRAMENTO. YOU
MADE THIS BILL YOUR OWN AND IT
WAS TRULY A JOINT EFFORT THANK
YOU COLLEGE. SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE WOULD BE A HUGE WIN FOR
KIDS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
COLLEGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER HELLO- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. FIVE
BELL FIVE BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
HI DODD. HI TORONTO. HI
GALGIANI. FIVE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON
FIVE LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL I MONEY HI NIELSEN. I
HAN BY FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH
I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER HI STERN I
BURKE I LIKE HOUSEKI FIVE
WIENER. HI. BATES BATES. SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE I'D BATES HI
GORGEOUS. OR JUST SB SEVEN NINE
THREE NOT VOTING. CHIANG CHIANG
SB SEVEN NINE THREE FIVE CHIANG
HI DOLLY. ALI SB SEVEN NINE
THREE FIVE DALLY HIGH GROWTH.
SB SEVEN NINE THREE NOT VOTING.
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB SEVEN
NINE THREE NOT VOTING. MORLOCK
WARLOCK SB SEVEN NINE THREE NOT
VOTE. MORALE ORALITY SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE NOT VOTING. WELL
WILK SB SEVEN NINE THREE HI
WILK HI. OKAY THE BILL HAS
THIRTY FOUR EYES NO NOSE- THE
BILL IS PASSED. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN- BY
SENATOR DODD- SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR DODD AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO INSURANCE. SENATOR
DODD. THANK YOU. START A SECOND
PLEASE READ. THANK YOU VERY.
YEAH SEPARADA AT INSIDE SENATOR
DODD THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB SIX EIGHT SEVEN TWO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS IN PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF INSURED LOSSES
AFTER DECLARED DISASTERS THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU OTHER.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL. OKAY SEEING NONE JUST
WANNA CONFIRM FOR THE REMOTE
MEMBERS SEXY NO HANDS UP. ALL
RIGHT CANTOR DIED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HOLD ON. SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON SENATE
BILL EIGHT SEVENTY TWO ALI
OFTEN SPEAK ABOUT THE COST OF
INSURANCE AND INSURANCE FOR
DEBILITY HOWEVER IT SEEMS LIKE
MANY OF THE BILLS WE TAKE UP
HERE ONLY MAKE INSURANCE MORE
COSTLY EITHER BY EXPANDING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS OR LIKE
THIS BILL INCREASING CLAIMS AND
LOSS EXPENSES THAT END UP
INCREASING PEOPLE'S PREMIUMS I
DID RAISE THIS ISSUE AN
INSURANCE COMMITTEE AND I
WANTED TO RAISE IT AGAIN HERE
TODAY JUST SO IT'S ON THE
RECORD I THINK WE SHOULD
CONSIDER REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. TO PROVIDE A PREMIUM
IMPACT STATEMENT AN ANALYSIS ON
ALL SPONSORED BILLS THAT ARE
NOT TECHNICALLY CLEAN UP WE
CANNOT KEEP OPERATING IN THE
DARK WITH REGARD TO THE IMPACT
ON CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'VE SEEN THIS RASH OF FIRES
IN OUR STATE BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
WHERE WE ALL ASK WHY INSURANCE
HAS GOTTEN SO EXPENSIVE IN
ADDRESS THOSE CORE ISSUES THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND OTHER COMMENTS OR- SEEING
NONE CENTER DOUBLE TO LIKE
CLOSE. I YES WE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION- THIS IS BACK- THE
AMENDMENTS A LINE THAT I
COMPETING PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL IN AB THREE OH ONE TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND LET
BOTH GROUPS TO MOVE TO NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
DODD- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS FIVE TELL. BRADFORD HI
CABRERA HI DODD FIVE TORONTO
FIVE GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HILL HI
HUESO I HER TADO HI JACKSON. I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. HI
MY NAME. HI NIELSEN. I PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. STERN. I NUMBER HI
MY COUNTY I WIENER. HI RIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO A REMOTE
VOTERS. FAITH MONNING BATES NOT
LOADING UP OKAY IT SAID THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO SEVENTY TO SAY YOUR NAME SB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO NONVOTING.
ALL BATES SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
NOT VOTING THANK YOU. GORGEOUS
ORDERS SB EIGHT SEVEN TWO NOT
VOTING. CHIANG CHIANG S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN TWO I'D CHIANG HI
DALLY. DALY AB EIGHT SEVEN TWO
HI SALLY FIVE GROWTH. AB EIGHT
SEVEN TWO NOT VOTING OR TO
CLARIFY THIS IS SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO SO I APOLOGIZE
GROSS SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO NOT
VOTING THANK YOU. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ SB EIGHT FOR ME TO NOT
RUNNING. MORE. WELL I GUESS WE
EIGHT SEVEN TWO NOT VOTING.
MORALE MORALE- SB EIGHT SEVEN
TWO NOT VOTING. WILK WILK SB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO HI WILK HI.
OKAY THOSE THAT ARE DONE UP IN
THIS BILL ON CALL RIGHT. THAT'S
MY MOVE ON NOW TO SO WE'RE JUST
GOING TO DO WHEN ROLE AND THEN
PUT THE BILLS ON CALL- THIS
POINT- SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN- A SEPARATE FOR YOU. TAKE
THIS BILL UP. RIGHT YES SAYS
SIXTY PLEASE CALL PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY. CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
MISTER PRESIDENT I'M SORRY S.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WILL BE
THE FIRST IN INTONATION TO
ALLOW TENANTS AND SUBSIDIZE
MULTI FAMILY UNITS TO HAVE
THEIR CREDIT AND PAYMENT
REPORTED TO A QUICK NATIONAL
CREDIT BUREAU VOLUNTARILY THIS
BILL HAS A SIMPLE GOAL TO
PROVIDE RENTERS WITH AWAY TO
MOVE OUT OF. POVERTY AND
ESTABLISH CREDIT WHICH WE ALL
KNOW IS VITALLY IMPORTANT. TO
DO ANYTHING HERE AND SOCIETY.
OUR BY FOCUSING ON SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING THIS BILL IS TAILORED
FOR THOSE TENANTS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE THE GREATEST BENEFIT.
FROM HAVING A POSITIVE CREDIT
SCORE WE KNOW ALL BIGELOW FAX.
OF REPORTING LATE PAYMENTS AND
THE FAILURE TO PAY YOUR RENT SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATUS
BENEFITS AND HAVE A GREAT
POSITIVE IMPACT FROM. THIS
POSITIVE REPORTING THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY MEASURE. AND
ESPECIALLY NOW WHEN MANY PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING FROM ECONOMIC
COMPLETE- DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
THIS BILL OFFERS A SIMPLE AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO HELP
PEOPLE IMPROVE THEIR CREDIT
SCORES AND IMPROVE HEIR LIVES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SAM BRADFORD
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS- CENTER BOARD YES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THROUGH
HUMANA POSE A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. SIR BRADFORD ARE YOU
WILLING TO ACCEPT THE QUESTION
YES. IT'S CONTINUE THANK YOU MY
QUESTION TO THE AUTHORED IS ON
THE CREDIT REPORT DOES IT
INDICATE. IS THERE A PROVISION
IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE- REQUIRE THE CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCIES ASTERIX OR
GIVE SOME SORT OF INDICATION
THAT THE POSITIVE- CREDIT
CALCULATION FROM THIS TYPE OF-
HOUSING- HISTORY. IS BASED ON-
THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION IN
OTHER WORDS IS A CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCY REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY AND THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING GIVEN A
GIVEN A CREDIT INCREASE. BUT
THAT THE PAYMENTS ARE COMING
FROM A THIRD PARTY LIKE A
SECTION EIGHT OR SOME OTHER
GOVERNMENT ENTITY. NO THE
TENANTS STILL HAS THEIR OWN
OBLIGATION TO PAY A PORTION OF
THAT AND BY DEPENDED ON TIME
GIRLS OF. WHAT MEANS AND THOSE
FINANCES COME FROM THIS CAN IT
STILL WILL BENEFIT DIRECTLY
FROM THAT SO IT'S NO. REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. WELL I THINK I
HAVE TO READ RENEW MY PREVIOUS
CONCERNS I'VE ABSOLUTE RESPECT
FOR THE AUTHOR AND I BELIEVE
THAT THERE. THERE ARE SOME
SOCIAL BENEFITS TO HAVING A
GREATER ACCESS TO A CREDIT
HISTORY. BUT MY INITIAL
REACTION LAST TIME WE DEALT
WITH THIS ISSUE. IS THAT IT
SEEMS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR. TO
THE WORKING POOR. THAT DIDN'T
HAVE THE SAME TYPEOF PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO ITSELF. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD MY CONCERN
THAT. THIS WELL IT'S WELL
INTENTIONED COULD VERY WELL. BE
INSTITUTIONALIZING INFLATION
CREDIT INFLATION TO THE POINT
WHERE THERE MAY BE A SANCTION%
DEGREE OR FRAUD FOR EXAMPLE IF
I AM A LENDER. WHETHER SOMEONE
IS APPLYING TO PURCHASE A CAR
OR TO BUY A- HOUSE AND I GO TO
THE CREDIT REPORTING AGENCY AND
I LOOK AT THIS AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE INFORMATION IS
ACCURATE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS. AND ARE HAVE HAVE
A HISTORY OF PAYMENTS OF THEIR
OBLIGATIONS BUT THAT SECTION
EIGHT OR SOME OTHER ENTITY IS
PAYING FOR THEM ALSO THERE
WASN'T A DISCRETIONARY EVENTS
MEANING THAT THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF THEIR
DOLLARS IF THEY HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO PAY RENT OR NOT
HE RAN THAT WE ARE CREATING A
SEGMENT OF THE CREDIT CHANGE.
THAT MAY ALLOW FOR ESSENTIALLY
SANCTION FRAUD AND THAT IS MY
CONCERN- WHICH IS AMONG OTHERS
EXPRESSED I THINK THE INTENTION
IS GOOD BUT IF WE REALLY WANTED
TO BE HELPFUL TO THE WORKING
POOR- THAT WE WOULD ALLOW THIS
TO APPLY EVERYWHERE- HOLDING
HANDS I. RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT
THOSE OR- SOME OF THE STATE
THANK YOU LETS THEM ON TO
CENTER. FROM SEVERAL SENATOR
MARIA QUESTION THE AUTHOR
PLEASE SAID BEVERLY EXCEPT THE
QUESTION A PLEASE CONTINUE
SEVERAL YEAH I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR ON THIS THIS PROGRAM
GOALS FOR RENTERS NOT ACROSS
THE BOARD BUT ONLY FOR THOSE
WHO- HAVE GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE
IS AT A JUST A CLARIFYING
QUESTION IS THAT CORRECT IT'S
SUBSIDIZED MULTI FAMILY UNITS
OF FIFTY UNITS OR LOS. OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER YEAH I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE VOTE FOR IT YOU
KNOW I ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT THE
DUTY OF THE LEGISLATURE IS-
FAVORITISM TOWARDS NINE. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. IN THIS
IS- FAVORITISM TOWARD SADDAM.
IN NOT OPPORTUNITY FOR OFFICE
ON THAT CASE- ALBIA RESPECTFUL
NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEING NONE A SEPARATE
FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE SUPPORT HERE IN THIS
MEASURE AND ALSO THE QUESTIONS
BUT WE FIND IT SOMEONE ARE
IRONIC THAT. WHEN WE STARTED A
BROADER APPROACH WE HAD PLENTY
PEOPLE SEND ALL KNOW YOU CAN'T
DO THAT YOU CAN'T DO THAT IT'S
UNFAIR THAT WE WHITTLE IT DOWN
TO THE PEOPLE WHO WE FEEL WOULD
BENEFIT THE MOST. AND I WAS
SOMEWHAT ASTOUNDED AT SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION STATING THAT IF
YOU IMPROVE YOUR CREDIT SCORE
THE FIRST THING YOU WANT TO DO.
IS GO BY A STEREO OUR GOAL BY A
CAR MAYBE THEY MIGHT WANT TO GO
BUY A HOME. YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THEY'RE MEMBERS HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT AT ONE
POINT LIVE IN SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING AND THEY NO LONGER LIVE
THERE TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THEIR
CREDIT SCORE AND WE BELIEVE IN
THE AMERICAN DREAM OF BEING
ABLE TO PULL YOURSELF OUT OF
POVERTY THIS IS JUST A SMALL
WAY. IT DEALS WITH BILLS
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN WORRIES ARE
LIVING IN SUBSIDIZED HOUSING.
MULTI FAMILY UNITS A FIFTY YEAR
LOSS AND GIVES THEM OPPORTUNITY.
TO ESTABLISH THEIR CREDIT SCORE
WE KNOW. PEOPLE WHO HAVE IN.
HOUSING FOR TWENTY THIRTY YEARS
AND HAVE PAID THEIR RENT. ON
TIME NEVER MISS THE PAYMENT AND
THEY'VE NEVER RECEIVED ANY
BETTER FROM FROM THIS THIS IS A
SMALL WAY ALONG THOSE FOLKS TO
MOVE THEIR WAY. OUT OF POVERTY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS. WELL
BRADFORD AYE CABRERA I DODD HI
DURAZO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
HUESO. HI TADO HI JACKSON I
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME FIVE NIELSEN. NO PAN
FIVE FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER. HI RIGHT. ATKINS I
HEARD RIGHT OKAY NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS THIS
IS AGAIN S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN SIXTY PLEASE CONTINUE
ROLE. EIGHT EIGHT. BATES SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NOT MONNING.
GORGEOUS LARGES SB ELEVEN FIVE
SEVEN NO FOUR JUST NOW CHIANG.
THANK SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN HI
CHIANG HI DOLLY. L. A. S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
NOT VOTING. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORLOCK. OR OR SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NO MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. MORALE S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN VOTING NO. MORE
MORALE NO WILK. AND WILK SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN NO WILK NOW.
RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
PUTS THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN CERTAINLY VERY
READY TO TAKE THIS UP ALL RIGHT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL IT PLEASE
READ ITEM FIFTEEN. SENATE THREE
TWELVE BY SENATOR LEYVA AN
ACTUAL LEADING TO COSMETICS.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SB THREE TWELVE
REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT APPEAR ON
DESIGNATED AND AUTHORITATIVE
HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL LIST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS BILL SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
YOU ALSO LAST YEAR. THOUSANDS
OF CHEMICALS ARE USED TO CREATE
FRAGRANCES AND FLAVORS THAT
COMPRISE THE BEAUTY AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT WE
USE EVERY DAY. SOME OF THESE
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS RANGING
FROM ALLERGIC REACTIONS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HARM AN INCREASED
RISK OF BREAST CANCER. EXPOSURE
EXPOSURE TO THESE CHEMICALS CAN
ALSO SUPPRESS OUR IMMUNE
SYSTEMS AND COMPRISED
COMPROMISED IMMUNITY WHICH CAN
MAKE INDIVIDUALS MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO NINETEEN. THIS
IS AN ADDITIONAL RISK THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES OF FAMILIES CANNOT
THERE DURING THIS TIME. THIS
BILL HAS STRONG SUPPORT FROM
FIFTY FOUR LEADING NONPROFITS
AND HEALTH GROUPS AND TWENTY
EIGHT BUSINESSES INCLUDING
UNILEVER CLOROX AND PROCTER AND
GAMBLE. SB THREE TWELVE HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. C. NINE I SEE NO
REMOTE NUMBER HANDS UP THIS
TIME. OKAY SAYING NONE- SERRA
LABEL WHICH I LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
pSEEING NO ONE WITH THEIR HANDS
UP THAT'S- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS. BELL
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I DON. HI
TORONTO FIVE GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO
FIVE JACKSON HI LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY.
FIVE NIELSEN. PAN BYE I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER STERN HI NUMBER I LIKE
HOUSEKI I WIENER. HI. ATKINS I
OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
REMOTE VOTERS AGAIN THIS IS S.
B. THREE TWELVE. BATES SB THREE
TWELVE HI. BATES FIVE OR JUST
OR JUST SB THREE TWELVE LIFE
FOR JUST FIVE CHIANG. TANG SB
THREE CALLED LIVE SANG HI DOLLY.
SB THREE TWELVE I DALLY I
GROWTH. SB THREE TWELVE NO
GROWTH NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB
THREE TWELVE I MELINDA'S AYE
MORLOCK. MOORLACH S. B. THREE
ONE TWO HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
SB THREE ONE TWO Y. MORALE I
WILK. WILK S. C. THREE ONE TWO
I WILK HI. THANK YOU US ARE
LEYVA PUTS THE BILL ON CALL.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN OKAY SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ACTUALLY DID TO CONTRACTORS
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH WILL
CLOSE LOOPHOLES IN CURRENT
CONTRACTOR LICENSING PRACTICES
WE TOOK TECHNICAL LIMITS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANNOUNCE THE BILL IS NO
OPPOSITION IS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER REQUIRED TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. OKAY I
DO NOT SEE. THAT THAT'S A
REQUIRE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WHERE IS EXPECTING ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU SAM REQUIRE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
TELL. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
DODD HI DERISIVE HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HI
HELLO I HUESO. HI HER TADO. HI
JACKSON I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN. I
CAN BUY HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH
HI RUBIO I SKINNER STERN HI I'M
BURKE FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WIENER HI OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TOUR VOTE VOTING AGAIN THIS
IS S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE.
EIGHT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE I
BATES. BATES FIVE LARGEST
ORDERS SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE HI
OR JUST FIVE CHIANG. THANK SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE HI CHIANG HI
DOLLY. THE L. A. S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE HI DALLY HIGH
GROWTH. SB. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
NINE. GROVE FIVE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
NINE MELENDEZ HI MORLOCK. IT'S
FEELIN EIGHTY NINE HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE HIGH MORALE HIGH WILL.
WILK SB EIGHTY NINE HI WILK HI.
OKAY THANK YOU- THIS CENTER
MCGUIRE PUTS THE BILL ON CALL
YOU RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE. OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING-
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE. AND I THINK THAT
SAYS CENTER MCGUIRE ARE YOU
READY TO TAKE THAT UP. I DON'T
SEE HIM AS ASK OKAY SO LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR. ENTER WIENER YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THAT BILL UP
OKAY. SECRETASE THESE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY DO THE
CRIMES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. AB ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE IS SPONSORED BY
QUALITY CALIFORNIA- AND IT
SIMPLIFIES THE LAW FOR MANDATED
REPORTERS THE BILL WILL
INCREASE ACCESS AND IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. FOR OUR
YOU. CURRENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR MANDATED
REPORTING OF CHILD ABUSE OR
CONFUSING. INCONSISTENT AND
DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. UNDER CURRENT
LAW TEENS ARE RESTRICTED FROM
TALKING TO A TRUSTED ADULT
ABOUT SEX BECAUSE DEPENDING ON
THEIR AGES AND THAT TYPE OF
SEXUAL OCT THEY MAY BE REPORTED
AS A CHILD ABUSER. OR AS AN
ABUSED PERSON EVEN IF NO ABUSE
OCCURRED. FOR EXAMPLE THIS
MEANS THAT OF A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD THAT'S CLOSEST TO THEIR
THERAPIST OR THEIR TEACHER THAT
THEY HAD CONSENSUAL ORAL SEX
WITH THEIR SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
PARTNER. THE THERAPIST WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO REPORT IT THAT IS
NOT TRUE VAGINAL SEX. TREATING
SPECIFIC SEXUAL BEHAVIOR THAT
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE VOLUNTARY
ENGAGE AND- AS QUORUM COURT
CHILD ABUSE HAS A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE ABILITY OF
COUNSELORS TEACHERS. THERAPISTS
AND OTHER PROFESSIONAL MANDATED
REPORTERS. TO OFFER REPORT
SUPPORT AND COUNSELING TO THEIR
ADOLESCENT CLIENT INDEED IT
SENDS A VERY LOUD MESSAGE TO
TEENAGERS THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
TALK TO TRUSTED ADULTS BECAUSE
THEY MAY GET IN TROUBLE. FOR
TALKING WORK AT THEIR PARTNER
IN TROUBLE. CURRENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS MAKE ARE YOU
VULNERABLE TO PREGNANCY
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
AND OTHER HARM THAT CAN COME
FROM THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT SEX BECAUSE THEY- BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN TRUST- THESE
FOLKS TO TALK TO THEM. BOB
LGBTQ. YOUTH WHO ARE MORE
LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN THE SEXUAL
ACTS ON OF THIS BILL ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED- BY EXISTING LAW.
NUMEROUS MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS NAMI THE
TREVOR PROJECT AND THE NATIONAL
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION HAVE ALL REPORTED
THAT LGBTQ YOUTH ARE TWO TO
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. ON A MUCH HIGHER
RISK OF SUICIDE THAN THEIR NON
LGBTQ PEERS. THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO ALIGN ALL REPORTABLE
SEXUAL ACTS UNDER ONE SIMPLE
CONCISE CRITERIA- THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE. AND THE
BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. SETTERS NAME SAYING I
ALSO NOTE THERE'S NO HANDS UP
REMOTELY AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
OKAY WITH THAT CENTER WINNER
WHICH I'D LIKE TO CLOSE. HER
QUEST FOR AN AYE VOTE. RIGHT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
FIVE WELL. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD. HI DERISIVE I
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TADO. JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN HI I'M BURKE HI
FI KASKI. HI WIENER. FIVE THANK
YOU- LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO A
REMOTE VOTING AGAIN THIS IS AB
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE. EIGHT BATES
LEVIN FORTY FIVE NO BATES NOW
GORGEOUS ORDERS AB ELEMENT WORK
FIVE NO OR JUST NO CHIANG. BANG
AB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE NO CHIANG
NO DALLY. DALY AB ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. AB
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ A LOOK AT
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE NO MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. OR LARGE AB
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE NO MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. WELL A. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE NO WELL NO WILK. AB
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE NOW WILK NOW.
OKAY SO SIR WINNER WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU I NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY LET'S MOVE ON TO-
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY SIX SENATE
MCGUIRE IS NOW AT DESK THEY SEE
IT NOW OKAY- WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT-
SENATE JACKSON NAY PREPARE TO
TAKE THIS UP. ALL RIGHT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I
REMEMBER. TWENTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY SIX SIXTY SIX BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMIT I JUDICIAL. AND
ACTUALLY IN THE JUDICIAL
EMERGENCIES IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES- THIS IS A MEASURE-
THAT ADDRESSES EMERGENCIES SUCH
AS THE COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS
THAT OCCURRED WHEN WE LITERALLY
CLOSE DOWN THE STATE IN ORDER
TO PROTECT AGAINST A PANDEMIC
RESPONSE SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAD
EXPERIENCED THE WATCHING NEW
YORK AND OTHER EAST COAST
STATES- EXPERIENCE. THIS
MEASURE WILL CLARIFY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE CHIEF JUSTICE
OF CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN
HER ROLE AS TEACHER PORTER
PERSON OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES THAT
OCCUR STATEWIDE OR THAT AFFECT
MULTIPLE COUNTIES CURRENTLY
WHEN WE HAVE SUCH AN EMERGENCY
IN ORDER TO AUTHORIZE COUNTIES
TO ENACT. A. AN AUTHORIZATION
HAS TO ISSUE TO EACH COUNTY
INDIVIDUALLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO MAKE ONE
PRONOUNCEMENT THAT WILL ALLOW
COUNTIES THE AUTHORITY TO DO
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY DEEM
IS MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
COUNTY IN THIS CRISIS AND TO
THE IT'S CLEARLY COVERT
NINETEEN- DEMONSTRATED WIDE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM I WAS SO
CUMBERSOME. THERE HAD TO BE A
REQUEST MADE THE CHIEF HAD TO
THEN ISSUE AN INDIVIDUAL THERE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AUTHORIZATION THIS WAY THE
CHIEF SIMPLY AT THE REQUEST THE
COUNTY ISSUES ONE AUTHORIZATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ALLOW
COUNTIES TO DO WHAT THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE PRESIDING JUDGES
BELIEVE IS MOST APPROPRIATE TO
HELP THEM AND WITH THAT- I
WOULD REQUEST FULLY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR J. UNDER
QUESTION ARE DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
SEEING NONE I SEE OKAY CENTER
GROVE
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
PLEASE. CERTAINLY THE QUESTION
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CONTINUE
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT IN YOUR COMMENTS- MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE WOULD BE ABLE TO
JUST- UNILATERALLY MAKE A
DECISION TO ALLOW THE COUNTIES
TO. INDEPENDENTLY DECIDE WHAT
THEIR BEST INTEREST OF THEIR
COUNTY WAS ON THESE PARTICULAR
DECISIONS- WOULD IT BE THE SAME
WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE COULD
UNILATERALLY SAY THE COUNTIES
COULD NOT. PARTICIPATE
INDIVIDUALLY IN THAT SHE WOULD
BE THE- THE FINAL SAY SO WHAT
IT WORK BOTH WAYS AND TO THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. NO OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SAYING NONE I
SEE NO OTHER HANDS UP ON THE
REMOTE VOTING. SENATE JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY YES
AGAIN THIS IS A BILL THAT IS
GOING TO GIVE- GREATER SPEED
AND ALACRITY TO VARIOUS
COUNTIES. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. WHEN WE ARE
FACING A STATE WIDE CRISIS SUCH
AS COVERT NINETEEN AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVAL THANK YOU
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
FIVE WELL. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD. HI THE RAZA.
HI GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WITH SO. I
HER TADO. I JACKSON FIVE LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING. FIVE NIELSEN. PAN BY
FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY KASKI FIVE WIENER. HI
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS AND GETTING THIS
IS EIGHTY THIRTY THREE SIXTY
SIX. EIGHT OKAY SIR BATES
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX NOT
VOTING. GORGEOUS AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX NOT VOTING.
CHIANG. PLAYING AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY SIX NOT VOTING. DALLY
DALLY AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX
NOT VOTING. GROSS AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX NOT BODING.
MELENDEZ. BUT WHEN S. B. I'M
SORRY AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX
MARKETING. MORLOCK AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX NOT VOTING.
MORALE. AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY
SIX NO. MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX HI WILK
HI THANK YOU S. R. JACKSON
PLACES THE BILL ON CALL LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY
NINE CENTER STERN. ARE YOU
READY FOR THAT OKAY A SEPARATE
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
AFTER LEADING TO BUSINESS
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE. WE WE'VE BEEN USING.
SINCE THEY OPERATE CODED AS A
LOT OF APPS TO RECEIVE OUR FOOD
DELIVERIES MORE AND MORE THOSE
OF YOU ORDER FROM RESTAURANTS
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD. I OFTEN
TRY TO USE THESE APPS TO
BENEFIT THOSE LOCAL RESTAURANTS
WHICH WE KNOW WERE. ARE HURTING
AND MANY ACTUALLY WON'T SURVIVE
THIS PANDEMIC- BUT WINDOWS FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICES IN THE
RESTAURANTS INTERACT- WE HAVE
TO HAVE RESTAURANTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CONSENTING TO THAT
INTERACTION THIS BILL REALLY
PUTS A SIMPLE CLARIFICATION IN
LAW THAT THERE HAS TO BE A
FORMAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
THE APT COMPANY AND THE
RESTAURANT BEFORE THEY START
DELIVERING FOOD YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE CONFUSION THAT ARISES WHEN
YOU HAVE DELIVERY SERVICE
PEOPLE ARRIVING AT YOUR DOOR
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF TAKE OUT
BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY PART OF A
BUSINESS OR ALSO IF THINGS GO
WRONG IN THAT INTERACTION THAT.
THE PEOPLE RECEIVING THEIR FOOD
IT'S CALLED THE VIDEO LIKE IF
THEY'RE GONNA DOING THE
BUSINESS- EVEN IF THE BUSINESS
DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
SO FOR THE SAKE OF PROTECTING
YELP REVIEWS EVERYWHERE AND FOR
REALLY HELPING THOSE
RESTAURANTS- GET THEIR FOOTING
NOT JUST THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
WITHIN THEIR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BURGEONING ENTERPRISE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO FOSTER AND DO
MORE OF I THINK. I THINK THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE
LEGAL CERTAINTY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR STERN QUESTIONS OR
DEBATE- CENTER BORCHERS. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- MY MAY POSE A
QUESTION TO THE FLOOR MANAGER
CENTER SERRANO YOU WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE QUESTION OKAY PLEASE
CONTINUE CENTER BORDERS. THANK
YOU WHEN THIS MATTER CAME UP
TO- JUDICIARY- I'D I'D
INDICATED. TO THE AUTHOR THAT I
LEARNED QUITE A BIT ABOUT THIS
I THINK IT IS FAIR THAT IN
AGREEMENT- BE REACHED BETWEEN
THE PARTIES THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE RESTAURANT ESPECIALLY MOM
AND POP. TO KNOW THAT IF
THEY'RE BEING LISTED ON A
WEBSITE LIKE DOOR DASHES CETERA
BUT THEY KNOW BECAUSE SOME OF
THEM HAVE THEIR OWN DELIVERY
DRIVERS AND IT DOES CREATE A
BIT OF CONFUSION SOMETIMES AND
ALSO. THROUGH THE DISCUSSION
WITH THE ALTERED DURING
JUDICIARY- SHE'D INDICATED THAT
PRICES CAN CHANGE IF IT'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE AS OPPOSED TO
JUST THROUGH THE NORMAL
DELIVERY PROCESS I DON'T MEAN
THE DELIVERY CHARGE BUT THE
ACTUAL. THE COULD BE DIFFERENT
AND I THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S
HELPFUL WOMEN IN ASTONISHMENT.
UNDERSTANDS IT'S BEING
ADVERTISED ONLINE SO THAT YOU
CAN ADJUST ACCORDINGLY OR EVEN
OPT OUT OF BEING LISTED ONLINE
SO I THINK THERE'S SOME MERIT
TO THIS. BUT MY QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR IT WAS A LENGTHY
EXCHANGE BACK AND FORTH. TO
WHICH SHE SAID SHE WOULD
PROVIDE AN ANSWER. THE
DEFINITION OF THE FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICE- SERVICE DOES FOOD
DELIVERY BY DEFINITION INCLUDES
SUPERMARKETS. BECAUSE
SUPERMARKETS IN THE CODE ARE
ALSO REFERENCE WITH THE- BY A
DEFINITION AS WELL SO CAN THE
INDIVIDUAL- FLOOR MANAGER OF
THIS HE'S LEGISLATION ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. ALL RIGHT SIR
STERN. I GOING TO DO MY LEVEL
BEST- THE WORD IN THE BILL IS
FOOD FACILITY. AND I AM TRYING
TO PULL UP HERE IN MY NOTES.
MAYBE I CAN POSE A QUESTION
MISTER PRESIDENT TO THE CHAIR
OF JUDICIARY WHETHER OR NOT SHE
RECEIVED AN ANSWER TO THIS
LENGTHY EXCHANGE. WELL CENTER
BURGESS I THINK YOU CANADA
QUESTIONS TO THE FLOOR JACQUI-
BUT- WE'RE NOT TAKING QUESTIONS
TO OTHER MEMBERS OF- ON THE
FLOOR THIS TIME. HERE AN
ACCIDENT SENATE STERN WHICH TO
RESPOND- I'M TO GIVE THIS MY
BEST SHOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTHORS AND SAYING THE
JACQUI HERE SO FOOD FOOD
FACILITIES SUCH AS A GROCERY
STORE THAT IS ACTUALLY
PREPARING. MEALS FOR DELIVERY
TO THE EXTENT A GROCERY STORE
HAS A TO GO- AREA WHERE THEY'RE
MAKING FOOD IN ACTUALLY DOING
RESTAURANT STYLE DELIVERY THAT
PORTION OF THE FOOD FACILITY
WOULD BE COVERED- FOR THIS
SERVICE- SO THAT THAT'S THE
EXTENT OF THE FOOD. FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORM- REACHING
THIS BILL HOPE THAT HELPS
CLARIFY. IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO FOOD IN YOUR GROCERY STORE
YOU'RE NOT COVERED UNDER THIS
SAME FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM
DEFINITION. THANKS TO CENTER
BOARD I THINK SUPER MORE IS
REFERENCED BY. ELSEWHERE I JUST
DID KNOW WHAT THAT MAY MY LOOK
LAST. MY LAST QUESTION ON THIS
IS- THE AGREEMENT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS LEGISLATION IN JUDICIARY
INDICATED THAT AN AGREEMENT CAN
IS GOING TO BE MADE BETWEEN THE
OWNER OF THE RESTAURANT AND THE
PLATFORM AND IT CAN BE AS
SIMPLE AS AN EMAIL INDICATING
APPROVAL THAT THEY BE LISTED
BUT THERE'S NO FORMAL SET OF
FORMS THAT MUST BE EXCHANGED
BETWEEN THE PARTIES IT'S
ENTIRELY UP TO THEM IS THAT
CORRECT. SIR STERN IF YOU WISH
TO ANSWERING WITH CANCER CLOSE
OF THE U. I CAN ANSWER MY
CLOTHES WELL I RECKON I GET A
VERY BRIEFLY DANCERS IS YES.
DOES THE SIMPLE TERMINAL
LEGISLATION IS. AN AGREEMENT SO
IT DOESN'T SAY EXPRESSLY TO BE
A CERTAIN TYPE OF AGREEMENT A
WRITTEN AGREEMENT A VERBAL
AGREEMENT THAT THE SIMPLE
PHRASE IN THE LEGISLATION IS
YOU CANNOT ARRANGE FOR THE
DELIVERY OF AN ORDER FROM A
FOOD FACILITY WITHOUT FIRST
OBTAINING AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
FOOD FACILITY EXPRESSLY
AUTHORIZING THAT PLATFORM. TO
TAKE ORDERS AND DELIVER MEALS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I'LL CLOSE
WITH THIS THAT. I LEARNED A LOT
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION AND I
KNOW A LOT SOME FOLKS IN THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS OR CONCERN
ON WEIRD THIS WILL GO- BUT ON
ITS FACE I THINK THAT THIS IS
A- A REASONABLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO CREATE A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE RESTAURANTS. AND IT
THERE ARE THE FOOD SUPPLIERS
AND PLATFORM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER VERSUS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER. SENATE JACKSON. THANK
YOU- MISTER PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO. UNCOMPLICATE THIS
BASICALLY IF YOU ARE A FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICE AND YOU ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF A
RESTAURANT THAT IS PREPARING
FOOD. YOU HAVE TO LET THE
RESTAURANT KNOW AND YOU HAVE TO
HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH THEM SO
THAT THE RESTAURANT WHICH IS
THE ONE THAT IS GOING TO SUFFER
FROM YOUR- INADEQUATE- RESPONSE
AS A DELIVER. OR NEEDS TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY MEALS IT'S
SUPPOSED TO PREPARE AND FRANKLY
A LOT OF THE TIMES WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS THAT THE
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE DOING THE
LION'S SHARE THE WORK MAKE VERY
LITTLE MONEY BECAUSE MOST OF IT
IS GOING TO THE DELIVERY
SERVICE. ARE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
NEGOTIATE AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THEMSELVES. ME THIS IS BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL BUSINESS FAIRNESS
WHICH I WOULD ASSUME ARE. GOOD
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE WOULD SUPPORT. OUR
RESTAURANTS TODAY ARE SUFFERING
TREMENDOUSLY THE WORKING HARDER
AND HARDER FOR LESS AND LESS
PROFIT. AND THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT'S GOING TO AT LEAST ALLOW
THEM TO NEGOTIATE WITH THOSE
WHO ARE FRANKLY MAKING MOST OF
THE PROFIT. SO THAT THERE IS A
FAIR DISTRIBUTION- AND
CERTAINLY A FAIR KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON AND THAT
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU SIR JACKSON ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR DEBATE SEEING NONE
I SEE NO HANDS UP ON THE REMOTE
NOW. A CENTER STERN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND APOLOGIES
FOR NOT HAVING. A VILLAGE TEXT
AT THE READY BUT I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION FROM THE CENTER
FROM FRESNO AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'VE GOT A- UNIQUE-
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR SOME
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR. HELP
PLEASE A MEASURE THAT
STRENGTHENS BOTH LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY ECONOMY AT THE SAME
TIME. THANKS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I FELL. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD. FIVE DERISIVE
HI GALGIANI. I. OKAY WE HAD A
LITTLE TECHNICAL ISSUES SO
LET'S WE'RE GOING TO REDO THE
ROLE START FROM THE BEGINNING
AGAIN RIGHT- SO APOLOGIES FOR
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. THIS YEAR HERE
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FELT.
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I DODD
HI DURAZO. HI GALGIANI. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. HILL I
HUESO. HER TADO. HI HUESO HI.
JACKSON I LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. FIVE ONE NINE. I
NIELSEN. PAN HI I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN
HI I'M BURGER. WHITE HOUSE SKI
I WIENER BY OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO A REMOTE MEMBERS THIS IS
AGAIN AB. TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE. BATES AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE HI. BATES HI. FOR JUST.
FORGES AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE
ALL RIGHT HI CHIANG. GETTING AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE I CHIANG
HI DOLLY. KELLY AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE HI DALLY HI GROWTH.
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE NINE
GROVE HI MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE NOW.
MELENDEZ NO MORLOCK. AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE I WARLOCK BY
MERLE. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE
NO. L. NO WILK. WILK AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE HI WILK HI. OKAY.
THE CENTER STERN PUTS THE BILL
ON CALL. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY- CEREMONY
PREPARED ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ONE MEMBER WICKS
AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
ACTIONS CEREMONY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS WITH THE
INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS EMERGING FROM
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY ALREADY BE
IN DEBT ARE LIKELY TO FIND
THEMSELVES IN EVEN GREATER
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AS A RESULT
OF OUR CURRENT RECESSION SOME
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS AND%
HOMEOWNERS MAY BE FACING THE
THREAT OF LOSING THEIR HOMES
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER RECENTLY COMPLETED A
REPORT THAT INVESTIGATED. WHERE
CREDITORS HAVE BEEN SEEKING TO
FORECLOSE UPON HOMES FOR SMALL
AMOUNTS OF CONSUMER DEBT THIS
PRACTICE OF FORCED HOME SALES
BASED ON SMALL AMOUNTS OF
CONSUMER DEBT IS PROBLEMATIC
AND EXACERBATES EXISTING
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA. IN PARTICULAR
THIS PRACTICE HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE WILL
ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT LOSE THEIR HOME SAYS
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO PAY DEBTS
IN WILL PREVENT FORECLOSURES ON
A PERSON'S PRINCIPAL PLACE OF
RESIDENCE RESIDENTS. IF THE
CONSUMER DEBT IS NOT TIED TO
THEIR HOME AS CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY WE NEED
TO TAKE STEPS TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE BY ENSURING THAT
THOSE WHO ARE FACING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP CAN KEEP THEIR HOMES
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CEREMONIES THEIR DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE. SEEING NO ONE I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP FROM THE ROOM
MEMBERS. WITH THAT THE CEREMONY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
MINING- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS. WELL BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I DODD. FIVE THE RAZA.
FIVE GALGIANI. I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON I LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL. FIVE MONEY I NIELSEN
I PAN FIVE FIVE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
STERN HI NUMBER WHITE HOUSE HE
FIVE WIENER. OKAY LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO A REMOTE MEMBERS-
THE MEASURES AB. TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE. BATES AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE HI. BATES I
BORJAS WE'RE JUST AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE OF SEVENTY.
CHIANG HEY AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE I'D CHIANG AYE DALLY.
BALLY AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE I DALY I GROW. GROCERY
GROWTH AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE ABSTAINED. MELINDA'S
MELENDEZ AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE I'M STAYING. MORLOCK
MOORLACH AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
AB AT TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE
STAY THAT'S OUR MORALE I DO
NEED YOU TO SAY YOUR NAME AND
THEN THE MEASURE SORRY COLLEGE
ICE I THOUGHT I SAID MORALE I
APOLOGIZE- MORALE A. B. TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE ABSTAINED.
THANK YOU WILK. WILK AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE HI WILK HI.
THANK YOU- CENTER REMORA CENTER
MINING PUTS THE BILL ON CALL.
BATES MOVE ONTO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY ONE SIR HERTZBERG YOU
PREPARED. RIGHT THE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMóN AND ACTUALLY INTO
OIL AND GAS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT. FOR THIS
MEASURE INCREASES CRIMINAL
PENALTIES LOS ANGELES INCREASES
PEDAL OF CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
OIL SPILLS INTO WATERS OF THE
STATE. BY THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR OIL SPILLS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES A MAJOR OIL SPILLS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE MEANINGFUL
DETERRENCE FOR ESPECIALLY BAD
ACTORS THIS INCREASES THE BASE
FILES FOR INFLATION WILL ALSO
GIVE COURTS DISK TO ADD
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES IF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE ALTHOUGH
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION IS RARE.
IT IS INDEED AN INTEGRAL PART.
THAT WHEN THESE ESPECIALLY
EGREGIOUS CASES ARISE THAT OUR
COURTS ARE GIVEN THE ABILITY TO
IMPOSE ADEQUATE PENALTIES I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG IS THERE
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. SEEING
NINE I SEE NO HANDS UP FOR
REMOTE MEMBERS. RIGHT WITH THAT
SIR HERTZBERG WHICH I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE BROUGH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SIR HERTZBERG-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OUR I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
BELL BRADFORD. CABALLERO I DODD
I THE RUSSELL I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO
HI JACKSON I LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE. AYE MITCHELL. HI MOM
NAME I NIELSEN. NO HAN HI I
PORTANTINO NEW HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER KERN I AM
BURKE. BY CASKEY FIVE WIENER HI
LET'S MOVE ON TO A REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS IT SKIN THIS IS
BILL AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN.
FAKES. EIGHT EIGHTY SB THIRTY
TWO FOURTEEN NO EIGHT NOW FOR
JUST ORDERS AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN NOW BARGES NO CHIANG.
AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN NOW
SANCHI BROWN ACTUALLY DO NEED
YOU TO SAY YOUR NAME FIRST THEN
GO BACK TO CHANGE. CHIEF
POLITICS IT IS WHAT WE HEAR
AROUND US AND SO SORRY. CHENEY
AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN NOW
THANK YOU CHIANG NOW DALLY.
DALY AB THREE TO FOURTEEN NO
DALLY NOW ROSE. AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN NOW GROVENO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB THIRTY TWO
PORTANTINO. MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOST. AB THREE TO FOURTEEN NO
MOORLACH NO MORALE. MORRELL AB
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN NOW. MORALE
NO WAY. WILK AB THIRTY TWO FOUR
NOW WELL NO. GALGIANI I DON'T
KNOW. HURTADO DON'T KNOW. UNDER
ANY OTHER OKAY SEEING NONE
CENTER HERTZBERG PUTS THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY. THE.
YEAH. ONE OF THE- OKAY SO FIRST
OF ALL AS CENTER BEATS WE WANT
TO CONFIRMATION ON YOUR VOTE SO
CENTER BASIS IS AGAIN AB.
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN. AB THIRTY
TWO FOURTEEN BATES NO. OKAY AND
THEN WHO'S THE OTHER COVERAGES
EIGHT NOW AND THEIR PORCHES. WE
JUST NEED A CONFIRMATION AGAIN
OF YOUR VOTE ON EIGHTY THREE TO
FOURTEEN. OR JUST AB THIRTY TWO
FORTINO ARE JUST NOW. OKAY
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA NOW
CENTER HERTZBERG PLACES THE
BILL ON CALL AGAIN APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE RIGHT LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
TWO US HERTZBERG WE PREPARE
GREEN THAT UP. ALL RIGHT US
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
AFTER LEADING TO ELECTIONS.
RIGHT SIR HERTZBERG THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- IS THIS BODY
IS WELL AWARE SOME WEEKS AGO WE
PASSED IN CA SIX ON A
BIPARTISAN VOTE IN BOTH HOUSES.
AND IS NOW AND. THIS MEASURE
NOW WAS ON THE BALLOT AS PER
SEVENTY. YOU HAVE YOU IN AB SIX
SO UPDATES RELEVANT CALIFORNIA
ELECTION CODE PROVISIONS. TO
RELAX TO REFLECT THE CHANGES IN
VOTER ELIGIBILITY SHOULD PROP
SEVENTEEN PASS THIS NOVEMBER I
ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR HERTZBERG DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. CAN SEEING NINE I SEE
NO HANDS UP FOR THE REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS. OKAY WITH THAT
SIR HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. CASTRONOVO THANK YOU
THANK YOU US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. WELL
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO FIVE DODD.
HI DERISIVE. I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI HILL FIVE WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. NO JACKSON I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY.
FIVE NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER STERN HI I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WIENER I
HEY LET NOW WE'RE MOVE ON TO
OUR OF THE VOTING THIS IS AGAIN.
FOR EIGHTY SIX FOUR SIX COULD
PLEASE CONTINUE TO ROLL. BATES
AIDS SB SIX FOUR SIX AND NO. NO
GORGEOUS OR JUST EIGHTY SIX
FOUR SIX NOW FOR JUST NO CHIANG.
THANK AB SIX FOUR SIX NO CHANGE
NO DALLY. AB SIX FOUR SIX NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB SIX FOUR
SIX NOW GROVE NO MELENDEZ. WE
NEED TO OFF MUTE SERMON LONDIS.
AND YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
OKAY MELENDEZ AB SIX FOUR SIX
NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. HOLD
ON. OKAY YEAH WE HAVE MORALE ON
RIGHT NOW OKAY MOORLACH.
MOORLACH A. B. SIX FOUR SIX NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. MORRELL AB
SIX FOUR SIX NOW. MORALE NO
WILK. AB SIX FOUR SIX HI WILK
HI GOOD THANK YOU SEARCH THE
BILL ON CALL LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE-
SIR WIENER YOU PREPARED RIGHT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME LONGER AN
ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES. CENTER WIENER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT CALLING SO I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE SUMMER CALLED
LONGER- IS THE CRISES ACTS-
WILL STOP WAS A PILOT PROGRAM
THE SCALE OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS FIRST
RESPONDERS. INTERACTIONS WITH
POLICE CAN BE SCARY FOR MANY
PEOPLE PEOPLE WITH IMMIGRATION
STATUS CONCERNS. BOTH SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK AND OTHER
PEOPLE HISTORICALLY TRAUMATIZED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. THESE
INTERACTIONS CAN BE DEADLY.
OKTAN HALL THE MOTHERS OF THE
MOTHER OF MILES HALL OF LIKE
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD WALNUT
CREEK RESIDENT WHO WAS KILLED A
YEAR AGO. DURING A SCHIZO
AFFECTIVE DISORDER INDUCED
CRISIS. SAYS THAT IF THIS BILL
EXISTED A YEAR AGO HER SON
MIGHT BE ALIVE. POLICE VIOLENCE
IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
FOR YOUNG BLACK MEN POLICE KILL
PEOPLE WITH UNTREATED MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. SUCH AS
SCHIZOPHRENIA SIXTEEN TIMES
MORE OFTEN THAN PEOPLE WITHOUT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. IN CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUCCESSFULLY
RESPONDING TO SITUATIONS.
INVOLVING ON HEALTH PEOPLE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS PEOPLE EXPOSED TO
VIOLENCE PEOPLE EXPERIENCES
EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE USE AND
OTHER ISSUES. DESPITE THE
POSITIVE IMPACT AND COST
SAVINGS. OF COMMUNITY ORIENTED
AND NON POLICE RESPONSE TO
THESE EMERGENCIES. CALIFORNIA
HAS DONE LITTLE TO SUPPORT AND
SCALE UP THESE EFFORTS. INSTEAD
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES THAT ARE
BETTER SUITED TO PEER SUPPORT
EXPERTS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS WERE CRISIS
COUNSELORS WHO ARE TRAINED TO
THE US AND RESOLVE CRISES.
THESE KINDS OF SERVICES NEED TO
BE PART OF THE WEB OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE NETWORKS AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR MARSHALS AN ARRAY OF
CREDIBLE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT ARE QUICK
TO STEP IN AS FIRST RESPONDERS
EXPANDING THE ROLE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS DOES NOT MEAN
ELIMINATING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
EXPANDING THE ROLE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS EMPOWERS GROUPS THAT
HAVE A DEMONSTRATED TRACK
RECORD THEY CAN PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT GUNS.
OFFERING THE POLICE TO FOCUS ON
ISSUES MORE SUITED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING- THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR WIENER
AS THEIR DEBATE ON THIS MATTER.
H. SEEN NONE I SEE NO HANDS UP
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. I NEED
THE MISSING ONE- OKAY SIR
WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
S. ARRIVAL. I THANK YOU. ANYONE.
NONWHITE SPEAKERS OKAY I THANK
YOU SEVERAL SIX EIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. WELL BRADFORD I HAVE
ITEM FIVE DODD. FIVE THEY'RE
AWESOME. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON.
I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
HI MY NAME. I NIELSEN. I PAN BY
FIVE PORTANTINO BY ROSS I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. STERN BOMBERG. BY
CAL SKI FIVE WIENER HI OKAY
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR OF
VOTE VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR SEPARATE
PLEASE CONTINUE ROLE. BATES
THANKS AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
PRIME. HI GORGEOUS WE'RE JUST
EIGHTY TWENTY FIFTY FOUR I FOR
JUST FIVE CHIANG. THANK AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR I CHANG AYE
DELHI. AB. TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
NOT AT STATE. GROVE. AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR HI GROVER AYE
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR ABSTAINED. MORLOCK
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE WELL AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR NOW. MORALIS SO WILK.
WELL WILK AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
HI WILK HI. OKAY. NIELSEN I TO
KNOW. NIELSEN I TO KNOW. RIGHT
THAT- CENTER WIENER PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR-
SENATE JACKSON YOU'RE PREPARED
TO PRESENT. ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND AND
ACTUALLY DID TO FIREARMS SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THIS MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON WILL
PROTECT COMMUNITIES BY
PROVIDING GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
OVER FIREARM DEALERS AMMUNITION
VENDORS OR MANUFACTURERS
PARTICIPATING ATGUN SHOWS. AS
THE COLD WIND PANDEMIC
CONTINUES TO UP IN COUNTLESS
FACETS OF AMERICAN LIFE DEMAND
FOR GUNS AND AMMUNITIONS HAS
INCREASED ACROSS THE NATION
UNDERSCORING THE IMPORTANCE OF
TAKING ACTION TO PREVENT
INNUMERABLE FUTURE TRAGEDIES.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INSPECT FIREARMSDEALERS
AMMUNITION VENDORS OR
MANUFACTURERS PARTICIPATING IN
A GUN SHOW OR EVENT IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT ALL TRANSFERS OR
SALES ARE CONDUCTED IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE APPLICABLES
STATE AND LOCAL ARE UP LAWS
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE DOJ TO
INSPECT THE RECORDS OF SOME
FIREARM DEALERS. AND AMMUNITION
VENDORS AT GUN SHOWS BUT NOT
ALL FOR EXAMPLE THE DOJ LAX
INSPECTION AUTHORITY OVER
VENDORS WHO HOLD FEDERAL
FIREARMS LICENSES BUT NOT ARE
NOT A REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
CALIFORNIA LICENSES THIS
MEASURE WILL CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION VENDORS
CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE ABIDING BY THE
SAME RULES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
ARE THERE IS THERE DEBATE ON.
THIS ISSUE. CENTER GROVE I
THOUGHT YOU HAD YOUR HAND UP
IT'S MY CONFIRM THAT DID YOU
WANNA SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE. OKAY
I DON'T. GO AHEAD THIRTY GROWTH
CAN I JUST CONFIRM THAT TO YOU
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS
ISSUE OR NOT I TOLD HIM MR
PRESIDENT YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU IT'S ON THE STREET IN THIS
YEAR OTHER AT OTHER ANY MOVE
THAT MEMBERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK.
SAY NONE. SENATE JACKSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BELL
BRADFORD. FIVE CABALLERO HI
DODD. HI TERRORIZER. FIVE
GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HELLO AYE HUESO I
HER TADO. HI JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL. FIVE ONE
NINE FIVE NIELSEN. NO HAN HI
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH. RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. STERN NUMBER.
THANK HOUSEKI I WIENER HI RIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO A REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS AGAIN.
EIGHTY TWENTY SIXTY ONE SIXTY
PLEASE CONTINUE TO ROLL. FACE
THANKS AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS ORDERS AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE OF STAYING.
J. CENTER CHANGES PLEASE CHIANG
STARS CHIANG AB TWENTY SIXTY
ONE NO THANK YOU CHIANG NO
DALLY. SALLY AB TWENTY SIXTY
ONE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE
ABSTAINED. MORALE. SEVERAL I
THINK IS THE ONE USED. ONE OF
AGAIN OKAY HOW MY THEIR OKAY
AROUND EIGHTY TWENTY SIXTY ONE.
HELLO MORRELL NO WILK. WILK AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE NO. WILK NO
ALL RIGHT SIR JACKSON PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL RIGHT. FIXED ITEMS
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY SIX SEVERAL
WHAT KOWSKI LOBBY PREPARED TO
PRESENT ALL RIGHT- SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY IT INTO DRINKING WATER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AB TWO
TWO NINE SIX WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING STABILIZATION
FOR THESE SMALL DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS WITH LOCAL OVERSIGHT
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE
SEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
ABOUT SIX LOCAL WATER SYSTEMS
COUNTY HAVE HAVE RELINQUISHED
THEIR CONTROL OF THE SYSTEMS
AND BROUGHT GIVEN THEM BACK TO
THE STATE. JUST RECENTLY- EARLY
THIS MONTH AMADOR COUNTY BECAME
THE LATEST IN THE SERIES OF-
COUNTIES TO DEFINE THESE LOCAL
PROGRAM SO THIS. STABILISATION
MONEY WILL PROVIDE MORE THE
SMALL SYSTEM TO A RISK OF-
SURROUNDING THE OVERSIGHT BACK
TO THE STATE TO COMPLY WITH
SAFE DRINKING WATER LAWS AND
WITH THAT WITH US AND I BOTH
THANK YOU SARAH CASKEY IS OUR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. OKAY
SEEING NONE I SEE NO HANDS UP
FOR A REMOTE MEMBERS. WITH THAT
S. ZERO CASKEY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. HIGHER CHEN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SARAH CASKEY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS. WELL
I BRADFORD. I HAVE A I DODD. HI
THE RYZEN. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. HI WESA. I
HER TADO HI JACKSON. I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL I MONEY I
NIELSEN NO PAN HI I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER.
STERN AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. HI THERE LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO A REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS-
THIS IS EIGHTY. TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX- SECTOR PLEASE
CONTINUE TO ROLL. EIGHT MAKES
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX NO
BATES NO GORGEOUS. ORDERS AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX NO PORGES
NO CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX NO CHIANG NO DALLY.
DALY AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX
I'M STATE. GROVE. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
BORDERLINE AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX DISNEY NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY SIX NO MORALE NO
WILK WILK AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX NO WILK NOW. OKAY SARAH
CASKEY PLACES THE BILL ON CALL
K. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN SIR MITCHELL YOU
HEARD THAT RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY WOULD ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
INCREASING PREVALENCE OF MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS BY REQUIRING
HEALTH PLANS TO DEVELOP A
DOCTOR TO DOCTOR TELEHEALTH
CONSULTATION LINE THE SUPPORT
PROVIDERS IN BUILDING THEIR
CAPACITY TO DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ONE IN
FIVE WOMEN WILL BE AFFECTED BY
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER DURING
PREGNANCY OR WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR GIVING BIRTH AND THE
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS IN CHILDREN HAS BEEN
INCREASING. EVEN BEFORE COLBERT
NINETEEN CRISIS THERE WERE GAPS
IN DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT OF
THESE DISORDERS AND A SHORTAGE
OF PROVIDERS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE. NOW MENTAL HEALTH
RISK FACTORS ARE BEING
COMPOUNDED AND INTENSIFIED TO
THE HEALTHCARE CONCERNS
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY AND SOCIAL
ISOLATION. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY OFFER AN
AYE VOTE FOR AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY. THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL
IS THERE DEBATE ON THIS MATTER.
SEE THERE'S NO HANDS UP BEFORE
REMOTE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NONE A SURVEY TO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. WELL FIVE BRADFORD I
HAVE I EVER. FIVE DODD. FIVE
THE RAZA. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON
AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
FIVE MONEY. FIVE NIELSEN. PAN
HI FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER STERN AMBERG
WHY CAL SKI I WIENER HI SURGERY
CAN BE JUST RECHECK THE ROLE
FIRST CENTER NIELSEN I THOUGHT
I CAST A VOTE. NIELSEN NIELSEN
NOW. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO A
REMOTE MEMBERS- AGAIN THIS IS
AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX THREE
PLEASE CONTINUE ROLE. VERDADES.
BATES. THIRTY THREE SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE SIXTY. I APOLOGIZE
IT IS TWENTY THREE SIXTY MY
ERROR THANK YOU CENTER BATES
FOR CORRECTING ME. I THOUGHT I
LOST PLEASE. BATES AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT NO. BATES NOW
PORGES. ORDERS AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY NOW FOR JUST NO CHIANG.
J. A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY HI.
TRANG I. DALLY DALY AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY OF STATE. GROSS AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NO GROVE NO.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ABSTAINED. MORALE.
MORRELL AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NO MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY HI WILK HI.
THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL PLACE
THE BILL ON CALL. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT CENTER PORTANTINO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT CASES THAT
A SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAN AN ACT RELATING
TO COUNTY JAILS. CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY.
REBEKAH BAUR QUE HAN- THAT WILL
REQUIRE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
STATEWIDE TO COMPILE AND SUBMIT
A DATA ON THE OFFENDER
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS PROVIDED TO
INMATES IN COUNTY JAILS AND THE
SUCCESS RATES IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM WE ALL WANT THESE
PROGRAMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND
THIS IS A PRUDENT MEASURE TO
MEASURE THE SUCCESS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS EACH YEAR REALIGNMENT
WAS ENACTED APPROPRIATIONS IN
THE GENERAL STATE BUDGET HAVE
PROVIDED MONEY FOR COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT DIVERSE APPROACHES
FOR SUPERVISION AND
REHABILITATION THAT REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. THE APPROACHES AND
CORRESPONDING SPENDING PLANS
ARE CREATED BY EACH COUNTY'S
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIP. THE CCP'S ARE MADE
UP OF THE CHIEFS OF PROBATION
SHERIFF'S D. A.'S PD AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE COMMUNITY
A STANDARDIZED LOOK AT SHARES
PROGRAMS WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF THESE REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT EFFORTS TO MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS SUFFICIENT AND
PRODUCTIVE- THE STATISTICAL
INFORMATION COLLECTED AND
SHARED BY COUNTY'S INSURERS
WILL GIVE US THE TOOLS TO MAKE
LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS. THAT
MAINTAIN PUBLIC SAFETY REDUCE
THE SIZE OF OUR INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND REDUCE COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IBM.
THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO'S.
THEIR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR AND MAY SUPPORT YOU
KNOW WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION. OKAY SEVERAL
INDUSTRIES CONTINUE I THANK YOU
I JUST NOTICING AND THIS BILL
IT DOESN'T APPEAR THERE'S ANY
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR THE. TASK
THAT ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
LIKELY THEY ARE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPILE THIS DATA WHICH COULD
BE VERY- CUMBERSOME TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
THAT WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO DO THAT I WONDER IF
THE AUTHOR COULD ADDRESS THAT.
SERVER TINA OBVIOUSLY- WHEN YOU
CREATE NEW PROGRAMS YOU WANT TO
BE PART OF THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION AND SO THIS IS A
CHANCE TO PUT A GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY. FORWARD BY THIS BODY
AND HOPEFULLY ON THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK IS IT GOES BACK TO THE
ASSEMBLY I CONCURRENCE. AND
THEN IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PART OF THE BUDGET DISCUSSION-
GOING FORWARD. AND ALSO SENDS A
MESSAGE TO OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.
OF THE LEGISLATURE SERIOUS IN
ONE OVERSIGHT WANT TO GET OUT
ONSETS OF. DURING A PANDEMIC AS
YOU KNOW WE ARE FACING
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET
SHORTFALLS. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- YOU KNOW BUDGET
ACCORDING TO A SOUND PROCESS
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE OUR
BUDGET. DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR OFTENTIMES TO PASS
LEGISLATION AND THEN WE COME
BACK THE NEXT YEAR AND FUND IT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE. THE WASHINGTON YOU CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
OF CENTER NIELSEN. PRESIDENT
AND I WILL URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS HERE AGAIN WE'RE IMPOSING
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHICH WE
GOT NAY NO CHOIR THE STATE TO
DO FOR DECADES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION THAT IS TRACKED
THE. SUCCESS AND EFFICACY OF
ANY. AND IN COMMUNITY TREATMENT.
THE ONLY THING WITH DONE UNDER
LINE. TO BE JUST SAT. AS THE
BOARD OF CORRECTION SEVERAL
YEARS AGO REDEFINED RECIDIVISM.
SO THAT THEY COULD INDICATE TO
THE PUBLIC THAT RECIDIVISM HAD
DECREASED NOT BECAUSE IT HAD
DECREASED BUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
REDEFINED THAT TERM. AGAIN
WE'RE IMPOSING ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DON'T EVEN ABIDE
WITH HERE AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE. GENOVA
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. OKAY
SAYING NONE SEEN NO FOR THEIR
HANDS UP IN THE REMOTE VOTING
THERE PORTANTINO WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR
PORTANTINO- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. WELL FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD. FIVE DURAZO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. JACKSON FIVE LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL HI MY NAME. I
NIELSEN NO HAN HI I PORTANTINO
ON I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER.
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. HI Q. LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO A REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS-
THIS IS AGAIN AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE SECRETARIES
CONTINUE TO ROLL. FACE. BATES
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE NO.
FACE NO CHARGES. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE. ABSTAINED CHIANG.
THANK AB. TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE FIVE CHIANG HI DOLLY. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE NOW MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE HI WARLOCK HIGH
MORALE. MORRELL AB TWENTY FOUR
SORRY EIGHTY THREE IS AN L.
NINETY MORALE NO WILK. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE HI
WILK HI. SIR PORTANTINO PLACE
THE BILL ON CALL. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE.
PERCENT ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS CENTER
WIENER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TO RISE TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU. AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
UNSAFE HANDGUN ACT IN TWO
RESPECTS. FIRST IT WILL ASSIST
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SOLVING GUN
RELATED CRIMES BY EASING THE
MANUFACTURER REQUIREMENTS FOR
MICROSEMI I WILL INCENTIVIZE
MANUFACTURERS TO PRODUCE GUN
MODELS WITH MICROCENTER A
TECHNOLOGY. MICRO STABBING AS A
CRIME SOLVING TOOL THAT
IMPRINTS ARE UNIQUE STAMP ON A
CASE WHEN A THIS FIRE. ALLOWING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO LINKED
CASINGS TO SPECIFIC GUNS. A
SECOND AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF ACCIDENTAL
GUN DEATHS AND INJURIES BY
ENSURING THAT ANY FIREARM ANY
NEW FIREARMS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
HAS A CHAMBER LOAD INDICATOR TO
SIGNIFY WHEN A FIRE ARM IS
LOADED. AT A MAGAZINE
DISCONNECT MECHANISM TO PREVENT
A GUN FROM FIRING WANTED TO
TOUCH OVAL MAGAZINE IS REMOVED.
IN THE MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC
GUN VIOLENCE PROTESTS ON THE
STREETS WITH VIOLENT CRIMES IN
HOMES WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SUICIDES AND- ACCIDENTS
FROM IMPROPERLY STORED GUNS
PARTICULARLY AS PEOPLE SPEND
MORE TIME AT HOME. THIS BILL
WILL EQUIP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO QUICKLY SOLVE GUN
CRIMES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS REDUCE ACCIDENTAL GUN
DEATHS AND INJURIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR WIENER DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE. A DEBATE ON THIS MATTER.
SEEING NONE I SEE NO HAN UP FOR
PARTS. AS WELL. WOULD YOU TO
CLOSER WIENER. RESPECT WEST
FROM EITHER THANK YOU SIX EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WITH
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS WELL
FIVE BRADFORD HI CABRERA. DODD
FIVE THE RAZA. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO. NO
JACKSON I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I NIELSEN
NO HAN HI I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH.
RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN HI
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER HI RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO VOTING BY OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS AGAIN THIS IS. EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CONTINUE TO
ROLL STATE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN NO. BATES NO
GORGEOUS. IT IS AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN NOW FORGES ALLIANCE
OUR BUDGETS WE DID NOT GET A
VISUAL ON YOU I NEED TO GET
VISUAL FIRST SORRY APOLOGIZE
KEEP PLEASE REPEAT YOUR VOTE.
GORGEOUS AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN NOW THANK YOU FOR JUST NO
CHIANG. HEARING AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN NO CHIANG NO DALLY.
GHALI AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN NO. DALLY NO GROWTH. AB.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN NO
ROVER NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB
TWENTY EIGHT FOUR STEP. MORLOCK
NO MORALE YES MORRELL AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN NO. WELL
KNOWN WILK. AB. TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN NO WILK NOW. THANK
YOU SIR WIENER PLACES THE BILL
ON CALL RIGHT NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FORTY CENTER BELL ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT-
SURGERY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC TRANSIT.
THANK YOU CENTER BELL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS- THIS
IS- AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW- BILL WOULD
PLACE UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES
DISPUTES FOR THE BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT. BART UNDER THE
JURISDICTIONS OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD- THE
CURRENT CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PROCESSES FAILED TO RESOLVE
MANY OF THE BARD. EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE DISPUTES- THOSE
UNRESOLVED DISPUTES CAN FOSTER
LABOR TENSION PUT A STRAIN ON
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS ACTUALLY
OF STOP THE SERVICES THAT. WE
NEED IN THE BAY AREA FOR
TRANSIT. AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
WILL PROMOTE BETTER LABOR
RELATIONS- AT BART AND IS
NEEDED IN A TIME WHEN PUBLIC
TRANSIT WILL PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE. IN OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY I RESPECTFULLY US IN A
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BILLS ARE
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE. CENTER
PORCHES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
IF I MAY POSE THE QUESTION TO
THE FLOOR MANAGER THAT'S
TERRIBLE YOU BE WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE QUESTION YES PLEASE
CONTINUE TO REPORT THIS. THANK
YOU. ARE CURRENTLY- WOULD THERE
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR DAMAGES
TO BE AWARDED IF THERE WERE IN
ON THE LAWFUL STRIKE. SO IS
THAT THE CASE THAT THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO DO SO RIGHT NOW BUT
THAT THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
CHANGE THAT THE LEGISLATION
SPECIFIES THAT THE PER- SHALL
HAVE THAT'S A- OF BOARD SHALL
HAVE NO AUTHORITY IN ACTIONS TO
RECOVER DAMAGESDUE TO UNLAWFUL
STRIKE. OR TWO WORDS STRIKE
PREPARATION EXPENSES AS DAMAGES
OF FOUR TO AWARD DAMAGES FOR
COSTS EXPENSES OR- REVENUE
LOSSES IN THE INTEREST INCURRED
DURING A UNLAWFUL STRIKE. BUT
CURRENTLY ARE THEY ABLE TO PULL
SELECT GO ON AND UNLAWFUL
STRIKE AND THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD CHANGE THAT
IS THAT CORRECT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CHANGE IN THE
TERMS OF PUTTING JURISDICTION
UNDER HER TO RESOLVE THE
DISPUTE BUT IT DOES NOT GIVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO- PAY FOR
DAMAGES DUE TO UNLAWFUL STRIKES.
THANK YOUR NUMBERS OKAY THANK
YOU AT OTHER QUESTIONS FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER. OKAY
SEEING NONE AND SAYING NO OTHER
HANDS UP FOR A VOTE TO
SUSPENSE- CENTER BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL THAT'S JUST
THE POINT WE DON'T WANT STRIKES
ABOARD WE WANT BAR TO CONTINUE-
I AM VERY PLEASED THAT- IN JUNE
BAR WAS EXTENDED DOWN TO SAN
JOSE FOR EXAMPLE. AND OUR
SERVER SKI OVERJOYED ABOUT
THAT- WE ONE OR WHEN I HAVE
FAIR LABOR RELATIONS PRACTICES
THIS WOULD DO THAT ORIGINAL
VOTE. IF YOU CENTER BELL- THAT
CITRIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WITH ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. WELL FIVE BRADFORD.
FIVE CABRERO I DODD. HI THE
RAZA. HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ. I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO. HURTADO HI JACKSON.
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN. NO HAN HI I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER STERN HI AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER HI A
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY SECTOR
PLEASE CONTINUE TO ROLL. FACE
BATES AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NO
BATES NOW REGIS. OR JUST AB
TWENTY FIFTEEN NOW GORGEOUS NO
CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT NOW CHIANG NO DALLY.
DALLY AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NOW
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY NO GROWTH NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. BERLOCQ AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY NO. MORLOCK NO
MORALE MORRELL AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY NO MORALE NO WILK. WILK
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NO WILK
NO. THANK YOU CENTER BELL PUTS
THE BILL ON CALL. RIGHT LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FORTY ONE CENTER ALLEN HE
PREPARED TO PRESENT RIGHT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN THE
CAP AN ACTUAL LEADING TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
DECLARING THE THERE OF TAKE
EFFECT. CENTER ALAN. MISTER
PRESIDENT AND OVER 60% OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
HAVE A SURPLUS. OF RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS WHICH LEAVES OVER
ONE EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
UNTOUCHED SO THIS BILL WOULD
WITHOUT CREATING A MANDATE
ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO USE THEIR
RESTRICTED LOTTERY FUNDS TO
PROVIDE HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
FOOD ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS.
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY WOULD
WOULD FREE UP EXISTING DOLLARS
AND IT'S ONE STEP THAT WE CAN
TAKE NOW TO HELP BRIDGE GAPS
FOR OUR STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS CRISIS IS NEEDED YOU KNOW
ALL THE MORE NOW IS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE REALLY BEEN
STRUGGLING TO RESPOND SWIFTLY
TO THE CURRENT CRISIS. BY THE
BILL DOESN'T GIVEN ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE LOTTERY-
INSTEAD IT ENSURES THAT FUNDS
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ALLOCATED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CAN ACTUALLY BE SPENT. TO
BENEFIT STUDENTS INSTEAD OF
PILING UP UNUSED. THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR ALASTAIR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. C. NINE ON THE FLOOR
C. NO HANDS UP FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS. SIR ALAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT ONE OF THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
RESPECT FAST NETWORK. OKAY
RIGHT WITH THAT LET'S SECRETARY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHER I CAN. WELL I
FOR JUST BRADFORD I HAVE A OUT
OF. I DODD HI THE RISER. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG. HELLO HI WITH SO.
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL HI MY NAME I
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER HI.
GROWTH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS AGAIN
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR- SOCRATES CONTINUED ROLE
FACE. AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR NO BATES NO FORTUS. AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR ON.
FOR JUST FIVE CHIANG. THANK AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR NOW
CHIANG NO DALLY. THERE IS- YOU
STILL ON MUTE SIR DOLLY. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. BALLY AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR NO
DALLY NO. GROWTH AB EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR I GROW
BY THAT'S WHY MULLIN DOES NOT
ALIGN IS AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. WELL AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR NO
MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR HI WILK HI. A
CENTER ALLEN PLACES THE BILL
OFTEN CALL. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FORTY TWO CEREMONY
APPEARED PRESENT RIGHT A
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WET. AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL ACTIONS
CENTER MINING THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS UNDER CURRENT
LAW VAST MAJORITY OF CASES
CONNECTED TO DR HEAPS OF
PHYSICIAN EMPLOYED BY UCLA WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED WOMEN IN THE COURSE OF
HIS THIRTY FIVE YEAR CAREER.
ARE TIME BARRED BY THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE OPENED A
BRIEF ONE YEAR WINDOW IN THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY FORMER
GYNECOLOGIST DR GEORGE TYNDALL
AT USC. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
CHANGE IN LAW ONLY APPLIED TO
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS EXCLUDING
PUBLIC ENTITIES LIKE UCLA AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO WOULD
TEMPORARILY REVIVE THOSE TIME
BARRED CASES FOR ONE YEAR%
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CEREMONIES THEIR DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE THIS BILL. OKAY SAY NONE
I SEE NO HANDS UP FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS. THAT CEREMONY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER MINING SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. WELL
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I DODD
HI DURAZO. HI GALGIANI HI
GLAZER GUNS. I HERTZBERG. HELLO
HI HUESO. HER TADO I JACKSON I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL.
MONNING HI NIELSEN. I CAN AYE
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH. I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER STERN. HI AMBERG
BY CASKEY SORRY WIENER. HI
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR OF
THE VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS
AGAIN AB THIRTEEN NINETY TWO
SECRETARY PLEASE CONTINUE THE
ROLE. BATES SB THIRTY NINETY
TWO ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS OR JUST
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO BY BOARD
JUST FIVE CHIANG. THANK AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO BY. CHANG'E
FIVE DOLLY DALY AB THIRTY
NINETY TWO I. DALLY FIVE GROWTH.
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO I GROVE
FIVE MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MORLOCK. AB THREE ZERO NINE
TWO ABSTAINED. MOREAU. L. A. B.
THIRTY NINETY TWO HIGH MORALE
HI WILK. WILK ABC THIRTY NINETY
TWO HI WILK HI. CEREMONY PLACE
THE BILL ON CALL OUR NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR
CENTER HUESO YOU. RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT AS DESK LET'S MOVE ON THEN
TO ITEM NUMBER. FORTY SIX SARAH
GONZALEZ REPAIRED ALL RIGHT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND AND
ACTUALLY THE CONTRACTS. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT ITSELF SORRY
THANK YOU SORRY I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO
FIVE FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIAM ON WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING CO SIGNERS
OF THE CONTRACTS FOR THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING PRIMARY SIGNERS.
CURRENTLY WHEN A CONTRACT IS
NEGOTIATED IN ONE OF FIVE
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH
THE PRIMARY CENTERS REQUIRED TO
RECEIVE THE CONTRACT IN THE
LANGUAGE THEY NEGOTIATED AND
THE SAME IS NOT TRUE
UNFORTUNATELY FOR CO SIGNERS AB
THREE TWO FIVE FOUR WILL
PROVIDE CO SIGNERS THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. BY REQUIRING THAT
IF A CONTRACT IS NEGOTIATED IN
THAT LANGUAGE OTHER TAN
ENGLISH AND A C CENTER SPEAKS
THAT OTHER LANGUAGE AND THEY
MUST RECEIVE THE CONTRACT IN
THAT SAME LANGUAGE AS WELL.
WITHOUT THESE PROTECTIONS CO
SIGNERS ARE EXTREMELY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD AB THREE
TWO FIVE FOUR HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SARAH GONZALEZ
ARE THERE MEMBERS WHO FOR
DEBATE. CASEY NINE I SEE NO ONE
WITH THEIR HANDS UP FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. THE DEBTS
ARE THOSE WHICH ARE LIKE THE
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
TELL BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
DODD. FIVE DURAZO HI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HELLO FIVE HUESO.
HER TADO. JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. MY NAME I
NIELSEN. NIELSEN THERE. PAN HI
HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER. HI
JOINT DOES. SANDALS IN THE
JEWISH TO. NIELSEN HI BUT LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO A REMOTE MEMBERS
THIS IS AGAIN AB. THIRTY TWO
FIFTY FOUR SECRETARIES CONTINUE
THE ROLE. BASS BATES AB THIRTY
TO FIFTY FOUR ARE BASED HI
GORGEOUS. FORGE'S LEAD LEAD
THIRTY TWO FIFTY FOUR I FOR
JUST HI CHIANG. THANK AB THIRTY
TWO FIFTY FOUR I CHIANG MAI
DALLY. SALLY AB THIRTY TWO
FIFTY FOUR HI DALLY HI. GROWTH.
AB THIRTY TWO FIFTY FOUR HI
GROVE HI MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MORLOCK. WHAT SB
THIRTY PEOPLE. MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE WE'RE ALL AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR HIGH MORALE HIGH.
WILK OKAY BE THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR HI WILK I. RIGHT SIR
BECAUSE THOSE PLACES THE BILL
ON CALL. RIGHT NEXT TIME IS A
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN CENTER HILL
IN PREPARED SIX EIGHT PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THANK YOU
TO PRESIDENT AB SEVENTY WOULD
PREVENT COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES FOR ME BEATING STATE
OVERSIGHT AND DECEIVING
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO VERIFY WHETHER AN
INSTITUTION THAT CLAIMS TO BE A
NONPROFIT COLLEGE AND THEREFORE
IS EXEMPT FROM STATE OVERSIGHT
IS ACTUALLY OPERATING AS A NON
PROFIT. A DECLINE IN
ENFORCEMENT OF NONPROFIT STATUS
BY THE IRISH'S LEAD TO A
DISTURBING TREND WHERE SOME FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES ARE USING
COMPLICATED FINANCIAL SCHEMES
AND SHELL CORPORATIONS TO LAY
CLAIM TO NONPROFIT STATUS THIS
EMERGING PROBLEM HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY TIME SENSITIVE AS
MANY STUDENTS ARE SEEKING
EDUCATIONAL S. SPECIFICALLY
ONLINE. DUE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE
PANDEMIC INDUCED RECESSION.
THOUGH AB SEVENTY WOULD PROVIDE
AN OBJECTIVE CHECK ON A NON
PROFIT CLAIM IN PREVENT THESE
COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES FROM
CONTINUING TO MISLEAD STUDENTS
AND AVOID APPROPRIATE STATE
OVERSIGHT. AB SEVENTY HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SIR HELLO
SIR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
SAYING NO ONE ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NO HANDS UP FROM THE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE A PREVIOUS RIVAL
COLLEGE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER HELD A SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. WELL
BRADFORD. FIVE CABALLERO I DON.
FIVE THE RAZA. HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
HILL HI HUESO. HER TADO.
JACKSON I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL MONNING I NIELSEN. I
CAN BUY FIVE PORTANTINO HI
RALPH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
STERN HI NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI MY
CASKEY HI WIENER HI. WE'VE ONTO
A REMOTE VOTERS VOTING MEMBERS
AND AGAIN THIS IS AB SEVENTY
SIX FIFTIES CONTINUE THE ROLE
FACE. BATES AB. SEVENTY FIVE
FIFTY FIVE GORGEOUS. ORANGES AB
SEVENTY I. GORGEOUS HIGH CHIANG.
CHIANG AB SEVENTY HI HANG HI
DALY DALY AB SEVENTY FIVE DELHI
HIGH GROWTH. CAN YOU SEE IT. AB
EIGHT THIRTY WE DON'T KNOW YET
SORRY CENTER CAN WE PLEASE
INDIVIDUALS OR GROUPS OF OKAY
WE NOW THESE THANK YOU. SORRY
AT GROWTH AB. SEVENTY FIVE
GROVE HI MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
SEVENTY I WONDER IF HI WARLOCK.
AB SEVENTY I MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. MORALE AB SEVENTY NINE
MORRELL AYE WILK. AB. SEVENTY
FIVE WILK HI. HUESO HI MILLS
WRITES CENTER HELP PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU RIGHT
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER. RIGHT
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FORTY
NINE SENATE MITCHELL YOU'RE
PREPARED TO PRESENT OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY DID TO STUDENT LOANS.
HEY CENTER MITCHELL THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
AB THREE SEVENTY SIX. BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ WHICH
CREATES THE STUDENT LOAN
BORROWED BORROWER BILL OF
RIGHTS. THE MOUNTAINS OF
STUDENT DEBT WHICH TOTALS ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA ALONE IS
ONE OF THE MOST SEVERE
FINANCIAL CRISES FACING OUR
COUNTRY TODAY. THE CRISES M.
HAS IMPACTED ALMOST FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
AFFECTS EVERY FACET OF OUR
ECONOMY. NOT ONLY DO BORROWERS
NAVIGATE A COMPLEX THREE
PAYMENT PLANS BUT THEY ARE
OFTEN SUBJECT. TO PREDATORY
LENDING PRACTICES. SERVICERS
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO LOSE
PAYMENTS OVER CHARGE AND
DISSEMINATE FALSE INFORMATION.
THE LARGEST LOAN SERVICER IN
THE COUNTRY HAS EVEN STATED IN
FEDERAL COURT THAT AND I QUOTE.
THERE IS NO EXPECTATION OF THE
SERVICEABLE ACT IN THE INTEREST
OF THE CONSUMER IN QUOTE. IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE HIGH
PROFILE LAWSUITS HAVE ALLEGED
WIDESPREAD ABUSES BY THESE
COMPANIES. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECERRA SUED
NAVIOS FOR STEERING CALIFORNIA
BORROWERS INTO HIGH COSTS
REPAYMENT OPTIONS AND DENYING
THEM THEIR RIGHTS TO AFFORDABLE
PAYMENTS. IN APRIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT SUED FEDLOAN
SERVICING FOR OBSTRUCTING ITS
EFFORTS TO HOLD THE COMPANY
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY'RE
CHEATED THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS
OUT OF THEIR REPAYMENT RIGHTS.
ABTHREE SEVENTY SIX WILL
CREATE INDUSTRY RIGHTS
STANDARDS FOR STUDENT LOAN
SERVICING AND PROVIDE BORROWERS
WITH BORROWERS WITH PROTECTIONS.
FROM PREDATORY LENDERS. THE
BILL WILL PROHIBIT ABUSIVE
SERVICING PRACTICES CREATE
MINIMUM SERVICING STANDARDS
RELATED TO REPAYMENT
APPLICATIONS AND ACCOUNT
MANAGEMENT ESTABLISH A NEW
STUDENT LOAN OMBUDSMAN TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF BORROWERS
ANDGRANTED APARTMENT A
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT ADDITIONAL
MARKET MONITORING AUTHORITIES.
ON THIS THE GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC CRISIS
STUDENT BORROWERS FACE
COMPOUNDING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
AND DESERVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. AB THREE SEVEN SIX
WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENT
BORROWERS RECEIVE QUALITY
SERVICE AND MEANINGFUL ACCESS
TO REPAYMENT PROGRAMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL
IS OUR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
K. C. HELLO YES ASSEMBLY CASKEY
MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IS REALLY A HUGE. DEAL
THIS THE CREATION OF THE
STUDENT BORROWER ADVOCATES AND
THE ABILITY OF THEM TO WORK ON
BEHALF OF A CLUSTER OF STUDENTS
ARE BEING. DAMAGED OR BEING ILL
TREATED IS HUGE THIS IS GOING
TO BE A GAME CHANGER IN THIS
AREA AND ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO
VOTE HI. THANK YOU SARAH CASKEY
AS IT FURTHER DEBATE. CASEY
NICENO HANDS UP FOR VOTE
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS RIGHT NOW.
THAT SIR MITCHELL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. BELL
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. I DODD.
I THE RAZA. I GALGIANI. AYE
GLAZER GUNS. I HERTZBERG. HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO. JACKSON
I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. MITCHELL I
MONEY. I NIELSEN. NO HAN HI HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN HI- BURKE I
LIKE HOW SCHEME FIVE WIENER. HI
I WILL MOVE ON TO OUR REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS AB THREE
SEVENTIES SECTOR PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE FAITH. BASIC
AB THREE SEVENTY SIX NO. NOW
BORJAS. FOR JUST WE NEED A
VISION BOARD JUST FIRST. OR
JUST DROP. OKAY. OKAY LET'S
HOLD ON A MOMENT TELL SEVERAL
JUST GETS BACK ON. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR CENTER BOARD JUST
TO GET ON- JUST MAKE A NOTE FOR
ALL THE MEMBERS WHO WERE SHOULD
BE ON THE FLOOR OR NOT OF THOSE
WITH ACCOMMODATIONS WE WILL BE
LIFTING CALLS AT TWELVE THIRTY
SO PLEASE PREPARE TO BE ON THE
FLOOR AT TWELVE THIRTY. HAVE WE
GOTTEN CENTER BOARD JUST BACK
YET. SHE WE CONTINUE THE ROLE
THE COMPACT THE BORDERS IF HE
COMES ON BY THEN ALL RIGT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU CONTINUE THE
ROLE OF THE OTHER REMOTE
MEMBERS AND WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN
GET TERRIBLE JUST ON. FORTY AT.
YOU SEE IF HE'S BACK OKAY
CENTER PORTIS CAN WE GET A
VISION CENTER BORDERS. HE IS
BADLY YEAH. ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE
A VISUAL ON YOU YET ON THEIR
SCREEN. I'M SORRY SOON. JUST
DROPPED YEAH. HELLO THERE YOU
ARE OKAY SIR BORDERS FOR JUST.
SEES FROZEN THERE. I APOLOGIZE
I APOLOGIZE SUIT. CHIEF MERCOLA
JERSEY JUST DROPPED I DON'T
KNOW WHICH I. OKAY ALL RIGHT
HERE WE HAVE A WE HAVE YOU ON
VISUAL YES PARTY CONNECTION AT
THE MOMENT. OKAY WHAT DO I TRY
TO CAST YOUR VOTE WE CAN
CAPTURE YOUR VISUAL AND YOUR
AUDIO THEN WILL THENTHE VOTE
WILL BE ON THE- RECORD ABOUT.
WELL IF YOU CAN HEAR ME. YES
PRESENT. I'M SORRY I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHICH ITEMS WERE ON OKAY
SO WE ARE ON OKAY SO WE ARE ON
ITEM FORTY NINE IT'S AB THREE
SEVENTY SIX. AB THREE VETERANS
IT EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AS
PRESENTED BY SENATOR MITCHELL
STICKING OKAY NINE THIRTY
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR NAME THE
MEASURE NUMBER AND YOUR VOTE
AGAIN. WHEN I HAVE A GOOD
CONNECTION. SHE. FOR JUST
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN SIX
ABSTAINED BUT STAINED OKAY WELL
THANK YOU WE CAPTURE THAT AND
WE HAVE YOUR IMAGE. THAT'S
OFFICIALS ARE TARIAN. OKAY
LET'S. LET'S CONTINUE WITH THE
ROLE THAT WE CAN CAPTURE THAT
THANK YOU CENTER. THESE COULD
THE ROLE AS CHIANG. HANG AB
THREE SEVENTY SIX ABSTAINED
DALLAS. AB THREE SEVENTY SIX NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB THREE
SEVENTY SIX NOW GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB THREE
SEVENTY SIX NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORLOCK. AB THREE SEVEN SIX NO
MORE LOCK NO. MORRELL WE'RE OUT
AB THREE SEVEN SIX NOW MORALE
NO WILK. AB THREE SEVEN SIX NO
WILK NO. SENATE MITCHELL PLACES
THIS BILL ON CALL. RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FOUR CENTER WE SO YOU'RE
PREPARED TO PRESENT. OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SELASA AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATE
HUESO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS SO I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET TO MEET ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND CREATE
MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR OUR
GRID. THIS BILL WILL EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF BIO MASTER
INCLUDE CELLULOSIC MATERIAL
LIKE THE TREES AND AGRICULTURAL
WASTE. WITHOUT UTILIZING WOODY
WASTE LIKE TO TREES TRIMMING
CYNICAL CULTURAL WAY SUCH AS
NOT SHELLS IN ORCHARD BERMAN
BROUGH MEANS THIS MILK MATERIAL
WITH THE EITHER BE PUT IN A
LANDFILL OR BORN BURNED IN THE
OPEN. THE CURRENT POLICY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SALAH
CONTROLLABLE BURNS UNLESS THERE
IS A BIOMETHANE PLANT TO SEND
THE SCREEN MATERIAL THEN OF
COURSE IF WE- ALLOW THIS BILL
TO MOVE FORWARD THIS WILL. FIT
THIS BILL WOULD IT HELP US.
REDUCE EMISSIONS IN THE STATE
OF THE STATE OF A- LANDFILL IN
A BURNING WASTE THAT CAN BE
CONVERTED INTO PIPELINE QUALITY
BIOMETHANE. AND USE FOR RENEWAL.
ENERGY JOIN ME IN PASSING AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE THIS
WILL HELP US AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED MEET OUR CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS WHILE REDUCING HARMFUL
EMISSIONS INVOLVED FAR RISK.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATE HUESO
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE CENTER
DOLLY. YOU STILL ON MUTE CENTER
DOLLY PLEASE AND YOURSELF FIRST.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- I RISE- AS A CO AUTHOR
THIS BILL THIS BILL- GREATLY.
INCREASE THE USE OF BIOMASS
WHICH WE REALLY NEED AT IN
THESE TIMES WHEN WE SEE THESE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IT WILL
IMPROVE OUR WATERSHEDS. AND
ALSO HELP OUR ADMIN SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I WOULD THAT ASKS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR DOLLARS
CENTER NIELSEN. THE GENTLEMAN.
OF THE SENATE. I ALSO URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THIS IS CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE FOR A
LONG TIME BECAUSE OF A THE
EMPHASIS OF THIS THESE FORMS OF
COGENERATION WHICH USED TO BE
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED. BUT
INVASIVE- A PREOCCUPATION WITH
ALIEN ENERGY AND- REALLY WITH
THE- SOLAR. AT THIS IS BEEN DE
EMPHASIZED THE NET PRODUCT OF
WITHIN THE AGRICULTURAL WASTE
AND OUR- FOREST AND WILDLAND.
WASTE THE BRUSH AND TREES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE NEEDED TO BE
CLEARED SO WE DO NOT HAVE THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES THAT WE'VE
LOST A LOT OF THE COGENERATION
CAPACITY THAT WE ONCE HAD. THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL I DO
WORDS AND I WILL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DEBATE SEEN ON THE
FLOOR SEE NO FOR THEIR HANDS UP
ON THE REMOTE THOROUGHLY SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU JUST- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU CENTER HUESO. JERRY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN WE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. WELL I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO FIVE DODD.
I TERRAZZO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG
HELLO I HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON NO LEYVA. MITCHELL HI
MY NAME. I NIELSEN. HI PAM HI I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BURKE. BY
CASKEY. I WIENER. NOW. OF
SERVICE KERN OF. SEARCH TERMS I
CAN USUALLY SPEAK UP SIR SIR
WITH WITH WITH. STERN I DON'T
KNOW STERN I DUNNO ERIN'S LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO A REMOTE VOTING
MEMBERS THIS IS AB. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE SECRETARY PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE. BATES THANKS
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE ALL
RIGHT.BATES FIVE. GORGEOUS
WE'RE JUST AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE HI LARGEST HI CHIANG HEY
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE HI.
CHIANG HI DALLY DALY AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE HI SALLY I KNOW
IT GROSS. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
THREE HI GROCERY WATER ICE
THIRTY ONE THREE SO COULD YOU
JUST REPEAT THAT AB. THIRTY ONE
SIX ZERO THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
I. THANK YOU. GROVE HI MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE I MUNDAS HI MORE LOCK. OR
OR AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE I.
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE MORRELL AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE I. L. HI
WILK. WILK AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE HI WILK HI. ACTIONS OF
ONE OF THE FLORIDA. THEY'RE
GOING TO FLORIDA WE GO
BACKGROUND OR NOT. NO MITCHELL
I DON'T KNOW. OKAY RIGHT. OKAY
OKAY THE- SERVICE ON THIS CALL.
RIGHT WE'RE TAKING. THE
PHARMACIST WE ORGANIZE TO LIFT
CALLS EVENTUALLY. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A TWO MINUTE
PROCESS WE RANGE TO LIFT CALLS.
SO ASK THAT- EVERYONE ANYONE
WHO USE TO BE ON THE FLOOR
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
HM
SHE- TRANSPORTERS. YEAH. SAYS.
THANK.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND OF COURSE REMINDER TO
MAINTAIN YOUR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING CENTER DIED. MISTER
CHAIRMAN UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ALL RIGHT HOLD ON A
MOMENT. RELATED TAKE THAT. BUT
THE RESOLUTION YEAH THAT
STARTED OUT AS A PLACE OF
RESOLUTION RAISING. BUT I
PLEASE CONTINUE SATURDAY YES
CAN YOU BOB I POLICE I'D LIKE
TO PLEASE REQUESTED TO MOVE AB
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT CURRY ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE TO AN
ACTIVE AT THE OUR AUTHORS
REQUEST PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU.
YES SENATOR HILL. PRESIDENT
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS I
HAVE A LETTER FROM THE JOURNAL
TO CLARIFY THE INTENT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THE LETTER
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH SIDES
OKAY THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION. RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ONE OKAY THAT.
ONE THANK YOU
JUST STILL TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
OUT. GET A REMINDER FOR AT ASK
MEMBERS TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WE ARE FINALIZING THE-
REMOTE MEMBERS HERE I BELIEVE.
THAT ACCESS THE MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE ALL OUR
MEMBERS THAT SEEKS THEIR SEATS
OKAY I SEE A COUPLE WORKING
THEIR WAY OVER TO ASK MEMBERS
IT PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. SO
WE CAN LIVE CALLS. CAN WE NEED
ALL THE NUMBERS IN THEIR SEATS
I SEE A COUPLE MISSING ONES
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. YEAH.
OKAY THE. ARE YOU READY OKAY SO
WE GOT EVERYONE THEIR SEATS
LET'S SEE ONE MORE MEMBER HERE
OKAY. OKAY INFLUENCE YOUR
CURRENT CAN I LIVE CALL. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
LIFTING CALL THE HOLD ON VERY.
OKAY WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
LIFTING CALLS SO. RIGHT GOT IT
ONE HERE ALL RIGHT SO- WILL
BEGIN WITH FILE NUMBER. TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS I. DODD. GLAZER
HERTZBERG. I HUESO HI LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I AMBERG HIOKAY
GLAZER HI. CHECK WITH DODD.
DODD HI. OKAY THIS IS TWENTY
SEVEN AND DOES NOT. BUT IT'S%
OKAY THAT'S RIGHT ALL RIGHT
REMOTE NUMBER PS SORRY I
APOLOGIZE AT LEAST- NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE ROAD VERBO
MEMBERS THIS IS AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU. BATES
CULMINATES THE LEVIN EIGHTY
FIVE. NO BATES NOW. MORLOCK.
CAN WE GET A VISUAL CENTER
MORLOCK. PFISTER PRESIDENT- I
ALREADY VOTED AND STATED I WAS
NOT VOTING ON THIS. BILL DO YOU
WANT ME TO VOTE AGAIN A THANK
WITH THAT WILL THAT THE FIGURES
THAT STAND THANK YOU SO I
CONFIRM ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER-
NIELSEN. NOW. CORRECTLY
COMPLETED THE REMOTE MEMBERS
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU SEPARATE
RENDON OKAY THIRTY FIVE I
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU PASSED
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO SEPARATE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BELL I
LASER I HERTZBERG. FIVE SKINNER.
HI LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO A
REMOTE MEMBERS- PLEASE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CONTINUE THE
ROLES SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
SEPARATE PLEASE CONTINUE THE
ROLE BATES. THANKS SB EIGHT
SEVEN TO CONFIRM ABSTAINED.
BORJAS. I WOULD JUST LIKE WITH
THE CENTER MORLOCK EARLIER ARE
WE GOING TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THE EXTENSIONS AGAIN SO- NORMAL
PRACTICES I REALIZE THAT OU
DID DECLARE ABSTENTION ONLINE
BUT WE USUALLY DO GO BACK
AROUND FOR ANYONE WHO IS NOT
CAST A EITHER AND AYE OR NAY
VOTES TO ACTUALLY RESTATE BUT
PERHAPS WE CONSULTED
PARLIAMENTARIAN. YEAH WE DON'T
HAVE MEMBERS CALLS AGAIN YEAH
WE WILL POSSIBLE RENOWNED.
MAYBE WE ARE MISSING A NUMBER
OF ALL. OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO
I'D ALL RIGHT SO I JUST WANNA
CONFIRM FOR A REAL MA'AM. I
PROPOSE WE DO THE FOLLOWING AND
IF YOU HAVE AN OBJECTION PLEASE
LET ME KNOW WHAT WE WILL DO
BECAUSE YOU'VE RATE CAST OF THE
VOTE THE NORMAL PROCEDURE HAS
BEEN IF YOU ON THE FLOOR YOU
DIDN'T HAVE TO BUT WE GO BACK
AROUND WE WILL ASK YOU INSTEAD
WHAT WE WILL DO IS WE COME TO
REMOTE MEMBERS BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH YOU. IF YOU
WISH TO EITHER CHANGE YOUR VOTE
OR BE CALLED ON AGAIN PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL THEN
CALL AND THEN HAVE THE
SECRETARY CALL ON YOU TO HAVE
YOU CAST YOUR VOTE IN CASE YOU
WANT TO NOW BUT AYE OR NAY YOUR
PREVIOUSLY IS THAT ACCEPTABLE
TO YOU. OKAY JUST LOT OF NON IF
ANYONE HAS ANY OBJECTIONS TO
THAT PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. I
DON'T SEE ANY HANDS REYES- I
ASSUME- MADAM MINORITY LEADER
IS THAT SOUND LIKE A REASONABLE
AGREEMENT AT WAY TO HANDLE THIS.
YES MR PRESIDENT OKAY THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT WE
ARE FOLLOWING PROCEDURE
EVERYONE'S COMFORTABLE WITH
OKAY WHAT YEAH SO WHAT THE
THERE WAS A BILL THAT LEFT THE
FLOOR. THEY DID NOT GET A
SECOND ROUND- FOR THAT- THAT
PURPOSE THAT WE JUST DISCUSSED.
OKAY WHICH. OKAY WHICH BILL SO
HOLD ON. THAT BILL SO IT'S
ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED FOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG WE HAD
OFFLINE CONVERSATION REGARDING
THAT BILL BUT I AM- I AM NOT
HAPPY THAT BILLS LEFT THE FLOOR
WITHOUT A SECOND ROUND AS A
FOLLOW UP. THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE JUST MADE GOING FORWARD WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT- IF ANY OF
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE VOTING
REMOTELY WANT TO. CHANGE THEIR
VOCAL I TO NO OR NOT VOTING TO
THE POSITION THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT BY RAISING
THEIR HAND AND I ACCEPT WHAT
YOU JUST SAID. AS ARE THE
REMAINS CURRENT OKAY GOOD SO
WE'LL JUST MOVE FORWARD THEN
WITH THAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
MAJORITY MINORITY LEADER ALL
RIGHT SO. WE CAN TAKE A BET ON
THAT. RIGHT IT'S OVER LET'S
RETURN TO SO. I DON'T NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
THE VOTE IS THIRTY THREE EYES-
NO NAYS THE BILL IS OUT LET'S
MOVE ON WE'RE NOW TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SO WELL. HI PLEASE. I
SKINNER. HI OKAY THANK YOU US
CENTER BATES HURDLES FOR THE
ROLE. IT'S S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN NO. BATES NOW. I SEE NO
THEIR HANDS UP- THE THIRTY UP
HIGHS THIRTY DAYS EIGHT THE
BILL IS PASSED THE TAXES I AM
THE FOLLOWING NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
THREE TWELVE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WELL. GLAZER I.
NIELSEN HI SKINNER HI. OKAY SAY
NO HANDS UP. THE EYES ARE
THIRTY SEVEN THE NOSE ONE THE
BILL IS PASSED LET'S MOVE ON TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WELL I
GLAZER I SKINNER. HI OKAY A
CITY NO HANDS UP A REMOTE
VOTING THE EYES ARE THIRTY NINE
THE NAYS ARE ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR AB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WELL FIVE GLAZER. I HER TADO.
SKINNER HI. OKAY I SEE NO HANDS
UP THE HIGHS ARE TWENTY EIGHT
THE NAYS TEN THAT BILL IS OUT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO AYE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY OKAY
FIRST ON BELL. YEAH I. GLAZER I.
SKINNER NIELSEN. SKINNER HI
OKAY SEEING NO HANDS- ALL NINE.
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY SIX NO. GROVE NO. OKAY
SEEING NO THEIR HANDS UP. BUT
DID YOU SEE HER NAME OR HER
PARENTS ABOUT. OKAY HERE
BECAUSE PATTERSON OKAY SIR OKAY
SO. I HEARD I HEARD. OKAY ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT SO THE VOTE IS
HI THIRTY NO TO URGENT I THIRTY
TO ON THE MEASURE. THAT'S NOW
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I FELL. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER I HERTZBERG. I MCGUIRE I
NIELSEN. SKINNER. HI NUMBER.
OKAY AND I SEE NO HANDS UP SO
THE ICE THIRTY FOUR NOTES TO
THAT BILL IS PASSED BY NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE-
CIGARETTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS I BELL I. GLAZER. FIVE
SKINNER. HI NUMBER. HI WIENER.
HI OKAY AND SEEING NO HANDS UP
REMOTELY ICE THIRTY FIVE ZERO
THAT MEASURE HAS PASSED THANKS
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO EIGHTY SIX
FORTY SIX SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ATKINS I FELL. I
GLAZER. I INNER. HI AMBERG I.
THEY SAY NO HANDS OPEN REMOTE
VOTING ICE TWENTY NINE IT KNOWS
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY
THIRTY TWO- EIGHTY SIX FORTY
SIX WE JUST APPROACH THAT SORRY
THAT'S RIGHT NOT. THIRTY FIVE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE SORRY NEXT
MEASURES I FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR A SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. I ATKINS I TELL. I
GLAZER I HERTZBERG. I MCGUIRE I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BURKE I
SAY NO HANDS UP FOR THE REMOTE
MEMBERS HIGHS THIRTY FIVE THOSE
TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES NEXT
ITEM IS FILE IN WITH THIRTY
FOUR EIGHTY TWENTY SIXTY ONE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ATKINS I TELL. I L. G.
ANI. I GLAZER I HERTZBERG. HI
MCGUIRE AYE ROTH. SKINNER I
STERN. I NUMBER HI. A SINGLE
HAND UP FOR THE REMOTE MEMBERS
THE ICE TWENTY EIGHT THOSE
SEVEN THAT BILL IS OUT. THE YES.
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS AYE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ATKINS I GLAZER I. HERTZBERG HI
MCGUIRE. FIVE FIVE STERN. I AM
BURKE. HI AC NO HANDS UP ON THE
REMOTE VOTERS HIS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS Z. NINE KNOWS THAT
MEASURE PASSES NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. FIVE
ATKINS. I GLAZER. I HERTZBERG I
MCGUIRE. I SKINNER. I STERN. HI
AMBERG. HI CENTER BATES. I NEED
A YOU NEED COME OFF MUTE. I
DON'T KNOW I GUESS SHE'S ON HER
BATES YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE.
THERE YOU GO HI. I DON'T NEED
TO READ I'M SORRY IF THE RUN
BACK. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT A
SCENE THEIR HANDS UP HI THIRTY
ONE DAYS. THAT BILL IS PASSED.
IT IS NOT THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AB. TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE SECRETARIES
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ATKINS
I FOR JUST. GALGIANI I GLAZER I
HERTZBERG. I HER TADO. I
MCGUIRE. I SKINNER. I STERN. I
AMBERG. HI SAY NO HAN TO FOR
REMOTE MEMBERS HIGHS THIRTY TWO
DAYS SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN SECRETARIES CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ATKINS I HAVE ITEM. NO
GALGIANI. GLAZER. I HERTZBERG I.
ROTH SKINNER. I AM BURKE HI A
SCENE THE HANDS UP TO THE
REMOTE VOTERS HIS TWENTY FIVE
THOSE TWELVE THAT MEASURE IS
PASSED NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FIVE OR FORTY AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ATKINS I GLAZER NO
HERTZBERG. I HUESO. I JACKSON.
MCGUIRE I SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE
I COULD YOU SAY NO HANDS UP FOR
REMOTE VOTERS HIS TWENTY SEVEN
DAYS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
NEXT ITEM IS AB THIS IS FILING
NUMBER FORTY ONE AB TWENTY
EIGHTY FOUR SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AT. FIVE PLEASE. I
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I MCGUIRE
I SKINNER. FIVE AMBERG I. THE
MILLIONS UP FOR REMOTE MEMBERS
IT'S HI HIGHS THIRTY TWO NAY
SEVEN UNDER URGENCY FIVE THIRTY
TWO DAYS SEVEN ON THE MEASURE
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY TWO EIGHTY THREE OH NINE
TO A SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ATKINS I BATES. TELL.
EIGHT HOLD ON HERE- I AM YES DO
HAVE YOUR HAND UP WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE FLOOR AND WE'RE
GONNA GET TO YOU AT THAT THAT'S
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO A SECONDARY
CALL THE ROLL. AND NOW. HI
GLAZER. I HERTZBERG I HUESO I
MITCHELL. I CAN FIVE AMBERG
FIVE SETTER BATES. EIGHT AB
THREE OH NINE TO OUR. SORRY HAD
A LITTLE BIT BACK IN A DIDN'T
HEAR THE VOTE PLEASE THAT.
BATES ALL RIGHT. BATES HI OKAY
I SEE NO OTHER HANDS UP- HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT- KNOWS IT'S ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES NEXT VERY
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY SIX EIGHTY THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AT TIMES. HI BELLE. I
GLAZER BY HERTZBERG. I HUESO
FIVE HER TADO. I MITCHELL. I
SKINNER. FIVE NUMBER. HI PLEASE
SEE NO OTHER HANDS UP ON THE
ROAD LEADING HIGHS THIRTY NINE
NAYS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS I FELL I
GLAZER I HERTZBERG HI TADO.
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I
SKINNER. I OKAY AND SAY NO HE
UP FOR THE RIVER VOTERS HI
THIRTY NINE AND A AT ZERO THAT
MAKE PASSES NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER. FORTY NINE EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS I FELL I GLAZER I
HERTZBERG HI HER TADO. I
MCGUIRE. HI. CASEIN NO OTHER-
HANDS UP TO THE RIVER HOLD ON
CENTER PORTIS. THANK YOU THIS
IS WHEN I HAD THE FAILED ZOOM-
MOMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO CAST IN
OPPOSITION VOTE NO VOTE. ON IT.
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN SIX. OR JUST
NOW. OKAY SO THOSE IN OTHER
HANDS UP- HIS TWENTY NINE IN
THOSE NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR EIGHTY THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE- SECRETARIES
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ATKINS I
DON'T WANT GLAZER. I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG I. AMBERG. NUMBER HI.
OKAY SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN. ALLEN. GONZALEZ NOW.
NUMBER NINE L. AMBERG I DON'T
KNOW YEAH OKAY A SINGLE HANDS
UP ON THE REMOTE VOTING ITS
EYES THIRTY ONE DAYS SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM FOLLOWING NUMBER. THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY THREE TWO ONE FOUR
SIX EIGHT SEIZE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS I FELL. HI BRADFORD.
GLAZER FIVE SKINNER. I AM BURKE
HI SEEING NO HANDS UP FOR THE
ROAD VOTERS BUYS TWENTY SIX
THOSE TWELVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT SO THAT-
COMPLETES OUR- MEASURES AT THIS
POINT IN TIME ADULT COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS- CENTER ACCOUNTS
NO PUN CENTER HUESO CAMINO
THANK YOU US PRESIDENT ENERGY.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UTILITIES
WILL BE MEETING HERE IN THE
SENATE FLOOR AT ONE FORTY FIVE
ONE FORTY FIVE SHARP. THANK YOU
SIR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS A LITTLE HEADS UP
FOR TOMORROW FOR A BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE ANTICIPATE MEETING TOMORROW
ALL UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION.
THANK YOU- FACT MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTELY SIR HERTZBERG YES
THANK YOU SO KINDLY MISTER
PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. FIRST THERE'S A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SPEND
JOINT RULES. SIXTY ONE AND
SIXTY TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AVOIDING HIS ME OF ALLOWING
POLICY AND FISCAL COMMITTEESTO
MEET. AND HEAR MEASURES AND
AMEND MEASURES ON THE FLOOR AS
DIRECTED BY THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE YES CENTER NIELSEN.
HI A NOBLE. ALL RIGHT. OKAY
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S NOT
BILLABLE SO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE MOTION-
THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE AND-
CENTER NIELSEN IS REFEREEING A
NO VOTE- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BELL I BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I
DODD I THE RAZA. DURAZO FIVE
GALGIANI. FIVE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO I HER TADO. HI JACKSON.
I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONNING. MY NAME. GOING NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HAN HI BYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN. I AM BURKE
I WHITE HOUSE SKI LONG AYE
WIENER HI BEFORE WE GO ON TOUR
REMOTE MEMBERS JUST QUICKLY
ABSENTEES AGAIN- AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO THE REMOTE MEMBER SO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENTEES. ATKINS I. MY MONNING.
FIVE SAID IT FOR THE FLORIDA
OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO TEAR
THE ROLE WHETHER ABSENTEE
MEMBERS IS A FULL RULE WAIVER-
SO- SURGERY PLEASE CONTINUE TO
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENTEE
MEMBERS. BATES. BIG BATES NO
EIGHT NO. GORGEOUS. WE'RE JUST
RULE WAIVER NOW BARGES NO
CHIANG. HANG WILL WAIVER NOW
CHIANG NO DALLY. DOLLY NO ON
SUSPENDING THE RULES DALLY NO
GROWTH. NOTE ON ROLL SUSPENSION
GROVE NO MELENDEZ AND MELENDEZ
NOW ON RULES SPEND XIN MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. NO ONE WAITING
RULES MORLOCK NO MORE AROUND.
BROWN'S RULE WAIVER NO BODY NO
MORALE NO WILK. WILL GREEN
WAITER NO WILK NOW. OKAY BUT
THE RULE WAIVER IS ADOPTED
THANK YOU OF MOTIONS RESOLUTION
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE OTHER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS ONE MORE
MOTION MEMBERS I MOVED THE
SENATE RULES BE SUSPENDED FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDING
MEASURES AND COMMITTEE AS
DIRECTED BY THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES MAJORITY
LEADER ASTRONOMICAL OKAY. IS
THERE AN OBJECTION. ON THE
CENTER NIELSEN. QUESTIONABLE
CUTS IN NOVA OKAY I. USING ALL
RIGHT IS THERE OBJECTION TO
USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL.
AND I SEE TWO HANDS UP- CENTER
BORGES'S. THIS IS NOT DEBATABLE
MOTION SIR IS NOT ON THIS
MATTER IT'S ANOTHER MATTER OKAY
HI THANK YOU CENTER MELENDEZ.
AT THE SAME PER ME IT'S ON
ANOTHER MATTER OKAY. ALL RIGHT
O- SO WE HAVE AN OBJECTION BUT
IS IT ACCEPTABLE USE THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL CENTER
NIELSEN OKAY IT IS THEY WILL
USE THE PREVIOUS. IS TWENTY
NINE DOES TEND THAT THE
RELIEVER IS SUSPENSION IS
ADOPTED. RIGHT SAYING NO THIRD
THING FOR SATURDAY'S BIRDS-
HOLD ON SO WHAT'S THE ISSUE
WHAT DO YOU DOWITH THESE TWO-
OKAY. HOLD ON A MOMENT HERE.
YEAH. ASK YOUR PATIENCE I KNOW
IT'S GETTING CLOSE TO LUNCH
HOLD ON HERE. SEVEN PEOPLE CAN
TAKE THEIR SEATS NOT CLUSTER.
YEAH. YES WE ARE WAITING- SO
PEOPLE CAN JUST TAKE A SEAT WE
HAVE NOT RECESSED YET I HOPE TO
DO THAT SHORTLY BUT- WE NEED TO
BE SURE ALL MEMBERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEIR
MATTERS TAKEN CARE OF SO.
THEY'RE GONNA HANG IN THERE.
RIGHT AWAY. ALL.
WE'RE GOING TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE DO
NEED EVERYONE BACK IN YOUR
SEATS SO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AGAIN. THANK YOU. WELL I'M NOT.
SO WE CAN GET TO A RECESSED
CAMARO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
NOW PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. RIGHT
NOW IT'S GIVEN THE TAKE YOUR
SEATS PLEASE. ASK MEMBERS TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. THANK
YOU. GO GET. I THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE IN THEIR SEATS
THAT'S- OKAY SO I'M GOING TO
FIRST RECOGNIZE AS CENTER BOARD
JUST SET UP FOR WHAT MATTER DO
YOU WISH TO USE ADDRESS THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I IMAGINE WOULD BE UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR BUT
IT'S A TECHNICAL ISSUE WOULD IT
BE POSSIBLE. IF YOU WERE TO PUT
pTHIRTY TWO FOURTEEN THAT'S
EIGHTY THREE TWO ONE FOUR
BECAUSE THERE WAS AN ERROR. ON
THE OTHER WITHOUT A MARRIAGE
THERE WAS AN ERROR ON THE
VOTING ROSTER OF. TERAHERTZ D.
WISH. TO ADDRESS THAT. FOUR
NINE. I DO HAVE THE FILE NUMBER.
I CAN I DON'T OKAY ALL RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY HERTZBERG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF AN
INQUIRY TO THE SENATOR WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR VOTE WAS
ON THAT. MEASURE IF YOU CAN
TELL US. I WAS I WAS GIVEN NO
PROOF THAT I VOTED NO BUT THE
SCREENSHOT INDICATED YES OKAY I
JUST WANT CLARIFICATION ON THE
SCREEN SHOT OKAY WILL PROVIDE.
MEDIA PLAYBACK. TOTAL YES SO
THE YOU'LL OKAY SO THE OFFICIAL
RECORD. SO THE OFFICIAL SHOW
THAT YOUR AND NO OF ON AB.
THREE FORTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO CENTER MELENDEZ. YES THANK
YOU PERCENT CENTRAL TWENTY
EIGHT I'D LIKE TO HAVE ESSERE
NINETY THREE REMOVED FROM THE
ROLLS COMMUTING BACK TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR A FULL AN
ROBUST DEBATE. OKAY HERTZBERG
OR LESS FOR A NO VOTE ON IT AND
I REQUEST ALL RIGHT- THE
MAJORITY LEADER ASPIRIN NO
VOTES. YES THAT IS ARE
HERTZBERG YES. AT LUNCHTIME.
FOLLOW OKAY. OKAY YEAH OKAY SO
ON THE MOTION TO REMOVE THE
RULES COMMITTEE CENTER
HERTZBERG ASK FOR NO VOTER
MELENDEZ AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA. NO NO ATKINS
FLOODING OFFICER NO BELL. WELL
NO BRADFORD NO CABALLERO NO
DODD. DODD NO TORONTO NO
GALGIANI. NO GLAZER. NO
GONZALEZ. NO HERTZBERG NO HELLO.
NO NO LISA. NO HER TADO NO
JACKSON NO LEYVA NO MCGUIRE NO
MITCHELL NO MONEY. NO NIELSEN I
PAN THOSE NO PORTANTINO. NO
ROTH. NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER NO
STERN NO I'M BURKE NO NO WHITE
HOUSE SKI. NO WIENER NO OKAY
NOW WILL MOVE ON TO A REMOTE.
OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY ABSENTEE
STUFF ON THE FLOOR ALLEN. NOW
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO A
REMOTE MEMBERS AGAIN THIS IS ON
THE- APPROVAL FROM RULES
COMMITTEE- SECRETARIES CONTINUE
THE ROLE. AT BATES. IT'S THE
MOTIONS WITHDRAW. HI FIFTHS
FORGES. WE'RE JUST ON THE
MOTION ONLINE FOR JUST I.
CHIANG. HANG ON THE MOTION
ABSTAINED. DALLY DALY ON THE
MOTION WITHDRAWAL. HI DALY I
GROWTH. BROKE ON THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW I. ROVE I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ ON THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW HI MELENDEZ HI MORE
LOCK. AFTER THE MOTION TO
REMOVE THE BILL FROM. RULES BY
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE MORRELL
MOTION TO WITHDRAW HI MORRELL
AYE WILK. WILK ON THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW HI WILK HI. OKAY RIGHT
SO THE EYES ARE NINE. OKAY
SERETSE ARE GROSS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE PREVIOUS- A
PREVIOUS SUBJECT MATTER THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN PASSED AND I DID
PUT IN THE CHAT BUT I'VE HAD MY
HAND SO THAT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
DISPOSED OF IT THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ON US. OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO THE MEASURE IS AYE AYES NINE
NOES TWENTY NINE THE MOTION
FAILS. OKAY THERE THEY SAY NO
ONE ELSE AT THE MICROPHONE A
MOTIONS- WE WILL NOW BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM IN
WHICH CASE WE WILL RESUME FLOOR
SESSION THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. SEE BACK AT THREE
THIRTY.
HE'S A COMMUNICATIONS
WILL BEGIN AND SIXTY WELL WE
ALREADY ANNOUNCED THAT WE'RE
GETTING STARTED LEGEND GERMAN.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY INTO PREP PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING ON
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRACTICE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. OUR
MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY ARE
CENTER MORLOCK. YOU ARE CENTER
IS YOUR HAND THERE AND JUST
MAKE SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME THEIR
CENTER CHIANG. THE CENTER
CHIANG ON THE NOT ON THE CALL
YET. SENATOR DOLLY. CENTER
CHIANG IS THERE VERY WELL THANK
YOU CENTER CHIANG TENER DOLLY.
AND SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER SKINNER ON THE
CALL I DON'T SEE HER ON THE
CALL. PERCENTER SKINNER HERE.
SHE MIGHT BE HERE ON THE FLOOR
OKAY VERY WELL. SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MOVE YOUR MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID US IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ALSO ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT A
MINUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
WILL ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY VIA TELEPHONE.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
TO ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION OR PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S.
1-844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO SIX SIX NINE
SEVEN. 052-669-7054 DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGNYOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT WHEN YOU ARE READY.
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING.
AND HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SIR FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I WOMAN MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE PERIOD
HEARING US CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
COME CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING
CYNICAL. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ARE. ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS. OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL WHEN PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND OF. MADAM CLERK DO YOU SEE
A QUORUM PRESENT. NOT YET. OKAY
WE WILL WILL MOVE FORWARD
NONETHELESS UNTIL MAYBE I'M
GIVEN AN INSTRUCTOR INSTRUCTION
AT ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD AS A SUB COMMITTEE
ON THE COMMITTEE TO HEAR
TESTIMONY ON THE TWO BILLS THAT
WE HAVE ON THE AGENDA TODAY
BEGINNING WITH SENATOR.
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD HERE A
2% A. B. NINE ONE THREE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU MR
CHEER ON SENATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE CALDERON I'M HERE TO
PRESENT. EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE.
AS WE ALL KNOW COLBERT NINETEEN
AS IMPACTED ELECTRICAL
CUSTOMERS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
INCLUDING UNEXPECTED CHANGES
AND LOAD AND GROWING ACCOUNT
DEBTS. MINIMUM THIS AMOUNTS TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT IS GONE UNDER COLLECTED.
THIS IS REVENUE THAT WAS
FORECASTED TO BE COLLECTED FROM
CUSTOMERS AND HAS ALREADY BEEN
DEEM JUST AND REASONABLE BY THE
P. YOU SEE. WITHOUT THIS BILL
THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY UNDER COLLECTIONS MUST
BE ADDED TO CUSTOMERS BILLS AND
TWENTY ONE. THIS BILL THIS
WOULD INCREASE. AFTER THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING FALLING UNDER
COLLECTIONS TO BE FINANCED AND
RECOVERED OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS. UNDER THIS BILL THE PC
MUST ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
FINANCE COSTS ARE JUST AND
REASONABLE. IMPART TO MISTER
CALDERON DISTRICT THIS AMOUNTS.
OF CUSTOMERS DEBT HAS DOUBLED
OR EVEN TRIPLED RESEARCH
CLEARLY MANY RATE PAYERS ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO TIME TO
VOTE WE SHOULD NOT AT A RATE
SPIKE ON TOP OF THEIR EXISTING
BILLS THIS BILL HELPS AVOID
THAT PROBLEM. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO AV TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE TO ASK TESTIFIED
ENHANCED ANSWER ANY. TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IS ADAM SMITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE WE
GO TO- MISTER ADAM SMITH WE
WILL I WILL LAST THE CLERK. TO
CALL THE ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM WESSEL PRESIDENT THERE
WAS A PRESENCE. MEISTER MORLOCK.
PRISONS SENATE AVAILABLE WAIT
FOR THE CAMERA TO CAPTURE YOU.
CINEMARK. BERLOCQ PRESS THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD HERE.
BRADFORD HERE. CHIANG THANK
PRESENT THANK PRESENTS. DOLLY.
KELLY PRESIDENT. TELL THE
PRESENCE DOT. YOUR MIKE. THERE
OKAY. THERE'S NO MIKE TERRA
CANOE STRAIGHT AGAIN. THIS WILL
HELP YOU. DOT HERE THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HERE HELLO. HELLO HERE HERE TO
THE MIKE THERE YOU GO. MCGUIRE
RUBIO PRESENTS PRESIDENT. RUBIO
SKINNER STERN DOZENS. INTO THE
MIKE PLEASE STERN PRESENT TURN
PRESENT. WIENER PRESIDENT. ALSO
CENTER WINNER TO THE MIKE AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN WINNER. PRESENT
THANK WIENER PRESENT. JERRY
HAVE CORN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE WILL- MOVE ON TO OUR THE
TESTIMONY AND WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE MISTER ADAM SMITH ON THE
LINE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL PART OF THE
PRESENTATION. YEAH YEAH. THANK
YOU. RIGHT CALIFORNIA SEN.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR- INTO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CENTER BRADFORD. THIS SUMMER
HAS SEEN A CONVERGENCE OF MANY
CHALLENGES PUTTING GREATER
FINANCIAL STRAIN ON
CALIFORNIANS DOES TRYING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AB NINE THIRTEEN
SIX ELEVEN ONE OF THOSE
FINANCIAL BURDENS BY PREVENTING
AN ANTICIPATED SPIKE THE
LECTURES TO BILLS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. INSTEAD SPREADING
THOSE COSTS. OVER TIME. THE
TOTAL PANDEMIC AND LET IT MAKE
IT CAN'T. HE SELECT CHRISTIE'S
AND AN INABILITY OF MANY
CUSTOMERS TO PAY THEIR BILLS.
S. C. EATING THE QC AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND WATCHING THESE
TRENDS CLOSELY WITH CONCERN.
INTERPRETING SEP IN A STATE OF
UNDER COLLECTION WHICH MEANS WE
HAVEN'T. YET TO RECOVER THE
COSTS THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
FOR RECOVERY IN RATES. THE
CURRENT REGULATORY PARADIGM
WOULD CATCH UP ON THOSE UNDER
COLLECTIONS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY RECOVERING
BACKLOG COST. YEARS IF WE DO
THIS WE CAN RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASE FOR
CUSTOMERS FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNDER
COLLECTION IN TWENTY TWENTY
THAT WAS RECOVERED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SB RAISED 7% ABOVE
FORECASTED LEVELS. S. B. HE
CURRENTLY ESTIMATES. THAT THE
RATE INCREASE FROM USED TO
AFFECT. CUTTING SALES AND- BAD
DEBT. COULD BE IN THE RANGE OF
47% IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
CANDIDLY NONE OF US KNOW HOW
LONG THIS PANDEMIC LAST. HOW
LONG THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY TAKE.
THIS BILL NINE THIRTEEN PUTS
THE RIGHT TOOLS. IN THE TOOLBOX.
KHALKHAL THIS CHALLENGE. IN
ORDER TO MODERATE THAT ABRUPT
RATE INCREASES STILL GIVE THE
PEACE THE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE
SECURITIZATION PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED COSTS. YOUR FINANCING
ORDERS WHEN UNDER COLLECTION
REACHES A SPECIFIED TRIGGER
POINT. I CENTER BRADFORD
MENTION THE BILL'S FOCUS ONLY
ON THE CAR COMMISSION HAS SEEN
JUSTIN REASONABLE AND THEREFORE
HAVE ALREADY APPROVED FOR
QUESTIONS YOUR LITERACY RATE.
BUILDERS AND ALLOW. SEAFOOD THE
RECOVERY OUT OVER TIME IF
APPROVED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. THE BILL
ALSO PROPOSES A TECHNICAL ONE
WORD DELETION THAT WOULD ALIGN
THE ELIGIBLE CLAIMS PERIOD IN
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WITH THE
UTILITIES INSURANCE POLICY
PERIOD. MINIMIZE COSTS REPAIRS
AND TECHNICAL FIX. BUT RIGHT
NOW ELIGIBLE CLAIMS ARE DEFINED
IN AB TEN FIFTY FOUR. ACCORDING
TO THE CALENDAR YEAR. HOWEVER
AS YOU KNOW WILDFIRE SEASON AND
INSURANCE COVERAGE CREATES
DON'T FOLLOW A CALENDAR YEAR.
ULTIMATELY GIVE THE FUND
ADMINISTRATOR CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY THE
ABILITY TO ALIGN THE ELIGIBLE
CLAIMS PERIOD WITH THE
INSURANCE POLICY PERIOD
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. AND
THEREBY BLOCKING SUBSTANTIAL
COST SAVINGS FOR ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS. REDUCING ELECTRICITY
BILL THIS TIME BACK ON THE
CONCERT TO HELP OUR CUSTOMERS
EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS FOR THESE
REASONS FC STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN AND URGES
YOU'RE ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW WE WILL- BRICK BEGIN
TO HEAR FROM ONE WITNESSES ANY
WITNESSES IN THE THAN THE
CHAMBER. HERE OF. THAT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
NINE HERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF. A.
B. NINE ONE THREE. ANYONE AND-
NO THE PEERS AND NOBODY IS
THERE. OKAY. WE WILL NOW MOVE
INTO WITNESSES WENT INTO
TESTIFIED VIA THE TELEPHONES
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE ONE THREE
WE WILL BEGIN NOW MODERATOR.
THANK YOU CALLERS ON THE PHONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO SHOW YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. ONCE AGAIN IF WE
COULD NOT PROMPT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. OF AB
NINE ONE THREE IF YOU WANT IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE AND YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE ONE THREE PLEASE THE
MODERATOR. PLEASE PROBLEMS THE
SPEAKERS. CERTAINLY AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SHARE YOUR POSITION
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINE ONE
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE ZERO
PLEASE. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME-
NO LINES IN Q. NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
HER NAME WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION. TO NINE
ONE THREE AB NINE ONE THREE.
SEE NON WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF IT AB NINE ONE
THREE ROOM ONE TWELVE NINE.
NONE ARE VISIBLE NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE OF THS
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT THEM TO INDIVIDUALS
WAITNG WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE ONE
THREE. THANK YOU STATE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. IT
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SHARE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION FOR AB NINE ONE
THREE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
LOCAL FIRST APPLYING FIFTY ONE
NINE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSUS BASS-
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO TAKE A FORMAL POSITION- BUT
WE HAVE. VERY GOOD QUESTION-
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT THREE
B. THAT COULD PUT PERMISSION
MAY FIND PROPER COVERING EACH
CUSTOMER CLASS BASED ON THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER COLLECTION-
WE THINK THAT NEED TO BE SHALL.
ASSIGN COST RECOVERY WHICH
SUCKED IN THE CLASS- HE- NEEDS
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
UNDER COLLECTION. THERE AND NOT
PUSHY UNDER QUESTIONS AROUND
THE OTHER CLASSES BUT WE WOULD.
ENCOURAGE THAT CONSIDERATION
AND THAT AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MONTEREY IF
YOU COULD PROMPT AND BIG. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIRED MEMBERS LIVING BRIKMAN
YANNI ON BEHALF OF CLECO THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION. AGAIN
THE BILL'S AMENDED- SO RECENTLY
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO TAKE A
<c.cyan>ORMAL POSITION BUT WE DO HAVE</c>
SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
LANGUAGE- THAT WE HAVE
REVIEWED. SIMILAR TO THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY GROUP SO.
WHAT BEST JUST TESTIFIED TO. I
DID HE HAVE THE- A VERY ROBOT
PRICE THAT IN THEY HAVE I'M THE
LACK AND IN OR TEN SOME OF
LANGUAGE. AND WE'RE HOW THE
RECOVERY WILL TAKE PLACE. MAY I
INTERFERE WITH THAT PROCESS. TO
THAT END WE REACHED OUT TO- SB
THAT SPONSORED THE BILL WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD SOME VERY FRUITFUL
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT TRYING
TO COME WITH TO A REVOLUTION.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO ME- IN THE
CREEK- UNITS CONVERSATION THAT
THERE WAS ANY INTENT BY ACCEDE
TO INTERFERE WITH THE PC
PROCESS AND HOW THEY DEAL WITH
UNDER COLLECTION RECOVERY THAT
UNDER COLLECTION. AND SO WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YASSER
YEAH WOULD HAVE TO BE ON A
RESOLUTION TO THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
MONTEREY CAN FROM THE NEXT P.
PLEASE. THANK YOU LOCAL CLINE
FIFTY TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS A-
HI MISTER CARE TO STASH ON THE
DEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICES ASIAN WERE
ACTUALLY HAD TO HEAR NOT NOT
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING WAS
INJURED THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- BUT THAT WE HAD WE HAVE
HAD. CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR- OR LAUNCH I'M SORRY WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE- AND THE
SPONSORS AND OUR ISSUE IS
WHETHER YOU KNOW THIS BILL IS
WHEN HIS SHIP DISTRIBUTION
COSTS ONLY- WE HAVE BEEN
ASSURED THAT BY BOTH IN SO.
THAT WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL- WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS CLARIFIED
TODAY- WE'RE ALSO SEEKING A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. ON
ISSUES WELL. WELL DO WE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. IT TIME. VERY WELL YOU FOR
MUCH MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR HURTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR ARM
YOU AYE AYE AYES STAND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
JUST WANT TO NOTE. AS WE
CONSIDER. AND HAVE CONSIDERED
FOR DECADES. TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. THE
NOTION OF SECURITISATION HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT WE'LL TALK ABOUT
IN THE NEXT BILL. AND IT'S JUST
I JUST FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY AREA WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO SMOOTH OUT APPROPRIATELY SO
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE-
SMOOTHED OUT THE CENTER
COLLECTION BY UTILIZING THIS
MECHANISM. AND HENCE WEATHER'S
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY RISKS
AND OR COSTS. TO RATEPAYERS I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO UTILIZE THIS
MECHANISM. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE FOLKS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS SOMEONE WITH A CHRISTINE
ARE YOU SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
ON THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF OF.
THE VARIOUS PARTIES TO TRY TO
GET THIS THING THROUGH SENATOR
BRADFORD AND HIS STAFF TOGETHER
WITH- MISTER CALDERON HIS STAFF
MR LIPPER. AND OTHERS BUT THIS
WAS A LOT OF WORK BUT IT WAS IT
WAS THE RIGHT IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST WHETHER IT WAS WHAT WE
DID WITH THE ENERGY CRISIS
TWENTY YEARS AGO OR- WHETHER
WILL PROPOSE IN THE NEXT BILL.
THAT IT IS INTELLECTUALLY
HONEST TO LOOK AT THIS TOOL. IS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT. THAT WE
WOULD UTILIZE IN DEALING WITH
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA AND FACING RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH S. RIVAL. VERY WELL
ANYONE ELSE- CENTER WINNER. AND
HILL AFTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I HAVE A QUESTION HE WOULD BE
FOR. A FOR ADDISON AS ONE OF
THEM WITNESS SINCE THE AUTHOR
MISTER CALDERON IS NOT PRESENT
IN THE BILL ITSELF. AND THE
QUESTION IS- THE ISSUE IS THAT
THE BILL I THINK IS A LITTLE
BIT VAGUE ABOUT WHETHER- CCA'S
I WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS- THIS
KIND OF- OF OUR FINANCIAL MODEL
AS WELL. I THINK THEY CERTAINLY
SHOULD BE- AND- I WOULD ASK
EDISON ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THIS
BILL CAME IN THE PRINCIPALLY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE POSSIBLE. TO AMANDA- BUT
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT AT
A MINIMUM WE COULD HAVE A%
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL TO
CLARIFY THAT THE INTENT IS TO
INCLUDE CCA'S SO MY QUESTION IS
TO A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
YES HELLO GENERATORS IN BALBOA-
CALIFORNIA SENATE YEAH WE I
THINK HAD INDEPENDENCE MANY
HEARD TODAY FROM THE
REPRESENTED FROM COUNTY CA SOME
REALLY GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH
THEM ABOUT- HOW THE CUSTOMERS.
THAT THEY REPRESENT AND IT
REALLY AREN'T WITH I HAVE USED
AND SHARED CUSTOMERS THE I USED.
TAKE CARE OF THE AND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM IN THE
DELIVERY OF ELECTRICITY IN SIX
YEARS- YOU KNOW HELP. RETURN
THE POWER THERE- THIS IS A- AND
OF THIS BILL THE D. IN OUR RACE
THAT WOULD TALKING ABOUT. WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WAS SHARE%
WITH ALL KINDS WHETHER YOU WERE
BY. ON THE HOW DOES HE SEE A-
OF POWER OR NOT IF HE- INVESTOR
ON YOUR TO INDUSTRY. PRINCIPLE
EDITION APART THE PC AND-
GRANTED US. THIS ACCORDING ON
THEIR CUSTOMERS THEY REPRESENT
IN A GIVEN YEAR PERCENT OF
SOMEONE SUGGEST. SIDE WE ALL
SHARE IN THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PROPOSAL I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
OTHER- AREAS- YOU KNOW HOW
QUICK EDUCATION UTILITY
RATEMAKING IS. RATHER INTENSE
BUSINESS I THINK HAVING GREAT.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM TODAY
AND WE- DEPLETE THAT. UNDER
YEAH. WE'LL CONSIDERING WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE YOU FOR I. HONEST
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL TO
THAT EXTRA IMPORTANT AND SO IN
CALIFORNIA EDISON PLEASE DON'T-
DON'T. LET US DOWN- ON THAT
WERE THIS IS A HI COMMITTEE IS
GONNA BE RECONVENING NEXT YEAR
AND I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE. THAT CONFIDENCE- THAT-
THAT THESE KINDS OF THINGS
HAPPEN BECAUSE IT REALLY SHOULD
BE INCLUDED. AND WILL BE
WORKING WITH MISTER TO SURE
THAT IT IS AN TO- WE HOPE GOT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
EXPRESSING. OF ALLENTOWN THANK
YOU. VERY WELL CENTER. THANK
YOU TO CHAIRMAN AND I WANT JUST
TO STAND AND- OF OUR CITY
SUPPORT OF US SENATOR WIENER'S
COMMENTS RELATED TO CCA'S AND
THEIR INVOLVEMENT AND HOPEFULLY
THAT CAN BE. ADDRESSED AND ALSO
IN. REFERENCE TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S. IN HIS OF.
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT TO THIS
OUTLINING THE BENEFITS OF
SECURITIZATION I THINK WE CAN
AGREE THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES IN CERTAIN TIMES
WHEN THAT IS CRITICAL AND- THE
NECESSARY ABOUT I LIKE TO ASK
THE OF. THE WITNESS FROM OF
THIS YEAR A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
IF I COULD- ONE IS. IT JUST FOR
ME TO GET THE CONTEXT AROUND
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE ACTUAL
NEED. THAT WERE EXPRESSING
TODAY IN THIS IN THIS
LEGISLATION- SO IT IT'S YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH UNDER COLOR HAVE
YOU ACTION. SO FAR THIS YEAR.
IN THE PANDEMIC AND IN THAT NOT
AN ESTIMATE FOR TWENTY TWENTY
TOTALLY WHICH IS FROM JANUARY
TO THROUGH AUGUST YOU. YOU HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS ARE. YEAH I'M
HAPPY TO PASS ALONG THE FIRM
NUMBERS- YOU TAKE CARE STAFF
AND I THINK THE GENERAL TREND
THAT WE'RE SEEING IF WE- YEAH I
KIND OF CONSIDER WHAT WE'VE
SEEN SO FAR UP TO THIS DATE FOR
THE END OF THE YEAR ON THE LOW
END. EDITION OKAY- THOSE TO
WHAT WE CALL KIND OF AREAS OF
UNDER COLLECTION. DECREASING
SALES NOW OF THE- YEAH BUILDING
QUINCY THAT TURNED TO BAD. WE
THINK ON THE END. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PLEASE JUST
PRESS ENTER ON SIX ON. MILLION
DOLLAR. IN THE YEAR TWENTY THAT
WOULD BE. PUT ON TOP OF RATE IN
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
COULD UNDO IT AND THEN ON THE
UPPER AND- BUT WE HIS. YOU GUYS
ARE YOU KNOW JOHN WITH THIS IN
REAL TIME I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING WITH IT
ON THE HIGHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM. EDITION CUSTOMERS
COULD BE FACING. SOMETHING
AROUND A BILLION DOLLARS ON
THE HIGHER EXTREME THE SUMMER
THAT KIND OF WHAT KIND OF THE
RANGE. UNDER COLLECTIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WOULD BECOME
AN ENTREE. INTO TWENTY ONE AND
HEARING CENTERS. FOR PER RATE
INCREASE. ON THE LOW END. THERE
IN TWENTY ONE WORK STATION 7%
RAY INCREASE. ON THE HIGHER END.
TWENTY ONE SO I UNDERSTAND SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT FROM JANUARY
THROUGH AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'VE HAD A SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR- REDUCTION OR
REVENUE. IS THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING. I'M SORRY THAT IT
HAPPENED AT THE TOTAL FORECAST
BASED ON THE TREND SO FAR- I
HAVE TO GET BACK TO ON THE
ACTUAL FIGURES WERE WHO WERE
LESS THAN THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION NOW- WE HAD SOME PRETTY
BAD MONTHS I THINK WE GOT A-
WARM NAY WHICH- IS ACTUALLY IT
IS NOT. HAVING A COUPLE MORE
MONTHS WHEN ELECTRICITY USAGE
INCREASES BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
USING THEIR EIGHTEEN HELPS. TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THAT.
DECLINING SALES. SO THIS IS
WHAT I NEED BEFORE CAN BASED ON
AND SEEN. SO FAR I CAN GET
CALLED AN YOUR ARE ABOUT THE
ACTUALS TODAY. WELL I MEAN THE
WEATHER'S ARE ONE THING WITH
THAT IS AN INDICATOR ROTH OR
REFLECT IN TERMS OF THE
REVENUE- FROM BUILD. AMOUNTS TO
COLLECT THAT AMOUNT WHICH IS
THE DISCREPANCY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO SECURITIZED. SO DO YOU
HAVE A NUMBER THAT FROM JANUARY
TO AUGUST THAT SHOULD REFLECT
WHAT YOU HAVE NOT RECEIVED FROM
YOUR BILLING AND HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE TO LAST YEAR'S PERIOD
OF TIME BEFORE WE HAD. THIS
PROBLEM. YEAH I CAN. I CAN
FOLLOW UP DIRECTLY WITH YOUR
STAFF WORKING GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT I COULD PULL IT UP RIGHT
NOW. OKAY. THIS AT ALL CENTER.
I'M SORRY- NO WELL. YEAH I AND
I DID HEAR MORE COMPLEX HE WAS
ACCUSED TRYING TO PULL UP THE
NUMBERS. YEAH I KNOW IT ANOTHER
QUESTION I CAN ANSWER THAT
HOMES. ARE YOU. LOOKING FOR
THAT. SORRY YES IT IS HERE GOT
IT HERE SO CURRENT TODAY. WHAT
I SAID I GOT MEMBERS. FOUR YOU
KNOW JUNIOR TODAY WE'RE SITTING
SOMEWHERE AROUND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF UNDER
COLLECTION AND I THINK OUR
PROJECTION FROM JULY TO
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE LOW END
SCENARIO IS ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION SO
THAT GETS YOU INTO THE REALM OF
SIX HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
YEAR SO WE'RE ABOUT. TO SEE IN
ABOUT HALF OF THAT TREND OKAY
ON THE LOW END SO FAR TODAY AND
HERE COMPOUND INTEREST SOMEONE
DOING THE SAME THING FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR AND WE MAY BE
IN THE SIX. AND YEAH SIX THIRTY
FIVE SIX FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
RANGE OF UNDER COLLECTION DRESS
FOR AT THE END AND THEN IT
NEEDS TRANSCEND CONTINUING
ESPECIALLY WITH- THE FUTURE I'M
GONNA CONSUMER BUILDING QUINCY
AND DAD DAD YEAH THE CREASE IN
THE WORLD WE'VE IN THE WAY THE
PLEDGE THAT WE WILL NOT BE TURN
OFF ANYONE'S POWER. DURING THAT
TIME OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP IN
THE PANDEMIC OKAY SO WE'RE
SITTING IN A PLACE WHERE
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE UNABLE PAY.
THAT DEBT AND BAD DEBT IS KIND
OF NEAT THE APPROVING AND BE
MORE AT. THE NEW ABOUT THE WE
ARE SEEING IS THAT ONE THING
THAT HAPPENED SPECTER MAYBE
THAT WILL BILLION SO TODAY
ACROSS WHEN I GOT THE NOW.
JANUARY TO JUNE IS AROUND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY RIGHT AND I
DON'T MY QUITE AND THAT WAS
WHEN THEY COME MY QUICK. NOW IS
HOW WILL HOW DOES THAT REFER.
ON LAST YEAR UNCOLLECTED.
REVENUE FOR THE SAME PERIOD OF
TIME. I'M TRYING TO GET A
COMPARISON WHICH LAST YEAR SO
HOW REFER HOW IT HOW IS COVERED
REFLECTED IN THIS. NUMBER YEAH
KNOW I HAVE TO GO BACK TAKE A
LOOK AT ACTUAL THANKS IS.
BETWEEN THE TWO I THINK THAT
WHEN I CAME HERE HE WAS SORT OF
OUR FORECAST RIGHT WHICH IS
INFORMED BY THOSE PREVIOUS
YEARS AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
LIKE MONTH BY MONTH IT'S A
MONTH WE'RE AROUND 7% UNDER
COLLECTED UNDER SOMEONE'S WHERE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LIKE I SAID A
WOMAN MONTH MAYBE 2% UNDER
COLLECTED THEN WE ONE COVERT
REALLY HIT APRIL YOU'RE 14%
UNDER COLLECTED VERSUS OUR
FORECAST. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL KIND OF BASED OFF OF YOU
KNOW WELL FORECAST WHICH IS THE
SALES EVERY YEAR AND WE'RE
WATCHING YOUR CAR AND
DISSIPATING GAIN A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF REVENUE FROM. OKAY
THAT. NUMBER KILOWATT HOUR. AND
IT RECEIVED OFF THAT CAPS TO
SPEAKING THE STATE. UNDER
COLLECTION SERVICE LIKE WHEN
KOBE PRINCESS. THE FIRST MONTH
EIGHT WHERE TO SACK. ABOUT 14%
DECREASE IN THE COLLECTED FROM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT INTO
IF I COULD S. SENATE BRADFORD.
A QUESTION TO AS AN IN YOU MAY
BUT WHY IS THIS DIRECTED ONLY
AT ELECT YOU. AND AN APK ADD OR
WATER UTILITY KNOWLEDGE SIMILAR.
ON MISTER CALDERON CHOI TO.
FOCUS ON THE LECTURE BILL I
THINK THAT A GREATER. ON ON THE
OVERALL UTILITY COST AND WITH
THE LOST REVENUES DURING THE
COLDER- SITUATION. IN LIGHT OF.
RESTAURANTS BUSINESSES IS BEING
CLOSED SO THEY'RE VERY DRAMATIC
IMPACT IN THAT AREA SO WE VERY
WELL PRATICA CAPTURED. WATERING
GASES WORLD BUT I THINK THE
GREATEST IMPACT HAS BEEN IN A
LOT TO CONSTRUCT. I COULD THANK
YOU. VERY WELL WILL TO SOME US
DALIO QUESTIONS COMMENTS. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I
GONNA TAKE A SENATOR HILL FOR
THEM HE ASKED ONE OF THE
QUESTION I WANT TO COMPARISON
FROM LAST YEAR TO THIS YEAR-
THE ONLY OTHER QUESTION I HAD
WAS- WE HAD BAD DEBT SO LISTS
FOR EXAMPLE IS A SAY THAT THERE
ARE COMMERCIALS RESTAURANTS OR
WHAT HAVE YOU. THAT YOU KNOW
BEEN GOING LONG NOT PAYING
THEIR BILL AND THEN THEY GO OUT
OF BUSINESS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THAT THAT DEBT YOU CAN'T
COLLECT IT IS IT GETS SPREAD
ACROSS THE PAYING CUSTOMERS
THAT. ARE LEFT IN THE FUTURE.
HE YEAH THAT'S RIGHT WE HAVE
HIM INTO THE PC YEAH THIS CASE
IN PROCESS FOR ASSESSING HOW
THAT. BAGHDAD WANT TO TERMS BAD
DEBT IS SOCIALIZED ACROSS THE
REMAINING CUSTOMER CLASS BUT
THAT YES- DAHLE YOU'RE RIGHT
THAT'S THE WAY IT GOES AND AS
YOU PROBABLY HEARD COME. SOME
OF THE COMMENTATORS I'M HONEST
A LOT OF THE POST OF THAT OFFER
COMMENTS STILL LEAVES MOST OF
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY ALL OF THOSE
DECISIONS ABOUT COST ALLOCATION
HEY DONNA SECURITIZATION TRUE
THAT PROBABILITIES. PROCESS AND
WE'RE IS NO WAY TRYING TO
CHANGE UTILIZED THE SAME.
FRAMEWORK FOR FROM IN CAN FOUR
AND WE CAN DISCUSS ARE BOUND TO
PAY THE HOW TO SOCIAL PUBLIC
YOU TO CAN. WHERE HE KNOW
PEOPLE YOU KNOW DATA AND
DIFFERENT COLOR OF VIEW AND
THAT REGULAR AGENCY TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A COMPROMISE THAT
WORKS. YEAH WELL ONE OF MY-
CONCERN IS THAT WE LEAVE IT UP
TO THEM YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAD
THE- ENERGY CRISIS. BACK IN THE
DAVIS ADMINISTRATION AND YOU
KNOW THOSE THOSE BILLS WERE CUT
OFF ON THAT. THE COMMERCIAL
USERS MORE THAN THE RESIDENTIAL
AND- AND I AM AFRAID IT TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
DID YOU KNOW THE RATES REALLY
GO OUT BUT NOT AT THE
RESIDENTIAL LEVEL- BUT THEY DID
SIGNIFICANTLY GO UP ON THOSE-
AND I'D- USERS THAT WERE WATER
PUMPERS AND FARMERS IN. AND
MANUFACTURERS ALIKE SO- I'M A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT
LETTING THEM JUST YOU KNOW PICK.
SPREADING OUT I WNT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MADE THATARE GETTING THIS.
RELIEF RIGHT NOW THAT. IS
ADVERTISED OVER TIME THAT THE
YOU KNOW HEY IT BACK AND IT
DOESN'T GET CAUGHT SHIFTED TO.
A SOMEBODY ELSE AND- BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE USING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
THE ONE THAT ASKED TO- THE BILL
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL A TODAY- BUT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THOSE TYPE OF GIMMICKS OR
OR SCENARIOS WHERE. THE PERSON
THAT RAN UP THE BILL. DOESN'T
PAY THE BILL AND IT GOES ON TO
SOMEBODY ELSE THAT'S NOT FAIR
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
MOVE. TO CENTER MORE LIKE DID
YOU WANNA. SAY SOMETHING THERE.
THANK YOU MEASURE- MAYBE JUST
TO RECAP BECAUSE I DID HAVE TO
LEAVE FOR A COUPLE SECONDS
BECAUSE MY HOT SPOT RAN OUT OF
JUICE BUT- IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
IS A TWO PRONGED CONCERN THE
PERSISTENT FACTOR. THE AB
ELECTRIC BILLS SO YOU'RE KIND
OF USING THE ACCOUNTS
RECEIVABLE LEDGER COLLATERAL
FOR THE LATE PAYMENTS AND THEN.
THE OTHER COMPONENT IS A YOU
HAD A DECLINE IN. SALES BECAUSE
OF THE WHOLE OF IT OR WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE. AND THOSE TWO
HAVE COME TOGETHER AND YOU ARE.
SORT OF LIKE THE WATER AGENCIES
THAT TOLD US TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF WATER WE USE FOUNDER
REVENUES DECLINED AND THEN
RAISED OUR RATES TO GET BACK UP
TO. A CERTAIN LEVEL SO I'M I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT A
COUPLE THINGS- YOU'RE SAYING
THAT WE HAVE TO GO TO THE SEE
IF YOU SEE BECAUSE OF A FIXED
RECOVERY CHARGE SAID AFTER.
CREWS. AND THIS. THREE FREES UP.
FINANCING WILL SMOOTH IT OUT
BUSH THE TIMING IS WE'RE SAYING
THAT. THE WHAT THE ELEGANT
SOLUTION TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
WOULD SAY THE SOCIALIZE THE
COSTS AND I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT
YOU CAN DO. IF YOU HAVE A RIVER.
THE NEW DECLINE IN THE FUTURE
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU DOING TODAY
GET READY FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SO THAT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
REPEAT THIS SHOW. YEAH. IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION ARMONK AND I'LL
I'LL TRY TO ANSWER THIS WAY I
THINK. THE UTILITY TAKES A LOT
OF PAIN AND REWORKS OF OUR
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO TRY AND
ELECTRICITY USAGE WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW OUR GENERAL RATE CASE
WORKS OUT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH WE
HAVE A NEW LEAD REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN OUR SYSTEM INVESTED
WILDFIRES SYSTEM HARDENING
SESSION CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. WE
HOW TO HELP WHAT IT'S GONNA
COST. AND DO ALL THE THINGS.%
YEAH WE NEED TO DO TO OUR
SISTER SAFE. AND AFFORDABLE
THEN WE KIND OF ASSUME AND
FORTY. YEAH USE WE'RE PRETTY
GOOD AT IT- YEAH ELLIPTICITY
SALES AND THAT'S HOW WE GET TO
OUR RATES AREN'T YOU SEE HOW
MUCH MONEY WITH YOU SEE
AUTHORIZES US TO. GET FROM
CUSTOMERS AND WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY KILOWATT
HOURS ARE GOING TO GET USE.
THAN WE COME UP WITH RATES IN
VERY CONCRETE FORMAT THE
PROBLEM THERE IS. YOU KNOW WE.
DIDN'T FORECAST A CO DEPENDENT.
YEAH DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW. I
DON'T THINK ANY. IN. RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEASURE.
OKAY VERY WELL AND MISSY DO WE
HAVE- ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
COMMENT. WELL THERE ARE NO MORE
COMMENTS SENATOR BRADFORD DID
YOU WANT TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR. DEGREE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE AND I.
THEY'RE NOT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
MISTER CALDERON BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AS A FORMER
EMPLOYEE OF INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY. AND STATE THAT. UNDER
COLLECTION IS NOT NEW. I JUST
THINK THE CURRENT SITUATION HAS
EXACERBATED A PROBLEM AND I
THINK IT ALSO SPEAKS TO THAT
ANTIQUATED. RATEMAKING SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS AS IT
RELATES TO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. AND THE P. YOU SEE.
AND THAT I WOULD DEFEND THE
FACT THAT. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AT A FAR HIGHER
BURDEN. AND POWER DELIVERY
VENICE CCA ALL CCA DOES ACQUIRE
THE POWER BUT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES RESPONSE FOR
DELIVERING POWER READ THE METER
DOING THE BILLING AND THOSE
COSTS ARE PART OF THOSE
STRANDED COSTS THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO RECOVER SO. IT'S
ABOVE AND BEYOND THEIR CORN IN
THE PURCHASING OF POWER BUT
IT'S THAT ACTUAL DELIVERY OF
THOSE POWER THE MAINTAINING
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS
BEEN FACTORED IN AND THEIR-
GENERATE CASE WHICH IS EVERY
THREE YEARS SO IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU CAN ADJUST THAT. ON THE WAY
HOME EVERY SIX MONTHS SO THIS
WOULD BRING US TO THIS POSITION
TODAY I THINK IT'S A FAIR.
PROCESS AND HOPEFULLY ONE THAT
WE WANT TO USE AGAIN BUT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COULD WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION HERE ALL SET CENTER
STERN SORRY. CENTER SURROUNDED
REQUEST TO SPEAK TO YOUR- I'M
SORRY CHARLIE INTENTIONALLY
OVERLOOKED FOR THREE FORTY I
KNOW I OF THE SPIN WANTED SAY
POINTS BY SEN HILL AND SENATOR
WIENER ABOUT- EQUAL TREATMENT
FOR ALL CUSTOMERS AS IN THE
RATE BASE INCLUDING CCA
CUSTOMERS APPRECIATE THAT- THE
ONE QUESTION WAS ABOUT WITH
THERE'S A COST ESTIMATE. OF THE
BOND ISSUANCE. IN OTHER WORDS
HOW. HOW HOW MUCH DO COST TO
ANTICIPATE I REALLY LIKE THE
DESIGN OF SMOOTHING OUT ANY
RATE IMPACTS FROM THIS UNDER
COLLECTION OF JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE IF ANYONE AS THE
MATH RIGHT. RIGHT NOW ON THE
ESTIMATES FOR THE COST OF
INTEREST PAID ON THE BONDS AND
HOW MUCH THAT WOULD ACCRUE TO
OVERTIME. CENTER BRADFORD OR OR
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION EDISON SHOULD
PROBABLY KNOW THIS ONE HAS.
YEAH ED IN ISRAEL HAS JUST
JOINED AGAIN I APOLOGIZE TO THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ADAM I'M
BACK. I'M COULD I GET THE
QUESTION WE ST I'M SORRY I
REALLY DID JUST ONE SIDE
SOMEBODY SENATOR STERN. SIR
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE IN
THE IN. THEY TALK TO I DO CALL
IS WITH COST OF INTEREST PAID
ON THE BONDS SAID JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE IF THERE'S ANY
INITIAL ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE
COST OF INTEREST MIGHT BE I
VERY MUCH. SUPPORT THIS AND-
LIKE THE IDEA OF SMOOTHING OVER
THE RATE IMPACTS JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE IF WE KNOW GOING
INTO IT WHAT THE COST WOULD BE.
YEAH M. I CAN TELL YOU WE JUST
RECENTLY. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
pFINANCING ORDER IN CONNECTION
WITH THE- AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
KIND OF THE WILDFIRE RELATED
COSTS THAT EXISTING FORTY OUT
THERE. AND WE'RE COMING IN
UNDER 3% ABSOLUTELY I THINK
WE'RE- SORT OF. HE THE GOING
RANGE RIGHT. EXCELLENTE YOU AND
IT SEEMS LIKE A TIMELY MOMENT
AND GIVEN THE COST OF BORROWING
IS INCREDIBLY LOW IT SEEMS
TIMELY THANKS. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I.
WHAT I ALSO WANTED TO RAISE THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR THE
CCA'S TO ALSO BE ABLE TO GET
THE KIND OF COST RECOVERY THAT.
WE ARE WHO WOULD BE PROVIDING
IN THIS BILL TO OUR I. O. U.'S
AND I REALIZE THAT THE CPUC
COULD POTENTIALLY DO THAT AND I
KNOW THAT EDISON IS NOW
ANSWERED IN MR- OR SENATOR-
WIENER RAISED IT BUT I WANTED
TO- JUST TO CONVEY IT BECAUSE I
THINK A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
IT'S GOT MAY BE NECESSARY SO
THAT THE CPUC REALLY DOES
UNDERSTAND OR INTENT AND I KNOW
THE AUTHOR WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE AUTHOR
NOT THE AUTHOR SO THE
REPRESENTATIVE MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFIRMATIVELY ANSWER BUT I
WOULD LIKE. THAT TO BE STRONGLY
CONVEYED- BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US I THINK THIS IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
APPROPRIATE BUT I ALSO THINK IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO EXTEND
THAT NOT ONLY APPROPRIATE BUT
NECESSARY FOR THE CCA'S. CENTER
WHERE YOU DIRECT YOUR QUESTION
WELL. I DON'T KNOW IF MR IF OUR
PRESENTER. CAN ANSWER FOR THE
AUTHOR OR NOT BUT. GREAT SO
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT I THINK
AGAIN THAT'S A REASONABLE
REQUEST BECAUSE THERE ARE COSTS
THAT ARE INCURRED- I'M JUST
SPEAKING TO THAT ASPECT OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY WORKS
THERE COST ARE GREAT. MORE
UNIQUE AND FAR GREATER. THAN A
PARTICULAR POWER SO THAT'S THE
POSITION AND I TRIED TO
ARTICULATE AND MY CLOTHES BUT I
THINK YOU HAVE A VALID ARGUMENT
AS TO. OTHER ENTITIES- BEING
ABLE TO RECOVER THEIR COSTS AS
WELL DURING THE DAY. UNDER
COLLECTION THANK YOU AND MAY BE
A I DON'T KNOW IF WE'VE EVER
DONE SUCH A THING FOR PERHAPS
THE COMMITTEE COULD CONVEY TO
THE AUTHOR WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. OKAY VERY WELL OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION. WE HAD CLOSING
COMMENTS QUICKLY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.AB NINE THIRTEEN
BY SIX SEVEN NUMBER CALDERON.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. SO
HI WESSELS I MORLOCK. BARLACH.
MORE LIKE Y. BRADFORD. MIKE
GIPSON PLEASE. YOU CAN ENTER.
ALL RIGHT THE THIRD SEVENTY.
FIVE BRADFORD I THINK HE'S IN
THE- CHANGE HEY I. THANK BY
DOLLY DALY HI DALY I DOT HI
THOUGHT I. HERTZBERG BY
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI HILL HI
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO. INTO THE MIKE. IF
YOU COULD SPEAK INTO THE MIKE.
RUBIO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RUBIO AYE THANK YOU SENATOR.
SKINNER SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STERN FIVE
WIENER.FIVE OKAY THAT IT
WIENER I. THIRTEEN AS CHAIR
OKAY THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER BRADFORD WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL THE
NEXT BILL IS- A. B. SIX ONE SIX
FIVE NINE BEING PRESENTED TODAY
BY CENTERS HERTZBERG AND ALLEN
IS HELEN HERE TO PRESENT WITH
YOU OR YOU CAN BE PRESENT IN A
LONG. WE CAN HEAR YOU SO AS
LONG AS YOU ARE HERE YOU CAN
PERCENT WHATEVER YOUR YEAH
MISTRETTA I'D LIKE TO IF I CAN
JUST WAIT A FEW SECONDS AND- WE
WANT TO CENTER ALLEN TO LEAD
OFF AND I'LL FOLLOW UP ON. THE
PRESENTATION FOR JUST A MOMENT
IS IT POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO START
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE HIM JOIN
AYE I'D LIKE IF WE JUST TAKE A
MOMENT IT'S POSSIBLE IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU CAN'T COME IN A
MINUTE ALL OF START. THERE
COMES LESS THAN A MINUTE. YEAH.
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM OUR CHAIR-
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE IN YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE GOT AND NORMA'S
PROBLEMS ON OUR HANDS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE FIRES THAT ARE BURNING
THE STATE WE DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE FIRE CHALLENGES- THIS BODY.
PASSED A BOND MEASURE LAST YEAR
THAT AND REFLECTED THE NEEDS
AND INTERESTS AND CONCERNS-
PARTICULAR WITH REGARDS TO
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY OF ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS I WAS IN SB FORTY
FIVE OBVIOUSLY NOW AND THAT IS
NOT HAPPENING BUT WE WORK-REALLY HARD TO CREATE. A SERIES
OF EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MOST
PRESSING NEEDS IN THE STATE HAS
REGARD TO CLIMATE RESILIENCY
PARTICULARLY IN THE SPACE OF
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY AND THAT IS
INCLUDED FUNDING FOR EVERYTHING
FROM FROM. ARE CONSERVANCIES IN
AND WORK THAT THEY DO IN
REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK TO- TO
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
NOT AND THEN WILD ISLAND URBAN
INTERFACE. WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD- PARTNERS IN
IN FIRE FIGHTING- AND SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO ROLL THOSE. NEEDS AT LEAST
SOME OF THOSE EXPENDITURES INTO
THIS PACKAGE. OBVIOUSLY CENTER
HERTZBERG GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
FINANCING BUT IT'S A CAREFULLY
CRAFED. A PACKAGE THAT COMES
OUT OF THE WORK THAT HAPPENED
WITH SB FORTY FIVE. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AND WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO I'D LIKE TO I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THE DETAILS OF THE
FINANCING. OUTSIDE THE DETAILS
OF EXPENDITURES BUT- WITH WITH
WITH THAT I LOVE TO PASS IT
OVER TO SET HER STRAIGHT TALK
ABOUT. THE FINANCING MECHANISM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALLEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE
MEMBERS- I WANT TO JUST RAISE A
COUPLE OF ISSUES. THAT A PART
OF THIS LARGER DISCUSSION. ONE
EMPHASIZE WHAT. SENATE ALLEN
TALKED ABOUT. FOURTEEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED FIREFIGHTERS RIGHT
NOW IS RECEIVING THIS COMMITTEE
ARE FIGHTING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIRES ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BRIEFING THIS
MORNING. ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
ACRES THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE LAST YEAR LAST
YEAR AT THIS TIME ONLY FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES. WE ARE
FACING AN EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE. THE QUESTION IS WHAT
ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT IT. WELL
THESE UTILITIES THAT ARE SO
ANXIOUS. NOT TO APPLY THIS
FURTHER TO THE IF THIS FURTHER-
EXTENSION OF MITIGATION. WE'RE
FUNDAMENTALLY ANXIOUS LAST YEAR
TO UTILIZE THIS VERY MECHANISM
TO IMPOSE ON RATEPAYERS
SUPPOSED TO SHAREHOLDERS THE
ABILITY TO TRYING TO LATE. THE
VICTIMS A FIRE SET DEFAULT
TRIANGULATED INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN
NOW. IT DOESN'T WORK AND I HAVE
SOME THEORIES ON THAT. THINK
ABOUT THIS FOR A MINUTE. NOT
ONLY FACING WHAT WHAT I JUST
EXPRESSION WOULD CENTER ALLEN
EXPRESSED BUT COMPARE THAT TO
THE ESTIMATED FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR HIT TO RATE PAYERS FOR
COST OF THE WILDFIRES THAT HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS MEASURE IS A
BARGAIN. IN TERMS OF PREPARING
FOR MITIGATING THE PROBLEM. TOO
OFTEN IN POLITICS WE SPEND THE
TIME RACING UP TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM AFTER THE AIRPLANE IS
AT THE BUILDING. THIS MEASURES
ABOUT DOING MITIGATING MEASURES
TO AVOID THAT BEFORE IT EVER
HAPPENS. THE EXACT SAME FUNDING
MECHANISM COUPLE OF OTHER
ARGUMENTS I WANT TO JUST
ADDRESS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
ME AT LEAST SO. IS TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT THIS SURCHARGE IN
THIS MEASURE. EXTEND THE IS NOT
APPLIED TO QUALIFYING LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS A CUSTOMER'S
YORKSHIRE CITIES FOR MEDICAL
NEEDS. BUT ARGUMENT IS OF THIS
HURTS LOW INCOME FOLKS NOT TRUE.
SAME MECHANISM THAT THE SENATOR
DODD AND OTHERS HAD WORKED ON
LAST YEAR IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
EXACTLY APPLIED HERE EXACTLY
APPLIED HERE. THE OTHER ISSUE
IS. THIS LARGER DYNAMIC ABOUT.
THE IMPACT ON RATEPAYERS AND
WHETHER OR NOT. THIS IS FAIR
WELL THIS BILL SAYS AND TO
AVOID ANY ISSUE I WANT TO QUOTE
PAGE NINE. LINES TWENTY NINE OR
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH THIRTY
WHERE IT SAYS. THE MONEY SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED PROPORTIONALLY
WITHIN THE SERVICE AREA OF THE
LARGE ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
AND EXCLUSIVELY WITHIN THE
SERVICE AREA WITHIN THESE
AREAS. IT'S THAT'S ONE
REFERENCES ANOTHER REFERENCE ON
PAGE TWENTY LINE TWENTY NINE.
THE POINT IS THAT IF THIS IS
RATEPAYER MONEY. THE RATEPAYER
MONEY IS TO BE UTILIZED ONLY IN
RATE SO SAN DIEGO AT SAN
DIEGO'S MONEY P. JEANNIE IT'S
MONEY AND EDISON IT'S MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THESE
CHALLENGES WITH THESE FIRES ARE
SO. AND CLIMATECHANGE AND THE
NUMBER OF LIGHTNING STRIKES IN
THE IMPACT YOU KNOW SOMEONE
ARGUES WELL THESE WERE CAUSED
BY LIGHTNING STRIKES WELL LET'S
ASSUME THAT. THE LIGHTNING
STRIKES THEN CAUSED A SPARK IN
THE TRANSFORMER AND YOU CAN'T
MAKE A DETERMINATION. WE'RE
TRYING TO MARY WHAT WE DID LAST
YEAR TEN FIFTY FOUR. WITH A
VERY ELEGANT APPROACH IN TERMS
OF WHAT CENTER ISLAND SENATORS
STARTED. SEVERAL MULLIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER C.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. EVERYBODY
SPENT WELL OVER TWO YEARS
NEGOTIATING OF COURSE ARE. THE
STEAM. ORTHODOX MEMBER OVER
THERE SENATOR STERN BEGAN WHO
WORK SO HARD ON THIS TO TRY TO
MARRY THESE TWO CONCEPTS AT A
TIME WHEN WE'RE FACING SUCH A
CRISIS WHERE WE HAVE SPENT
YEARS WORKING LITERALLY ON THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE FINANCIAL
PIECE AND YEARS WORKING ON AND
PULLING OUT OF THE THOSE BOND
MEASURES THAT WE'RE GONNA GO ON
THE BALLOT OR SOME DISCUSSION
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT BONDS BUT
THIS ISN'T BONDS THIS IS RARE
MONEY. REDUCING THEIR RISK
PROFILE IN THIS REGARD. AND THE
ARGUMENT THAT I'VE HEARD FROM.
I GET IT I SAW. US ONE OF THE
SENATORS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT AND
REPAIRS HE'S RIGHT. LARGE
REPAIRS THEY PAY MOE. WE HAVE
OBSERVED JURISPRUDENTIAL MATTER
MAY DETERMINATION THAT POOR
PEOPLE PAY LESS. RESIDENTIAL'S
PAY SOME PORTION AND
COMMERCIALS PAY MORE THAT HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT THIS BODY
HAS DIED IN THIS GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE FOR MANY YEARS NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT. BUT RIGHT NOW AS WE
STAND HERE TODAY THERE'S NO
INCREASE IN FEES IT'S EXACTLY
THE SAME FEE. THAT B. IS BEEN
EXTENDED UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT CENTER DODD INCIDENT OF A
SUMMER HOLDEN OTHERS NEGOTIATED
UP UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
AND THIS JUST SIMPLY EXTENDS
THIS TIME FOR IT TO BE ABLE TO
GET A REVENUE STREAM AND
SENATOR STERN WAS JUST TALKING
IS IT RELATED TO THE LAST
MEASURE ABOUT HOW CHEAP MONEY
AS EVERYBODY WE TALKED TO ALL
THE EXPERTS SAY. NOW IS THE
TIME TO THINK ABOUT THIS IS I
CLOSER TO PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS MONEY IS THE
CHEAPEST IT CAN BE. FOURTEEN
BASIS POINTS ON A TWO YEAR
TREASURY THAT'S LITERALLY JUST
A LITTLE MORE THAN A TENTH OF A
PERCENT. THE COST OF MONEY IS
THE LAST. AND TO. WHEN WE
SPACED FORTY BILLION DOLLARS OF
RISK FROM THE LAST SET OF FIRES
WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THE BIGGEST
I THINK SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT
AS THE BIGGEST. NOW IN STATE'S
HISTORY IF NOT PRETTY CLOSE. N.
SHOULDN'T WE INTELLIGENTLY
THINK THROUGH AND PLAN IN
ADVANCE SHOULD WE LIMIT WHAT
THAT RISK IS TO HELP EVERYBODY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS ONLY
DOES IT FOR THE SERVICE AREAS.
BUT IT IS INDEED A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH. THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS LAST MINUTE BY ITS
NATURE BUT IS JUST COBBLING
TOGETHER. WELL DEVELOPED
COMPONENT PARTS. THAT INFORMED
ONE OF THE BIGGEST EMERGENCIES
WE'VE EVER FACED IN CALIFORNIA
ON TOP OF THE OTHER BIGGEST
EMERGENCIES WE'VE EVER FACED IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THAT I WANT
TO JOIN WITH SENATOR ALAN.
SEMIR BLOOM MULLIN THE TWENTY
THIRTY FROM FORTY SOME CO
AUTHORS IN BOTH HOUSES THAT
ARE. WORKING HARD TO DEAL WITH
THIS EMERGENCY THAT WE'RE
FACING THANK YOU. ALL WE HAVE
IS WE HAVE AS WITNESSES EXCUSE
ME WE'VE GOT TO WITNESSES WITH
US FIRST TODAY'S MISTER SCOTT
WHICH REPRESENT A COALITION. OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY WORKERS TO
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDS THE RSK
IS MEMBERS TOGETHER WITH STACY
HEATON WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ALSO UNDERSTANDS
EXTRAORDINARY RISK THAT THEIR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN FACING
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER. TO MISTER WHICH IF THAT'S
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN YES MISTER
WHICH. REYES WEISEN MIKE NINE
OPERATING. CAN WE TRY AGAIN
MISTER MUCH YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF SCOTT WENT TO BE HAPPY CAL
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES I'D LIKE TO EXPLAIN
TO THE COMMITTEE WHILE WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WHY THE
OPPOSITION'S OPPOSITION IS
SHORT SIGHTED. WE KNOW THE
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
LINES START FIRES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE UTILITIES
JURISDICTION OVER CLEARING OF
THE BRUSH OF DEBRIS AND TREES
IS LIMITED TO FIFTEEN FEET A
MERE FIFTEEN FEET AROUND THOSE
POWER LINES WHEN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FUEL IN THE
FORESTS IS NOT AROUND THE
POWERLINES. SO YOU TO HE'S IN
RATEPAYERS FACE THAT MASSIVE
LIABILITY THEY WILL HAVE TO PAY
EVENTUALLY WE HAVE SUCH A HUGE.
GROWTH BECAUSE OF DEAD TREES
DUE TO DROUGHT IN BEATLES. WE
NEED TO CLEAR THAT FUEL OUT OR
UTILITIES AND RATEPAYERS AND MY
MEMBERS WILL SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES IN THE LONG TERM
THAT'S WHY THIS MEASURE IS
FORWARD THINKING AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY
WELL. MRS HE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. I'M HERE TO
REPRESENTS THIRTY SEVEN RURAL
COUNTIES STATEWIDE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE STARKLY
BORNE AND JORIEN DESTRUCTION
CAUSED BY HIGH SEVERITY
WILDFIRES BUT YOU ALL KNOW AND
WE'VE ALL SEEN THAT RESEARCH
HAS NOW BECOME A WORSENING
STATEWIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS. WILDFIRES ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
COMPROMISED THE QUALITY AND
QUANTITY OF MUCH OF THE STATE
WATER SUPPLY WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT AND THE FIRES
ACTIVELY CONTRIBUTE TO AIR
POLLUTION IN PROFOUND WAYS THAT
EVEN AIRPORT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO QUANTIFY ADEQUATELY AT THIS
POINT. AS EVIDENCED BY THE PAST
FEW WEEKS WE KNOW THE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES HAVE A WIDE
RANGING I NEED AND CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE LONGER WE
KEEP DELAYING MEANINGFUL LARGE
SCALE WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
BUT JUST WANT OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL IN FAVOR OF A MORE
REACTIONARY RESPONSE THE MORE
WEEK AFTER WEEK LAST IMPACT ON
OUR COMMUNITIES FORCED WATER.
AND AGRICULTURE AND THE MORE WE
CONTINUE TO STAND ON FIRE
SUPPRESSION AND. REBUILDING
EFFORTS IN THE LONG RUN. THE
LIBRARY. EVERYONE IN STATE FARM
RENDON IN THE TRYING TO ENSURE
THEIR HOME TO CENTRAL WORKER
THAT WORK. AND SMOKE FILLED
KITCHEN. SO SOME OF CAL.
LARGEST INTO WHOSE CROPS ARE.
BY THE CHANGE THE FILE SMOKE.
AND NOTHING. HE FIRED ARE
COSTING REAL HE LIVES EACH YEAR
AND OUR COMMUNITY. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL COULD
FINALLY PROVIDERS- WE NEED
TWENTY STRANGE MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE STATE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EMERGENCY
RESPONSE HOLD. AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY. URGE
OR EITHER TODAY THANK YOU. VERY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL MOVE ALONG TO. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS MEASURE. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH SPEAKERS
HERE. I CAN BARELY CHEERLEADER
SEE YOUR FACE ANYWAY PLEASE
PICK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BY
PHONE ON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON APPLE SUPPORT
RIVERLANDS TRUST'S SECTION
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE A OF
THIS BILL THE FINES- ENTITIES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOME OF THE
FUNDING USES A TERM CALLED
QUALIFIED NON PROFITS BUT IT
DOES NOT ESTABLISH. HAT A
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT IS WE
SUGGEST USING LANGUAGE LIKE AN
ACCREDITED LAND TRUST A
NONPROFIT THAT HAS A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM EITHER
PARTNERING WITH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS OR SCHOOL-
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
GALLERY OKAY WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THERE IS NO ONE
PRESENT. WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY BY
TELECONFERENCE FIRST MODERATOR.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. A. B. I'M SORRY
THIS BILL IS AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE- MODERATOR THANK. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX FIVE NINE
YOU PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL LINES IN Q. EIGHT LOCAL.
RESEARCHER WILL GO TO THE FIRST
LINE. I DO APOLOGIZE MISTER WE
ABLE TO GO TO THE FIRST LINE.
YES YES PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS MARK PENSION BAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL TOWN
LOTTERY DEEPLY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION RESOURCE
CONSERVATION. DISTRICT WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO THE
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. BLIND SIX
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BEING HAD CHANGED-
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
BELMONT IN SUPPORT IF YOU. WITH
REGARD TO THE NEXT BIGGER PLACE.
THE LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF BILLS FOR EVERYONE
IN THE COURTS. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK SPEAKER. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER JERRY
MEMBERS VISITING L. LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS GREATER
VALLEY CONSERVATION CORPS AND
CONSERVATION CORPS NORTH
STAYING STRONG SUPPORT. BROUGH
WILL THANK YOU MODERATOR NICK
SPEAKER. BLIND SIXTY SEVEN SIX
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST LITTLE WITH
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE HERE
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING NEXT SPEAKER
MODERATOR. NINE FORTY FOUR FOUR
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOCELYN AND I'M EXPECTING
SUPPORT PARTY THE ONE SIX FIVE
NINE ON BEHALF OF THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLAY MODERATE. BLIND
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BOARDROOM REPRESENTING THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY
WATER OUR BOARD IS TAKING A
SUPPORT IN AMENDED PETITION TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR FIRE
IMPACTED WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WATERSHED IN DOUBLE THE
LANGUAGE OF FUNDING REGARDING
THE PLANET KERR CANAL TO
INCLUDE OTHER WATER CONTAINS
IMPACTED. SERGEANTS THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR NICK WEEK PLEASE.
BLIND EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THE HIGHER
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE IT IN
TEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE
AND ARE NOT SUPPORT BUT WE'RE
NOT OPPOSING I HOPE THIS IS THE
RIGHT KIND SHOULD. CONCERN
ABOUT THE INTERNET CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE WITH AT EIGHT AND YOU
FOR COMBATING FIRED AND MAKING
FIRING AND MAKING COULD TEACH
ME THREE CATASTROPHIC WHY IN
ETERNITY EVENT. HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION AS TO THE
ELLAGIC OF LOCAL IN BILL AND
AFTER THE INCLUDE A PRESS
DISTRICT AND HELL NO INCOMING
THE DECATUR SPECIFIED GREAT IF
HOW IT REMAINS LIKE IF OTHER
DISTRICTS. TO OCTOBER FOR THE
SAME WAY OUR ELIGIBLE EVEN
AFTER EVEN SURE THAT THE VITAL
PART THE MILD RICHARD ARE NOT
ANY EXCLUDED I THINK YOU ME AND
MY WORK ACROSS THE DIVIDING
IMPACT WITH OUR MEMBERS INITIAL
SUGGESTS THAT THE MECHANISM
POTENTIALLY PLACING. I DO COSTS.
IT MAY BE THAT THE BENEFIT THE
COSTS WE WOULD THAT AND- THAT
YOU MAKE THAT THE PROGRAM
FUNDED ARE. AND RIGHT AND HAVE
AT THE AS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATE NXP. THREE
NINE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARYLAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BETH AND POLITICAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AND I'M
EXPECTING SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND THE
FOURTEENTH CERTIFIED LOCAL CORD
THAT REPRESENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT PICKER
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY FIVE TWO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS A- MISTER
SHARON NUMBERS THIS IS ERIN
ADVANCED ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
PART OF THE FRAZIER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NICK
SPEAKER PLEASE. KLEIN TWENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN PAYING OFF
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY SUPPORT OF AB I THINK
THE THING THAT I HAVE PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
AND ALSO. WANT TO THANK OFTEN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON.
THE DOWN THE BURKE COUNTY
PARTNERS. THANK YOU MODERATOR
BAKER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY NINE
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
APPARENTLY. THE PRESIDING
CAUGHT FIRE FIREFIGHTERS AND
THE RESOURCES LEGACY FUND OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
THERE ARE HISTORIC FIREARMS IN
A NEW NORMAL WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING IS THAT BOTH THOSE
DESCRIPTIONS RK ARE SPEAKING OR
SUPPORT FASTERHIS HAIR TO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT
CHAIRMAN IS ONLY AUGUST IS ONLY
AUGUST AND WE ARE FACE SOME
LARGEST THE SECOND AND THIRD.
LARGEST TIRE NAME OPPOSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE MR WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO MAKE A STRONG
INCREDIBLE. STATEMENT THANK.
THANK YOU GOING NEXT. IS MR.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE- JUST
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS NATALIE
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
THE LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS
MAN TRAPPED IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE OVER THE
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE AND PLEASE
ONLY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. NINE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE BRAIN BUT AT THE ON
BEHALF OF YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
RECOGNIZE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
BEEN ON THE INTERNET AND THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. VERY LONG NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. DELINE SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS NATALIE
BERGERON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND A
COMPUTER CREEK CONSERVANCY OR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT BAKER. NINE THIRTY THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS SEAN REAGAN
ON BEHALF OF CREDIT EOC LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. VERY WELL THANK YOU A
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER. NINE
FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS ONLY
PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BECOMES MODERATOR. NINE
FORTY NINE FOUR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTEO CHROME
HAPPENED MOUNTAINS RECREATION
AND CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER. NINE SIX
SIX SIX SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOUNG NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. SEVENTY EIGHT
NINE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER TWO CHARGES COULD
NOT HAVE COOL COALITION BUCKLEY
URGING HERE EITHER DID YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE
TWENTY FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF. WHAT
OPENS TRUST THE BIG SUR LAND
TRUST AND SANTA CRUZ WATER
DEPARTMENT INTO COURT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE FIFTY
FOUR FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS DO KERNEY ON
BEHALF OF THE WEYLANDT. I MEAN
PLANT. ALSO WE DON'T WORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
PLANKS EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KAREN MEMBERS OF THE
CEREBELLAR REPRESENTING
SEMPERVIRENS FUND IN SUPPORT.
BROUGH ON XP KERR. ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA I'M ANDREA
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THE
NEXT BIGGER. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
ALL YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS AFRIKA VARGAS AND FOR
THE SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION RECALL.
THANK YOU. VERY WELL OF ARE
THERE ANY MORE SPEAKERS AS
MODERATOR. WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
MORE IN LINE. I'M CLINICS
BECAUSE PLEASE. PRETTY GOOD
LINE SIX THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ARBEL CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON OFFICIAL
WANTED TO BUILD A ON BEHALF OF
THE SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS OF
TOGETHER BAY AREA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY WELL
NEXT PICTURE PLEASE. NINE EIGHT
THREE EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS THAT DID MY CLIENT ON
BEHALF OF CLIENT WATER
AUTHORITY THE POOR AND NEEDY.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS. YES OUR
OUR FINAL LINE IN QUEUES LINE
SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BUCKS I'M EXPRESSING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE L. A.
CONSERVATION CORPS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE THANK YOU.
VERY WELL. ANY OTHER SPEAKERS.
NO NO FURTHER LINE IN Q. WE
WILL NOW WILL COME TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS I WOULD WISH SPEAK
CENTER HILL. LAKE EFFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
AND- YOUR THIS IS THIS BILL IS
A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
REVIEW AND YEAH THE FASTER
CERTAINLY THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRE. THE WILDFIRES IMPACT
NOT. JUST YESTERDAY MY
CONSTITUENTS WERE ABLE TO MOVE
BACK INTO THEIR HOME THOUGH.
AFTER DAYS OF BEING EVACUATED
YES ARE. I DIDN'T OPPOSITION I
THOUGHT. BUT THAT WAS OKAY VERY
WELL G. DIGITALIZATION YEAH
WE'RE GONNA GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION I'M SO SORRY ABOUT
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO GO- TWO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE MARK TONY WITH THE UTILITY
REFORMNETWORK AND CAN WITH ANY
GAS ELECTRIC ON THE LINES.
WE'LL START WITH MARK STONE IF
HE'S IN LINE NOT WILL GO TO.
CAN CAPS. SURE OKAY THANK YOU
MARK COUNTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF KERN. REPEAT OKAY NO I'M A.
FIFTEEN NINE. REYES BLACK YEAR
ON THE WHILE. DR BY THE- PAID
FOR BY GRAY HERE COULD BE. TEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
FORTY THREE AB TEN FOUR LARGER
RATE HERE INCREASE HISTORY. I'M
HAPPY THAT THEY'RE BILLION MORE
DOLLARS AND REYES HERE AND THE
FULL COOPER MITIGATE CURRENTLY
EIGHTY FIFTY P. WE. AB FIFTY
NINE IS NOT SHORT OF LAND
MINUTE BACK ROOM. REYES. I
BELIEVE I'M OKAY I FOUR GREATER
HERE MY WHILE MANY ONLY TO YOUR.
TO RIGHT NOW HEY LATE THEIR
BOSS HEY BUT YOU COSTA RICA.
BARRING THREE BILLION NOW BUT
THE LADY BIRD READ UNTIL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT REYES HERE
HEY OFF TO SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN. CRITICAL. THIRTY
UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY ONE NOT
THREE ONE PERMITTED SHOULD BE
PAID FOR BY ACT FUNDS IT IS
BARMORE WELCOME PAPER
POLITICALLY. THAN LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME. END UP WE'RE
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TROUBLING IS THERE MIGHT YOU'D
BE BILL WITH YOUR OF BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IS WHO. ONLY BE OF.
YEAH BECAUSE HE TO LOSE WEIGHT
THERE ACT BOOKS DOES NOT. RIGHT
PLEASE VOTE NO. THE FACT ON THE
ARE YOU CUSTOMERS THE PAPER
PROGRAMS COMPLETELY UNRELATED
TO ELECTRIC UTILITY SERVICE.
LOSING MUNICIPAL PROVIDERS FROM
PAYING FARE. WILDFIRES
INCLUDING THOSE STARTED BY
LIGHTNING STRIKES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO HIRE YOU SERVICE
TERRITORIES. EVEN IF COMPLETELY
UNFAIR AND THE PROGRAM SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED FOR WHAT THEY ARE
ATTACKED. THEY WERE BY ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE NOT JUST
FOR CUSTOMERS WILL BE BEDROOM
YOU. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE
MANDATE BECAUSE YOU'D BE A ON
BY PATH WILL BE TO PAY.YET
WHEN DIRECTED DO SO. UNDER AB
TWO FIFTY DO YOU DO YOU CAN
NAME CUTLER'S AND OTHERS FROM.
AND INSTEAD. THOSE GREAT
BLOWING THAT CHARGE RIGHT NOW
MILLION L. CAMINO LOWER INCOME.
CUSTOMERS WHO CANNOT INTO SOLAR
AND OTHER STUFF WITH IT
PANDEMIC WILL FORCED PICK UP
THE- COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY AB
NINE ONE TO HELP. REYES
INCREASES THE NOTRE COMBAT THAT
CAUSED BY THE- YEAH BUILDER
COMPLETE ALL. NOTED CAN FOUR
REQUIRES. AND CUSTOMERS EACH
PROVIDE TEN POINT BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE SEVERAL CAN
MITIGATE BALLPARK RIGHT AT YOU
KILLED. IN WHILE OUR MEDICATION
PLANS. OFF REPAIRS MORE.
COMMITTEE L. NOTE THE IMPACT OF
THOSE VERY CHARGES AND REYES OF
pTO REPAIR STATE STAND BY LIKE
STRIKE BECAUSE FIRES. WATERING
FOR. AMONG OTHER THAT AREN'T.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR- TO
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. AND ON
BEHALF OF ARE YOU. REACT FOR
MOBILE. VERY WELL THANK YOU
WILL GO TO SPEAKER. HERE AND
GALLERY OFFICE. ANYONE WHO IN
THE GALLERY WHICH TO SPEAK
OFFICE. OF AB SIX FOR NINE. NO
ONE IS CURRENTLY VISIBLE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
SEEMS TO BE A VISIBLE THERE
EITHER WE'LL GO NOW TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES IF ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WISHES TO SPEAK
AGAINST A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE MODERATOR PLEASE- Q. THE
SPEAKERS TO SEE HOW MANY ARE
HERE TO SPEAK. AGAINST SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THE STATE YOUR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE SIX FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YOU CAN THAT COMMANDERS ONE OF
THEM ZERO. YOU KNOW. SORRY
PLEASE CALL THE SPEAKERS MISTER
MODERATOR. BUT DID YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TOTAL MISTER CHAIR DID
YOU WANT TO JUST GO THROUGH
THEM YES PLEASE WHAT IS THE
TOTAL. SIXTEEN WE HAVE SIXTEEN
IN Q. ONE SIX SIXTEEN THANK YOU
AT LEAST CURRENTLY THAT THE
MMHM PLEASE MOVE FORWARD
CALLING FOR SPEAKER. VERY GOOD
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AT THIS TIME. I DO
APOLOGIZE COLOR NINE THIRTY TWO
ARE YOU ON MUTE. WE WILL WE
WILL MOVE ON LINE THIRTY TWO
YOU CAN RE QUEUE IT NEEDED.
LINE FORTY SIX LINE FOR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NEVER DID THE TURKEY
USED IN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF FOOD PRODUCERS REPRESENTING
FOOD PROCESSING AND DATA
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO
THE RATE INCREASE THAT WILL BE
A BY EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU. VERY WEALTHY COULD THE
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO BACK TO LINE THIRTY TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU YEAH. YES HELLO THIS
IS BLANCA CASTRO WITH A RP
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION A. R. P.
MEMBERS AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB ONE SIX. FIVE
NINE. AND I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY WE'RE SPEAKING ALSO
ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
A FIXED INCOME OF SOCIAL. WITH
SOCIAL SECURITY AND THEY CANNOT
AFFORD IT AND I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFUL THANK YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT SENATOR HER SURGERY
OR NOT GOING TO HAVE A GOOD
DAY. WE JUST HAVE TO YOU
COLLABORATOR IF WE COULD MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
AND WE ASK YOU JUST TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
AFFILIATION IN. AND NO OTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. MODERATOR
CALL THE NEXT PICKUP PLEASE.
THANK YOU SHARELINES DELAY SIX
PLEASE AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE PAY HOW
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT SOMETHING WE CANNOT
AFFORD RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT'S A LOT SO ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND WHO COME
ON THE VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. VERY WELL
I THINK. DID THEY FINISH. OKAY
MODERATOR NEXT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE SO. YEAH LINE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LARRY MUNSON WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU NEXT FIGURE
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DR KAREN NUMBERS TO HEARING
YOUR WITHOUT WILL CULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AT
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. LINE FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS QUITE ALMOST CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO NOT
PROFICIENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE FORTY TWO
FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MONDAY AFTER
EIGHT TRYING TO TEACH AND
INSTRUCT OPPOSITION. PRETTY
WELL NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON- EDUCATE
MEMBERS MATTHEW WELL WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. LINE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS AUDRA HARTMAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LARGE ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING EXPECT HER PLEASE.
LINE SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LAUREN ONLY PAYCHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMER
THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL AIRCRAFT IS THAT
HE CAN CALIFORNIA COUNTRY
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON.
GROWERS ASSOCIATION ARE WITH
THE PARTICULAR IF NEED FARMERS
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA WANTED
COMMISSION AND WESTERN
AKROPOLIS GROUP EDUCATION ALL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. MAN THAT'S
LOWER KLEIN. HEY NEXT NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. BLINDS FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ROBERT SPIEGEL FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION ALSO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY LINE
FORTY SEVEN IS YOUR DEVICE ON
ME. WE'LL GO ON THE LINE FORTY
ONE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER DANIEL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN
GALLERY CAROLYN LOCHHEAD FOR
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY ECHOING THE CONCERNS OF
MY AYE AND YOU COLLEAGUES AND
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
UNDER CUTS THE WORK DONE.
ALLIES I OWE YOU FINANCIAL
HEALTH WHICH WILL HURT OUR
CUSTOMERS. WE ARE CLOSED. NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THANK YOU
FINALLY COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME IS LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL THE ONLY CALIFORNIA
CREATED BECAUSE THE STATION
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WAREHOUSE
ASSOCIATION AND WE MUST
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE THIS
CUSTOMER THANK YOU. VERY WELL
THANK YOU. MR MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE IN TWO. NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY NOW
NOW WE WILL GO. TO THE SENATORS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
CENTERVILLE SORRY CUT YOU OFF
AT THE SURFACE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR APPRECIATED AND- BY. I
GUESS I'LL JUST GO BACK I WAS
THIS IS JUST A DIFFICULT BILL
FOR ME- IN ONE TO REVIEW WHICH
OF THE SOUL CHALLENGING WHEN I
LISTEN TO MISTER WEBB SHOULD
HIS. COMMENTS IN SUPPORT AND HE
WAS VERY CLEAR IN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR THE UTILITIES ARE ONLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FIFTEEN
FEET AROUND. A TREE. AND THAT'S
THEIR LEVEL OF-AUTHORITY
THAT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT'S THE WORK THAT THEY NEED
TO DO WITH THAT IMPLIES THAT.
ANY FIRE THAT STARTS OUTSIDE OF
THAT AREA IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF A REPAIR. BUT THAT'S NOT
TRUE. REPAIRS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT. STARTED OR
NOT IGNITED UTILITY BECAUSE
FIRED IT'S TO TAXPAYERS IT
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
NOT THOSE RATEPAYERS SO THAT'S
THE STRUGGLE THAT I'M FACED
WITH I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES I'VE BEEN WE HAVE A-
OF. THE STATE THE CHECKOUT THE
DOLLARS THAT NEGOTIATIONS
REGARDING THE BONDS THERE HAVE
BOTH YOU KNOW BEEN LIMITED AND
CERTAINLY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
WE NEED THE RESOURCES WE NEED
TO GET THE WORK DONE AND WE
NEED TO CLEAR THOSE- THE
VEGETATION THAT'S CAUSING THE
PROBLEM AND THE THREAT IS NOT
GOING AWAY I JUST IN OUR
DISTRICT- MY DISTRICT THE
RESIDENTS ARE JUST ABLE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR HOMES WHO ARE
EVACUATED- A WEEK AND A HALF
AGO SO IT IS A CHALLENGE I JUST
FOR ME THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
EXPENDITURES PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL. AND THE COST BEING BORNE
BY THE UTILITY RATE PAYERS IS
TENUOUS. HOWEVER NOBLE THE
CAUSE AND NO HOWEVER NOBLE THE
GOALS ARE OF THIS I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
COMMITTEE. AS I. THINK MORE
ABOUT THE ISSUE AND- IN THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY CALIFORNIA
THE LIMITED RESOURCES WE HAVE.
AND THE NEXUS THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THANK YOU FIRST TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR. THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD. OVER
THIS ISSUE IN HIS- ERY
THOUGHTFUL PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
CENTER HILL WE HAVE- MEMBERS ON
THEM ON THE- THAT LIKE TO SPEAK
SENATOR DOLLY THEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND THEN SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FIRST I HAVE A QUESTION FOR- I
THINK- CENTER HERTZBERG GOOSE
WAS DOING THE FINANCIAL PART OF
IT. BY MAY. ASK A QUESTION SO
THERE'S- THATTURNED OUT
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS THAT IT
FAILED ON BONDS AND WE WOULDN'T
EVEN WE WOULDN'T START MAKING
PAYMENTS ON THOSE BONDS INTEL.
FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW UNTIL
WHAT IS EXPECTED TOTAL PAY OUT
OF THIS TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY BY TWENTY
FIFTY ONE THAT'S THE FIRST
QUESTION. OKAY DON'T ANSWER
THAT NOW YOU WANT TO GET THE
EXACT QUESTION TO OKAY I'LL GET
THE NEXT ONE. LEGIBLE WELL
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT
ANSWER BUT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
ANSWER THAT'S FINE YOU CAN
ANSWER YOUR CLOTHES OR
WHATEVER. YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW THAT THE BANKING CHAIRS
ON THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AND
WE TALK ABOUT PREDATORY
LENDING. TO FOLKS WHO. DON'T
UNDERSTAND FINANCING AND YEAH
THISIS IT THIS IS EVEN WORSE
THAN PREDATORY LENDING ANY
PREDATORY LENDING BILLS WE'VE
SEEN. COME THROUGH IN MY
OPINION WE HAVE FIFTEEN YEARS
OF NOT EVEN MAKING THE NEXT
INTEREST PAYMENT. ON UPON. THEY
WERE LOANING THE MONEY FOR
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S NOT ONLY-
IT'S AND IT'S ONLY A SELECT
GROUP OF PEOPLE IT'S NOT WE I
WAS INVOLVED IN. A AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WHICH WAS A BIOMASS
BILL. HAS A FIRE- NINE OH ONE A
FEW YEARS AGO WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER ON IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND I. HAVE BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR- TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
WATERSHEDS IN OUR OUR WILDLIFE
AND SEE THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES BURNED. AND BUDGET TO
NARROW THIS BILL DOWN TO THREE
UTILITIES THREE I USE WHERE'S
THE- WHERE'S THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES WHERE'S THE- WHERE'S
THE NEW NEEDS AND ALL THE OTHER
ONES THAT. ARE GETTING A
BENEFIT FROM. THE RESOURCES
BEING MANAGED AS WELL AND SO
IT'S REALLY JUST NARROW IT DOWN
TO. THE THREE ITEMS SO THAT I
THINK THAT'S- VERY DIFFICULT I
LOOK AT THE BILL THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
THE FRYING CAN NOW. I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S JUST SUPPORT OR
OR THAT'S THE NAME ABILITY BILL
TO GET A BOAT SOMEWHERE. BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF IN THIS
BILL THAT DOESN'T REALLY ADD UP
TO WILDFIRE SO THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF FIRST. QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE. THAT I YOU KNOW THIS IS
A I THINK IT. THE BILL THAT
REALLY NEEDS A LOT MORE TIME
THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST. AS IN THIS SESSION AND I
KNOW THAT- WE HAVE FIRES
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THE WERE
WERE BURNING DOWN IS
UNPRECEDENTED. BUT IS THIS
REALLY THE ROUTE WE WANT TO GO
IT'S REALLY THAT. THE YOU KNOW
THE FOLKS OF CALIFORNIA
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA'S IS.
LIABLE FOR. THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS INCIDENTS SUCH DISARRAY
FOR LACK OF MANAGEMENT FOR.
OVER THE LAST. SIXTY YEARS O
FOR ME IT'S LIKE WE'RE PICKING
OUT ONE SECTOR THAT'S REALLY
EASY TO- YOU KNOW YEAH THEY DO
CAUSE SOME FIRES BUT ONLY ONE
OUT OF TEN FIRES. ARE CAUSED BY
UTILITIES WE KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT SO. THOSE ARE A FEW OTHER
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
ADDRESSED IF YOU MAY. AS
CENTERS YOU WANT FOR THAT JIM.
BUT THE EASY EXAMPLES DOT WOULD
BE THIS. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AUTHORS AND OTHER AUTHORS IN A
LOT OF FOLKS TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME. ONE THING THAT'S CLEAR IS
THAT BARRING MONEY HAS NEVER
BEEN CHEAPER. SO LET'S ASSUME
YOU COULD ESTABLISH A LOAN FOR
YOUR HOME. AND INSTEAD OF
PAYING 5% INTEREST YOU COULD
PAY A HALF A PERCENT INTEREST
BUT YOU PAID IT ALL AT THE END
INSTEAD OF AT THE BEGINNING.
THE TEST IS WHETHER IT'S A
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND TO THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT OF THE
TAXPAYERS. OF ANY KIND OF OTHER
BORROWING THE TEST WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ISSUE THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT A PREDATORY LENDING. IS
WHAT'S THE ULTIMATE COST.
WHAT'S THE ULTIMATE COST AND
THE REALITY IS FROM ALL THE
BEST EXPERTS THAT WE CAN FIND
FROM ALL THE VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS WITH WHOM WE HAVE
CONSULTED. AND ALL OF THE
VARIOUS FOLKS SENATOR A SENATOR
BLOOM AND MULLIN OTHERS AS YOU
KNOW IS THAT MONEY NEVER
CHEAPER AS I SAID EARLIER. IT'S
LITERALLY ALMOST A TENTH OF A
PERCENT FOR TWO YEAR TREASURY.
YOU CAN ESTABLISH THE PRICING
NOW. WE HAVE THE NEED NOW IS
THE STATE'S BURNING UP BECAUSE
YOU HAVE THE NEED FOR YOUR
HOUSE YOUR CAR FOR YOUR FAMILY.
AND THIS IS JUST A PAYMENT
STRUCTURE THAT QUITE FRANKLY.
IS GOING TO BE A LOT CHEAPER
THAN G. O. BONDS OR OTHER TYPES
OF BONDS. THE BETTER I THE THAT
WOULD BE ISSUE. SECOND THING
IS. THAT WHEN YOU READ THE
MEASURE ITS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
BORROWED WHICH IS CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FOR WORK RIGHT
NOW PUT PEOPLE TO WORK DEAL
WITH SOME OF THIS VERY
EXTRAORDINARY REYES FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND THEN THERE
IS THE ISSUE OF APPROPRIATION
FOR THE BALANCE OF THE MONEY.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SCRUB THOSE
ISSUES GOING FORWARD. AND THE
THIRD THING I THINK THAT GOES
TO THE CORE OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THE NEXUS ISSUE AND
YOUR SENATE ALL YOUR 1000%
CORRECT. YOU CANNOT USE
RATEPAYER MONEY FOR NON. RATE
PAIR INTERESTS. BUT THE
ARGUMENT IS GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE SPEND FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS ON ALL
THIS LIABILITY ANYTHING WE CAN
DO. FOR THE REPAIRS TO REDUCE
THAT LIABILITY WOULD BE A
PRUDENT THING TO DO. CHECK A
ARE CHEAP. IT'S NOT IT'S THE
IT'S THE FARTHEST THING AWAY
FROM. ANYTHING YOU LOOK AT. IN
THE CONTEXT OF. A OF A- A
PREDATORY IN THE LAST THING I
WOULD SAY IS. WE ARE IN TOUGH
TIMES. AND CREATIVE FINANCING
ALLOWS US TO GET THE PEOPLE TO
WORK GET THIS WORK DONE NOW
WITHOUT PUTTING A BURDEN ON THE
BUDGET WITHOUT PUTTING A BURDEN
ON THE BUDGET AND ALSO BY THE
WAY ZERO BURDEN ON RATEPAYERS.
ARE GOING TO PAY A NICKEL A
NICKEL UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY SIX
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO PAY WHAT
WAS UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR NOBODY
HAS ONE. MORE MONEY AND ALSO
JUST TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE IF I
COULD THAT TURN TALKED ABOUT
AND- THE- THE A. R. P. POOR
PEOPLE UNDER THE CARE. OF THE
TICKET CARE CUSTOMER AND THE
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER IS
STILL PROTECTED EXACTLY THE
SAME PROTECTIONS OR INTENT
FIFTY FOUR I THINK THOSE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS. I MADE
MISTER CHAIRMAN- JUST TO OUR
EAST THESE ARE THESE ARE NOT
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ARE THEY- NO
THEY'RE NOT SO THE RATES GOING
TO BE HIGHER THAN THERE USUALLY
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ARE GOING TO
BE A LOWER AND THE OTHER THING
QUESTION I HAD IS WHY ISN'T L.
A. D. W. P. A PART OF THIS THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE SOME
OF. THE BENEFIT FROM THAT. AS
WELL. YES THANK YOU THE REASON
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
WATER AND POWER. AND THE OTHER
MUNICIPAL ONED UTILITIES WOULD
BE. IS THAT WOULD BE A NEW TAX
THAT WOULD BE A NEW FEE ON
CUSTOMERS OVER AND ABOVE WHAT
THE EXISTING FOR YEARS. THE
NOTION JUST LIKE. WAS
ARTICULATED IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT YOU WERE INVOLVED IN. THAT
THIS WAS A CONTINUING OF THE-
AB ONE X. MR KILLIAN TWO
THOUSAND WE DID BACK THEN. AND
A CONTINUE THE FREE. SO NO ONE
WOULD FEEL A GREATER NUMBER. IN
TERMS OF IT IT'S JUST EXTENDED
OUT. THE MEDIA THE- ISSUE AND
MAYBE IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AND THE LAST THING AGAIN.
THE BOND LAWYERS. WHO WILL
APPROVE THESE LOANS WILL NOT
ALLOW. FUNDING THAT IS NOT. THE
IT RELATED TO THE NEXUS AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ITS CONTINUING
APPROPRIATION PROCESS. WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SCRUB
PRECISELY THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISED. I WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FOR THE ANSWERS ARE
TAKING TO ANSWER SOME I JUST
WANT TO WIN ENCLOSING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGING ME- BUT MY QUESTION
AT NIGHT I KNOW THAT MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT. MY FAMILY
HOMESTEADED IN CALIFORNIA AND-
I PLAN ON STAYING HERE FOR A
LONG TIME AND- I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT HOW. WE CAN
BORROW MONEY NOW. AT A LESS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE THE RATES ARE
LOW THAT'S A THAT'S A FACT BUT
WHEN YOU'RE BORROWING MONEY
THAT YOU'RE NOT STARTING TO PAY
ON YOUR CRUISING THAT HALF OF
PERCENT. OVER TIME OVER THE
FIRST FFTEEN YEARS AND I'M
NOT. CONVINCED THAT THAT'S A
GOOD DEAL FOR MY- CHILDREN TO
BE PAYING OFF- OVER THERE
THEY'RE- STARTING THEIR CAREER
SO- FOR THAT AND MANY OTHER
REASONS I THINK THIS BILL IS.
MISGUIDED AND I THINK THAT- I'M
I'M NOT. GOING TO BE A NO VOTE
ON IT AND I'LL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTERED EARLY-
SENATOR STERN. THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER RUBIO THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER CHIANG. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. PRESHEAF THE COLLOQUY IN
THE CLARIFICATION ON THE RATE
PAYER ISSUE WHICH I HEARD
MENTIONED. THANK SOME
MISSTATEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE BY
OPPONENTS TALKING ABOUT RATE
IMPACTS ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
JUST TO REITERATE IS STRUCTURE
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE THIS NON BY
PASSABLE CHARGES NOT PAID BY.
THE LOWEST INCOME RATE PAYERS.
AND THE CARE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
MEDICAL BASELINE. YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S REALLY A QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE WANT TO KEEP THIS.
THIS FIX SURCHARGE SITTING
ASIDE AS A BACKSTOP FOR
UTILITIES. WHICH IS UNDER
CURRENT LAW OR WHETHER WE WANT
TO. PUT THIS MONEY TO WORK
FILLING CRITICAL GAPS. THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW IN OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE RISK MITIGATION BUDGET
YEAR AFTER YEAR IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AS THIS STATE HAS
BURNED. WE HAVE CUT PREVENTION
EVERY SING SESSION. WE HAVE
STEPPED UP ON SUPPRESSION. WE
ARE DOING RIGHT I THINK BY OUR
MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
FIREFIGHTING FORCE BUYING
HELICOPTERS UNISA PRESS WE NEED
TO DO. BUT LAST YEAR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO GO
TO WILDFIRE PREVENTION CUTS.
THIS YEAR ZERO DOLLARS THE HOME
HARDENING BUDGET FOR THIS STATE.
AB THIRTY EIGHT MISTER WOULD
PASSED IT HOW MUCH MONEY IS IN
THE BUDGET ZERO. WE HAVE GIVEN
COMMUNITIES NO TOOLS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT- THE
FORESTRY SIDE OF THINGS AND
SORT OF. THE DEEPER RURAL AREAS
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES. BUT
WHERE WHERE I LIVE AND WHERE SO
MANY PEOPLE LIVE IS RIGHT ON
THE EDGE. IT'S THAT WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE AND THE KIND OF
JOBS OF THIS WOULD GENERATE ARE
NOT JUST RELEGATED BY THE WAY
TO THE FIRE COMMUNITIES ANYONE
CAN GET A GOOD HARD WORKING JOB
AND HAVE A LONG TERM CAREER
PATHWAY THROUGH THE LARGEST
EVER INVESTMENT IN A CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WORK FORCE IN STATE
HISTORY. WITH THIS MEASURE. THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FUND
THIS PUTS TOGETHER IS NOT JUST
ABOUT A TEMPORARY LANDSCAPING
JOB. IS ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE TO
WORK RIGHT NOW UCLA LUSKIN
CENTER DID AN ANALYSIS OF THE
MOST JOBS INTENSIVE. CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS WE CAN MAKE IS A
STATE. AND THIS KIND OF
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE INVESTMENT
IS THE MOST JOBS INTENSIVE
INVESTMENT YOU CAN POSSIBLY
MAKE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A LOT
OF PEOPLE GETTING OUT THERE AND
DOING WORK FOR PUTTING GAS
GETTING ON YOUR VETS SEALING
YOUR ROOF SERVICEMEMBERS CAN'T
GET IN AND BURN DOWN YOUR HOUSE
FROM THE INSIDE DOING THAT
LANDSCAPING WORK. WE LOOK DOWN
ON LANDSCAPERS AND TRY TO TREAT
THEM LIKE- IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
THE GARDENER GUY WITH A LEAF
BLOWER IT'S TIME WE START
LOOKING DOWN ON PEOPLE WHO DO
THAT HARD WORK AND REALIZE THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE MAIN JOB OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GOING FORWARD AND THIS BILL
FINALLY PUT SOME MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS. THERE'S ALSO
MONEY FOR BACK UP POWER WE UST
SAW WE- WE CONTINUE. TO LOSE
POWER AT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN NURSING HOMES
FOR PEOPLE IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHO CAN'T KEEP
THEIR AC ON DURING THE POWER
OUTAGE WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO
GO TO A COOLING CENTER RIGHT
NOW OPTIONS ARE LIMITED THIS
BILL STEPS IN AND ACTUALLY
STEPS UP FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES.
LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY THE
PRIORITIZATION IN THIS FIELD OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE IS
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ORIENTATION.
THERE ARE WEALTHY PEOPLE IN
THIS STATE AND I REPRESENT SOME
OF THEM. IN MALIBU AND
CALABASAS HIGH INCOME MORNING
BRACKETS THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT HARDENING WORK
ON THEIR OWN. THIS BILL IS NOT
DESIGNED TO SUBSIDIZE THOSE
FOLKS BUT WHEN YOU'RE ON A
FIXED INCOME. AND YOU'VE YOU'RE
LIVING IN AN AREA YOU NEVER
THOUGHT WOULD BURN DOWN AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN. YOU DIDN'T DO THAT
GAS GETTING WORK ON YOUR GARAGE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD THAT
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO HAVE
SOMEONE COME OVER AND DO THE
PATCH WORK YOU NEED DONE. AND
THEN YOUR WHOLE LIFE INVESTMENT
BURNS DOWN BEFORE YOUR VERY
EYES. THAT'S A TRAGEDY THAT WE
CAN AVOID. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
WHETHER WE'RE TRYING TO PUT OUR
THUMB ON THE SCALE AND DO THE
WRONG KINDS OF FIRE TREATMENT
IN THESE KINDS OF COMMUNITIES
FOR INSTANCE WE SHOULD HAVE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN SENSITIVE
NATURAL HABITATS WE SHOULDN'T
BE DOING TYPE CONVERSION OR
GETTING. RID OF NATIVE PLANTS
IN FACT USING THAT LIVE OAKS
PREVENT FIRE THOSE ARE NATURAL
BUFFERS- I WOULD SAY I'M
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BUT ALSO WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WILL GET
A SECOND BITE AT THIS APPLE TO
REFINE THIS PLAN AND I HAVE AN
EXPECTATION. THAT WHAT THAT
FINAL PLAN WILL LOOK LIKE IF WE
CAN GET THIS ARCHITECTURE IN
THE LAW WILL NOT PUT A THUMB ON
THE SCALE TO DO THE WRONG KINDS
OF FIRE TREATMENTS IN THE WRONG
KINDS IN NEIGHBORHOODS. IT WILL
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT NO
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN SENSITIVE
HABITAT. AND REALLY MAKE CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT FINALLY
GETTING DOLLARS MOVING ON
PREVENTING THESE TRAGEDIES WE
WILL SAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACCORDING UCLA'S ANALYSIS
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND JOBS. FROM
THIS INITIAL INVESTMENTS. THIS
IS A GOOD BILL. WE KNOW IT'S
LATE BUT THE CLOCK HAS BEEN
TICKING ON US FOR TOO MANY
YEARS WE CAN'T AFFORD TO SIT I
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVE
MECHANICS DONE BY SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER AND- I THINK
IT'S WORTH MOVING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD IN GETTING SOMETHING
DONE BEFORE WE LEAVE SESSION
THIS WEEK. IF WE DON'T MOVE
WILD FIRE MONEY BEFORE WE LEAVE
THIS SESSION. WE'RE DOING
MALPRACTICE PEOPLE STATED
CALIFORNIA. THANK CENTER STERN
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I WILL FIRST OF ALL
ON I THINK THE AUTHOR AND
ANALYTICAL AUTHORS FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I THINK
THAT TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
ON THIS FLOOR- IN THE SENATE
LEGISLATURE- IS VERY INTERESTED
IN RYING TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH THE
WILDFIRES THAT. HAVE BEEN.
REALLY RAVAGING SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- YOU KNOW I HAD A
FIRE ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO AND A
CAESAR HILLS WHICH IS. MALES
THAT I REPRESENT AND SO I WANT
TO BE. MINDFUL AND THANKFUL TO
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
TO GET CREATIVE WITH MEASURES I
DO BELIEVE WE HAVE TO GET
CREATIVE WITH FUNDING. THAT'S
WHY AS A CHAIR OF INSURANCE TAX
SET UP TO. TO PROPOSE SOME
BILLS TO SEE WE CAN FIGURE OUT
THE FUNDING MECHANISM INCLUDING
BEST PRACTICES FOR MEDICATION-
FIRE RESISTANT MATERIALS AND
OTHER ITEMS THAT I THINK ARE
GOING TO BE HELPFUL I DO AGREE
WITH. WHAT THE GREAT CENTER
FROM- MALIBU IN THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS FOR
FAMILIES FOR PEOPLE TO FIGHT
FIRES AND I ALSO. TO AGREE WITH
THE GREAT SENATOR FOR FROM THE
SENATE TELL THAT. THERE'S A
STRUGGLE HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT OUR RATE PAYERS. WILL BE
IMPACTED I KNOW THAT I
REPRESENT S. C. E. THEY'RE MY
DISTRICT AND SO. I'M VERY
MINDFUL THAT WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE REPAIRS
HIMSELF. THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT BILL AS- THE CENTER
FROM SAN MATTEO EXPRESSED. IT
IS SEVENTY NINE- WE PROBABLY
NEED TO VENT A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT WE KNOW THAT WHERE YOU.
HAVE VERY LIMITED TIME GIVEN
THIS CALL BUT CRISIS AND HOW
LITTLE WE HAVE TIME TO SPEAK TO
PEOPLE. SINCE THE OUR THAT THIS
HAS BEEN IN PRINT I'VE BEEN.
REALLY AGGRESSIVELY BEEN- I
HAVE. CALLED AND TEXTED AND
SENT LETTERS FROM MY DISTRICT
AND- FOR ME RIGHT NOW I REALLY
NEED TO TAKE A LITTLE TIME TO
ADDRESS SOME OF MY DISTRICT
CONCERN. I KNOW THAT I ALWAYS
DO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
PRIDE MYSELF. AND REACHING
REACHING OUT. OF THREE
QUESTIONS WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND THIS IS- CUTTING MY
DISTRICT A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN- AND SO I AGREE WITH
THE CONCEPT I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE AT THE- A MAJORITY
LEADER BUT- AT THIS POINT I'M
JUST GOING TO HAVE TO- STAY
OFTEN I'M- VERY. EAGER AND OPEN
TO HAVE THIS DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR AND- AND RE REACH OUT TO
MY COMMUNITY WHICH WILL BE
IMPACTED AND SEE IF WE. CAN GET
THERE THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG. THANK
YOU MISTER YOU KNOW I JUST
WANTED TO LINE MY COMMENTS ALSO
WITH THAT SENATOR COLLEEN AND-
SENATOR RUBIO AS WELL. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO MENTION- YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE SOME
REALLY GOOD ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL FOR EXAMPLE THE HUNDRED
MILLION. A TO STATE PARKS TO
REDUCE THE RISK WHILE FIRING
RESTORED FIRE RELATED DEATH AND
JUST I HAVE TO KNOW HOW STATE
PARK IN MY DISTRICT AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A GREAT
ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT TO.
EXPAND EXPANDED IN ORDER TO
PROTECT ITS BEAUTIFUL OPEN
SPACE AND WILDLIFE. AND YOU
KNOW I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. ON YOU KNOW FINDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
PROTECTION AT THE STATE PARK
AND OTHERS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
FINANCING MECHANISM IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS NOT
SOMETHING I CAN SUPPORT TODAY-
I HARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY HE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND HOW
DIVERSE TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
AND YOU KNOW TO GET THE FIGHT I
AM CONCERNED THAT THIS FUNDING
MECHANISM WOULD MEAN ADDITIONAL
COST BURDENS ON ON RATE PAYERS
AND THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE FOR
ME IN MY DISTRICT- AND IF THIS
DOESN'T GET TO THE GOVERNOR I'D
REALLY LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A FINDING OTHER
FINANCING MECHANISMS OR YOU
KNOW. FIGURE SOMETHING OUT OF
IT YOU KNOW FOR SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE BUT UNFORTUNATELY. I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SO BRADFORD. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE MEMBERS AND
SERVICIOS SIMONE BLUM IN HIS
WORK ON THIS EFFORT. BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL ALL
BUT UNDERMINE ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR DID LIVE HERE
THROUGH- AB TEN FIFTY FOUR TO
HELP STABILIZE THE UTILITY
INDUSTRY AND I'M CONCERNED HOLE
CREDIT RATING AGENCIES WILL
VIEW THIS MEASURE AND IT WILL
IT COST TO BE A INCREASED COST
IN BARNEY FOR- THE UTILITIES I
MEAN. I HEARD A WHOLE LOT OF
DEBATE I THINK THERE SHOULD BE
A SHARED COST THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS SIMILAR
TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA STATED A
LOT OF THESE FIRES DIDN'T
HAPPEN AND I OWE YOU TEAR TOLD
TERREUS SOLELY. AND AGAIN JUST
ABOUT 10% ARE STARTED BY A
QUICK MINIMUM FOR STRUCTURE
AGAIN THE FIRES THAT WE'VE
WITNESSED FOR THE LAST MONTH
I'VE BEEN PRIMARILY CAUSED BY
MOTHER NATURE AND WE NEED TO.
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE. I ABOUT
THE AND THE YOU TO ARE NOT
POLICY ALL THESE FIRES THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT WORKING HARDENING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT MOTHER
NATURE HAS BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TIME. IF
YOU TALK TO OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THAT TELL
YOU THEY WALKING FIRE TO HELP
MANAGE. THE FORCED TO THE HOPE.
DANIEL I BROKE AS WELL SO WE
HAVE A BIT OF RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR AS YOU TALK TO SOME OF
OUR FORSTER'S BECAUSE WE FAILED
TO MANAGE BUT I WANT TO GET
BACK TO THE FACT THAT. I THINK
THIS SHOULD BE A SHARED COST I
THINK. ON MUNICIPALITIES AND
THE PUBLIC OWNED UTILITIES-
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED MANY OF
THESE FIRES MANY STARTED IN
THEIR DISTRICT AND I THINK THIS
COST. IF THERE WILL BE A COSTS
SHOULD BE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
SEN I KNOW YOU TERRITORY SO.
THAT'S WHERE I STAND ON THIS
ISSUE. OKAY ANYONE ELSE CENTER
BAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF. I THINK MANY OF
US IN THIS COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAVAGING THE STATE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. IN
THE LAST. IN A TEN DAY SPAN
HERE IN AUGUST ONE POINT SIX
MILLION ONE POINT SIX MILLION
ACRES OF WILDLAND HAVE BEEN
BURNED OUT BY A MAKE A WHILE IN
SIZE IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
HUNDREDS OF HOMES HAVE BEEN
LOST IN LIVES ATTENDED. WHEN
YOU TRAVEL NORTH OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN GET INTO CINEMA
AND LAKE NAPA AS WELL AS
MENDOCINO COUNTY'S. THOSE TWO
COUNTIES OUT OF THOSE FOUR
COUNTIES IN OUR HOME TO NOT
ONLY THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY BUT NOW THE
SECOND LARGEST WHILE IN FIRING
SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT AS WELL
AS THE DISTRICT. THAT I
REPRESENT IN LAKE COUNTY. WELL
THERE ARE NO SIMPLE FIXES TO
THIS ISSUE. WHAT WE CAN'T DO
THIS YEAR WE CANNOT LEAVE THIS
SESSION WITHOUT INVESTING IN
WILDFIRE PROTECTION AND SAFETY
IN PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE. IN
THIS THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
STEPPED UP TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
UTILITIES BE SECURITIZED THERE
DIDN'T APPEAR TO STAY AFLOAT.
YET WE ARE HERE DEBATING HOW WE
CAN ASSIST OUR COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO STAY SAFE. AGAIN
THERE ARE NO SILVER BULLETS IN
THE TABLE TODAY BUT THIS IS THE
BEST TOOL THAT WE HAVE. RIGHT
NOW TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND SAFETY.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD SEE. A
BILLIONAIRE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH AN AYE VOTE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS ISSUE.
TRY TO SECURE THE FUNDS TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE IN THE BILL
TO STOP THESE HOMES AND THEN
BURNING DOWN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WELL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ANY ANY OTHER.
CENTERS WHICH TO SPEAK. OUT
RESEARCHER. THE LAST CENTER DOT
FILIBUSTER MARLA. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE BILL'S AUTHORS FOR JOCKEYS.
WHATEVER FOR I BRING THIS UP
TODAY THERE ARE YES- THE
SENATOR AND I CONSIDER MCGUIRE
HAS JUST SAID THERE ARE NOT A
LOT OF GOOD OPTIONS. IS THIS A
PERFECT OPTION NO BUT I TOTALLY
AGREE. THAT WE HAVE TO LEAVE
THE SESSION WAS SOMETHING IN IT
AND PLAY IT POTENTIALLY. WITH
OVER FORTY BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT I DON'T REALLY SEE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANY BIG
POTS OF MONEY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE TYPE OF THINGS MOVING
FORWARD- FOR SENATOR- DOLLING-
HE'LL REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE
DOING. IN A FEW BILLS YEAH
BEFORE TEN FIFTY FOUR MOST MOST
NOTABLY TRIED THE ACTUALLY
BEFORE THAT SB NINE OH ONE
EIGHT. SB. NINE OH ONE. JUST
GETTING THE ADMINISTRATION AT
THAT TIME. TO COME FOR WITH A
THE BIG DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THESE FIRES
AND PROBLEMS WAS- YOU KNOW IS
VERY VERY DIFFICULT SO I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE BEST
WE CAN DO RIGHT NOW. IN THIS
FORWARD SOME OF THESE
INEQUITIES WITH WITH REGARDS TO
OTHER UTILITY I JUST DON'T I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S WORTHY OF
A CHANGING THE POSITION OUR
TRAJECTORY OF THIS BILL. THAT'S
AS FAR AS OTHER REPAIRS CAN'T
AFFORD IT THEY CAN AFFORD IT
NOW THERE FORTY EIGHT EVERY
SINGLE- EVERY EVERY SINGLE
MONTH RIGHT NOW WHICH IS GOING
TO LAST A LITTLE BIT LONGER SO
WITH THAT I ANSWER I'M. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER MORE LUCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE I THOUGHT WE'D
SEEN IT ALL- I WAS UP HERE TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN THE LIGHTNING
STORMS HERE TODAY. I'VE BEEN IN
A LOT OF LIGHTNING STORMS BUT
THAT WAS LIKE A WAR ZONE AND IT
MADE YOU WONDER YOU KNOW WHAT
ELSE COULD HAPPEN TO THE STATE-
YOU KNOW WE'RE PROBABLY OVERDUE
FOR A GOOD EARTHQUAKE I DON'T
WANT TO SAY IT BUT IT. MIGHT
YOU KNOW SIX THREE TO TWELVE
CERTAINLY HAD. SOME INTERESTING
ISSUES BUT- THIS IDEA OF
BORROWING- AT A VERY LOW RATE.
IS A VERY STRONG ARGUMENT.
UNLESS UNLESS WE- HAVE
DEFLATION. AND WE FIND
OURSELVES. BAYING WHERE THE
MORE EXPENSIVE DOLLARS. ALONE
IN THE FUTURE IT DIDN'T DIDN'T
IT WILL HAVE BACKFIRED ON US
AND I HAVE NOTHEARD THIS
LEGISLATURE TALK ABOUT AS MUCH
DEBT AS WE HAVE IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ASKING EMPLOYEES TO CUT THEIR
PAY BUT ALL WE DID WAS GIVE
THEM FOR LOS THAT THEY CAN
BANKS AND THEY COULD CASH OUT
LATER THAT'S BORROWING WE TOLD
THEM THAT. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PAY INTO THEIR PAST ARE OTHER
POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THE
BEST STATS ANOTHER. INCREASING
DEBT THAT'S CLOSE TO. NINETY
BILLION DOLLARS IT JUST WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. HAVING
CORPORATIONS PREPAY THEIR-
INCOME TAXES- IN IN SORT OF A
CERTIFICATE IDEA. WE'RE
BOUNCING AROUND SO MANY IDEAS
ON ON DECK AND WE NEED TO STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA DONE TO TRY TO
ELECTRIFY. THIS STATE AND WE'VE
DONE SOME THINGS IN RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE TRYING I
APPRECIATE BUT WITH THE
STATE'S. HYDRO AND NUCLEAR ARE
NOT RENEWABLE AND THEN THE
FORCE WIND. SOLAR MERA FARMS-
WHICH ARE. YOU KNOW I WON'T
EVEN GO DOWN THAT ROAD- AND
THEN THE IN FORM THE I. O. USE
THAT THEY'VE GOT TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS. AND THEN WHAT DO
THEY DO THEY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE STATE WHAT WHAT
ELSE IS THERE BEING A YANKEES
AND BACK AND FORTH AND THAT
GIVES US THESE. TRANSMISSION
LINES THAT ARE NOW OLD FREIGHT
AND NEED TO BE REPAIRED SO I
WOULD SAY THAT SACRAMENTO HAS
NOT BEEN PROACTIVE IT HAS A
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE. AND
EXIST. SURE THIS BILL IS REACT.
AND IS ARE. DO THIS ACKERMAN
LACK OF. IT'S A LITTLE. BECAUSE
CONSTANTLY YANKING I KNOW YOU
WITH A J. AROUND THE ONE THIS
WAY. AND THAT WAY ALL ITS- IS
THAT CENTRO PLANNING IS A JOKE
A SAD JOKE SO NOW THE SOLUTION
IS X. SIR SEARCH. WHICH IS
TANTAMOUNT TO ATTACK INCREASE
IN THAT IS NOT THE KIND OF
ANSWER WE SHOULD BE GIVING TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THIS IS NOT A
BILL. IT WOULD SEEM MORE
REASONABLE TO PREPARE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN DROPPING OR
MAYBE POSTPONING CERTAIN
IDEOLOGIES AND RUN ARE YOU USED
TO LIKE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
RUN. WITHOUT CONSTANTLY WHICH
SIGN WHAT SHOULD BE. AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A REASONABLE AND
REALISTIC PROCESS TO PROPERLY
ELECTRIFY. CALIFORNIA IN AND
FOR THOSE REASONS AND MORE I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU- CENTER
MORLOCK- FOR MY OWN COMMENTS
FIRST OF ALL. I AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES I THINK IT IS WITH IT
IS A GROWING PROBLEM. AND I
WANT TO THANK CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER ALAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM. FROM EARLY TRYING TO
IRON OUT. THIS PROBLEM WORKING
ON AND I REALLY REALLY BELIEVE
YOU SHOULD BE COMMENDED. FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS AND YOUR
PASSION. HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND- TRYING TO BRING AT
LEAST SOMETHING FORWARD THAT
WILL HELP- WITH BUT FIRE SHOULD.
I JUST HAVE. AN ENORMOUS
PROBLEM FOR YOU FOR USING
RATEPAYER FUNDS TO CREATE A
FIREFIGHTING PROGRAM THE STATE
I THINK WE COULD. DEFINITELY
GENERATE THOSE FUNDS FROM OTHER
SOURCES AND I THINK WOULD BE
MORE PRUDENT I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD EVEN BE ALLOWABLE TO USE
THESE FUNDS SPECIFICALLY TO
FIGHT FIRES A KNOWLEDGE EXPLAIN
WHY I SAY THAT. CURRENTLY OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
NEEDS TO BE UPGRADED TO HARDEN
IT. TO MAKE IT MORE RESISTANCE
TO FIRES AND TO. CLIMATE CHANGE
WHICH IS. INSTIGATING WINDS
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN AT AND
MORE VIOLENT THAN MANY OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE EVER COULD HAVE
ENVISIONED. AND SO THESE THESE
FUNDS SHOULD COME FROM REPAIR
FUNDS WE ALREADY HAVE A PROCESS
THAT ALLOWS THAT THROUGH THE PC.
AS I LOOK AT THIS BILL AND I
SEE HOW THEY'RE THEY'RE ONLY
FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW THE DAY-
PRIVATE UTILITIES TO- FIND THIS
THIS PROGRAM. YOU KNOW I REALLY
THINK IT DOESN'T COVER THE
STATE STRATEGICALLY. AND I
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH THE PRIVATE
UTILITIES COVER CALIFORNIA IT
IS A LARGE SWATH BUTTER IN
OTHER AREAS OUTSIDE OF THAT
THEY ALSO NEED TO BE INCLUDED.
IN IN A MITIGATION PROGRAM. AND
THAT NEEDS TO REALLY BE FOUGHT
OUT. AN END TO THE EXTENT THAT
THESE REPAIR FUNDS SHOULD BE
USED TO HARDEN THE GRID I
SUPPORT THAT. AND IF THERE IS
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL THAT WILL
SUPPORT THAT I WILL SUPPORT IT
IS WELL IF IT GOES OUTSIDE OF
THAT I WILL NOT BECAUSE THOSE
ARE AREAS. THAT SHOULD BE
INVESTED IN FROM OTHER FINANCE.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD. THAT IS
ILLEGAL COUNTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE. AND CENTER
MCGUIRE I JUST WANT TO. CORRECT
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT THIS FROM
YOUR DISTRICT. BUT IN SAN DIEGO
OUR OUR OUR TRAGEDY STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. WITH THE
CEDAR CREEK FIRES. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WE HAD A FIRE IN
JULIAN THAT BASICALLY DESTROYED
THE ENTIRE. I WOULD SAY MID
MAJOR PART OF THE OF THE JULIAN
FORCE THAT HAS NOT REGENERATED
SINCE THEN. I DRIVE THERE EVERY
NOW AND THEN AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
OF A NEW PINE TREE GROW IN THAT
AREA. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VERY DESTRUCTIVE FIRES ARE.
RAVAGING OUR FORESTS. AND BACK
THEN I REMEMBER A SCIENCE TO
SAY THAT THAT FORCE WOULD NEVER
COME BACK AND HE WAS RIGHT. AND
THAT IS OF EXTREME CONCERN IF
THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN OTHER
PARTS OF STATE I UNDERSTAND
THAT. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE FOUND.%
OTHER OTHER SOURCES TO FIND.
TREE PLANTINGS AND OTHER
PROJECTS BUT- IN SAN DIEGO WE
STARTED ORG HARDENING THE GRID
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE IN SAN DIEGO
RATEPAYERS HAVE SUPPORTED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF HARDENING
PROJECTS. THAT INCLUDE A
WEATHER STATION THAT INCLUDE A
RAPID. RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAVE REALLY HELPED TO
REDUCE NEW FIRES THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY HARMFUL.
THAT TWO BILLION HAS BEEN MADE.
OVER OVER A DECADE. AND HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL AT
MITIGATING THESE WILDFIRES
THAT'S WHY WHEN I SEE THAT
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL AMOUNT
MAYBE A VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THREE. BILLION DOLLARS
BILLION- FURTHER BURDENING
RATEPAYERS IN SAN DIEGO WHEN WE
HAVE A PROGRAM WE'VE HAD
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS TO HARDEN
THE GRID. YES THERE ARE MORE
THINGS TO DO. AND THAT WHAT
THAT PROCESS IS ALREADY ALLOWED
UNDER THE P. YOU SEE AND- THE
PC CAN MORE EXACTLY. ALLOW THE
UTILITIES TO INVEST IN AREAS TO
HARDEN THE GRID. IN WAYS THAT
WILL PROTECT NOT ONLY THE RATE
PAYERS BUT ALSO PROTECT. THE
YOU PUT THE UTILITIES FROM OF
HAVING THEIR EQUIPMENT SPARKED
FIRE SO WHEN PEOPLE TELL ME
THAT THIS IS ABOUT. PARTY IN
THE GRID I DON'T I REALLY DON'T
BY THAT BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE
THAT MECHANISM ALLOWED WITHIN
THE LAW THAT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROP
PROCESS AND SCRUTINIZE. THOSE
PROPOSALS AND REALLY LOOK AT
HOW MUCH MONEY IS GOING TO BE
INVESTED IN HARDENING THE GRID.
AND HOW MUCH IS REALLY HOW FOR
HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO GO TO
HELP PREVENT WILDFIRES AND
DISASTERS IN OUR STATE. BUT I
THINK I'VE I'VE I'VE SAID
ENOUGH I HAVE A HARD TIME
SUPPORTING THIS JUST BECAUSE
HONESTLY I HAVEN'T REALLY HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO SCRUTINIZE THIS
BILL AND THIS IS A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF WHERE I'M COMING
FROM I SEE THAT WE COULD STILL
MOVE FORWARD. AND MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS LAST YEAR WE RAISED
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES AND THAT WAS
IMMEDIATELY THAT'S MONEY THAT
IS HAS BEEN SPENT AND IS BEING
SPENT TO PURCHASE EQUIPMENT TO
COMBAT FIRES TWO OF. WORK ON
SUPPRESSION PROJECTS THAT WILL
PREVENT FIRES AND IF WE CAN
WORK ON SOMETHING ELSE THAT
COVERS THE ENTIRE STATE
STRATEGICALLY AND LOOKS AT HOW
WILDFIRE AREAS AND COMES UP
WITH A STRATEGY I WILL SUPPORT
IT. BUT UNFORTUNATELY I FIND
MYSELF IN A TOUGH PLACE BETWEEN
FRIENDS ON BOTH SIDES AND
INTERESTS ON BOTH SIDES THAT.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE
AND- HIGH IMPORTANT PEOPLE THAT
OF WHICH- I THINK WOULD STAND
TO. BENEFIT ENORMOUSLY BY
PROGRAM. AND WE DO NEED TO PUT
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND-
HOPEFULLY WITH THE WITH WHAT
WE'VE DONE. IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE
WE'VE DONE AND ALL THE VARIOUS
WATER BONDS PARK FUNDS AND
OTHER FUNDS WE'VE- POST AND ALL
THAT MONEY HASN'T BEEN
EXHAUSTED HOPEFULLY THAT COULD
BE- THE EXPEDITED TO GET PEOPLE
TO. START START GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER AND WITHIN ALL OF THOSE
PROJECTS THERE. THERE WAS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT CAN BE
DESIGNED INTO- FIRE
SUPPRESSION. AND READ IT
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF FUEL. IN
THE ENVIRONMENT SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE TO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. I'M SORRY.
THE DOT DALI DO YOU STILL WANT
TO SPEAK AGAIN. WE HAVE A
QUESTION OR WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE
CENTER DOLLY. HERE PLEASE UNDER
YOURSELF. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU I HAD ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR A CENTER HERTZBERG
SO WE DID TEN TEN FIFTY FOUR
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS TO
STABILIZE THE- THE RATINGS SO
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BORROW
MONEY. IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY. MAKE
IT EVEN HARDER FOR THEM TO
BORROW MONEY BECAUSE WE'RE
LAYING OUT BURNING ON THEM
AGAIN A COULD YOU ANSWER ME HOW
THEY COULD IT COULD POSSIBLY
PUSH UP THEIR ABILITY TO BORROW
MONEY AGAIN BY DOING THIS.
ACTUAL PROCEDURE THAT THAT'S
WHY WE DID TEN FIFTY FOUR WAS
TO ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO
SECURITIZE THAT THAT AND BORROW.
GIVE ME. THAT EXACT QUESTION
WAS ASKED OF ME FROM THE C. E.
O. OF PGNIG. WHEN I SPOKE TO
HIM WITH HIS LOBBYISTS
YESTERDAY I GIVE ME THE ANSWER
AND I SEARCH I CONFIRM THAT
ANSWERED WITH THE BEST EXPERTS
IN THE FINANCIAL SPACE. WHO
BASICALLY TOLD ME ONE THAT IN
FACT YOU'RE DE RISKING THE
PROBLEM FOR THE UTILITIES ON
THE ONE HAND. BY VIRTUE OF
REDUCING FIRE RISKS WHICH IS
WITH INVERSE CONDEMNATION CAN
DESTROY THESE COMPANIES. AND
THAT IN FACT YOU CAN ENHANCE
THEIR RATING A THEIR RATINGS.
AND TWO BECAUSE THERE IS NO
BURDEN ON THESE COMPANIES TO
THE OFF BALANCE SHEET FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS THERE'S NO BURDEN
AT ALL IN THE RATINGS. SO IN
FACT IT HAS THE EXACT OPPOSITE
EFFECT OF THE INTENT OF THE
QUESTION I THINK IN FACT HELPS
THE COMPANIES WITH BORROWING BY
DE RISKING THEIR FIRE RISK.
BECAUSE OF THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
VERY WELL TO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY DID YOU WANNA MAKE CLOSING
COMMENTS CENTER HERTZBERG ROUTE
WHERE THOSE YOUR PER CLOSING
COMMENTS JUST A FEW FEW CLOSING
COMMENTS I KNOW WE BOTH WANT TO
MAKE MEMBERS- WE KNOW WE'VE GOT
A HUGE CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
WE'VE GOT OUR STATE IS BURNING-
THIS THIS SENATE PASSED AND
WITH A STRONG MAJORITY. SB
FORTY FIVE AFTER VERY EXTENSIVE
CONSULTATIONS WITH EVERYBODY
HERE- THERE IS A LOT OF WORK
THAT WENT INTO CRAFTING THAT
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE CREATED A SLIMMED
DOWN VERSION THAT HELPS
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE TO
ADDRESS OUR FIRE CHALLENGES-
AND THAT'S WHAT'S AT THE HEART
OF THIS BILL- SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN CAREFUL WE'VE BEEN
THOUGHTFUL AND ULTIMATELY THE
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE HERE
ADDRESS THESE ENORMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURAL CHALLENGES IS
ENORMOUS- WILDFIRE RISK
CHALLENGES THAT WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE AND IN THE END OF THE DAY.
ARE THESE PROBLEMS AREN'T GOING
AWAY AND INVESTMENT THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE NOW CAN MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN SOLVING AND
SAVING MONEY FOR REPAIRS- FOR
TAX PAYERS- AND FOR HOMEOWNERS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS OFF INTO
THE FUTURE THAT'S WHAT. IS AT
THE HEART OF THIS BILL. IT'S A
IT'S AN- NOW THAT WILL PAY OFF
INTO THE FUTURE BY THE WAY IT'S
NOWHERE NEAR AS ROBUST AS IT
NEEDS TO BE. OF IN TERMS OF THE
COST ASSOCIATED- WITH WITH
REGARDS ARE FOR WILDFIRE
LIABILITY LONG TERM BUT IT'S A
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND WILL CERTAINLY
SAVE US MONEY ON THE LONG TERM.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO PASS.
AT THE MICROPHONE OVER TO
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER ALLEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
GRACIOUSNESS AND- PAUL THE
MEMBERS FOR THE TIME OF
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
COMPRESSION THAT WE HAVE. ON
OUR SCHEDULE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE. WANT TO THANK GOD.
THE JOINT AUTHORS- SONORA
BLUMEN MULLIN FRIEDMAN EDUARDO
GARCIA IRWIN LOOSE AND ROBERT
RIVAS. AND WOOD SO THERE WOULD
AMONG THE NUMEROUS CO AUTHORS
IN THE SENATE. YOU SHOULD YOU
ARE CORRECT MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS IS A DIFFICULT TIME AND
IT'S A DIFFICULT CHALLENGE.
ANOTHER WOULD SAY GIVEN TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE HERE THAT
THE COURT QUESTIONS. ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE BALANCING SO MANY
THINGS. TO IT WHAT IF THERE'S A
FIRE TOMORROW. WHAT IS A BIG
FOR TOMORROW AND YOU'RE RIGHT
MAYBE IT MAY BE OUTSIDE THAT
FIFTEEN FOOT AREA MAY BE PART
OF THE TAXPAYERS ARE NOT BUT IT
AFFECTS US ALL RIGHT. WHAT IF
THAT'S HAPPENING WHAT ABOUT
PUTTING PEOPLE TO WORK IN
MARRYING THAT ISSUE WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY ISSUE. WE'RE
TRYING NOT TO PUT BURDENS ON
THE STATE BUDGET WHICH THAT
IMPACTS DEVELOPING DISABLED AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND ALL THE OTHER
EDUCATION OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE CHALLENGES FOR. INCOMING
AND BEING CREATIVE. THE IMPACT
OF THIS IS NOT UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY SIX. THERE'S NEVER BEEN
A BETTER TIME TO BORROW.
SENATOR BILL SENT ME A NOTE AND
I THINK HE'S RIGHT IF YOU LOOK
AT INFLATION FACTORS VERSUS THE
ABILITY TO SET THE RATE NOW.
THAT'S THE KEY WE CAN BORROW
NOW AT A CHEAPER RATE. THE
GOVERNMENT ARE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE ABILITY TO DETERMINE. THESE
OTHER ISSUES WITH THE ABILITY
TO DEBATE THE ISSUE IS TO
NEXUS. AS WE MOVE FORWARD. BUT
WE MAKE A BIG STATEMENT. GOING
FORWARD. THAT THIS REALLY ISN'T
JUST MOVING THE DOLLARS I WANT
TO SHARE. IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOME OF THE BIG RATING AGENCIES.
AND WHAT THE BECAUSE I'M
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS BORING I
THOUGHT WAS CENTER MORE LIKE
CITIES RIGHT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT HE SAID. BUT WHAT
THEY TELL US AS WE FACE THIS
PANDEMIC. THE FIRES AND ALL THE
THINGS. THEY'RE MORE INTERESTED
IS DO WE OFFER A VISION FORWARD
THAN WHAT THE DEBT EQUITY RATIO
IS. DO WE HAVE A PLAN AS A
GOVERNMENT. TO MOVE FORWARD TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THESE
CHALLENGES AND MITIGATE THE
RISK THAT'S THE BIGGER THING
WHEN THEY LOOK TO A RATING
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
I DO KNOW THAT WE OFTEN FACE
THAT ISSUE OF THE YOU KNOW OUR
DEBT RATING IN THE LIGHT. BUT
I'M TELLING YOU WE HAVE VETTED
THIS WITH FOLKS DEALING WITH
THE LARGER ISSUE. I WANT TO
THANK MR LEOPARDS THE CRAVEN I
WANT TO THANK. SORRY OF MY
OFFICE SOMEONE THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE ASSEMBLY WORKED
HARD ON THIS. I THINK THAT THE
ARGUMENT WITH RELATED
TRANSPARENCY IS WRONG. BECAUSE
THIS IS SIMPLY TAKING THESE
ARCTIC PIECES OF ARCHITECTURE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- I THINK HAS
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL. WITH
RESPECT TO A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES TRYING TO. PATIENT
PRIORITY ON THESE THINGS WHICH
I GIVE THEM GREAT. ACCOLADES
AND RESPECT FOR IN THAT REGARD
SO. I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE.
BUT IT IS. DYSTROPHY A TERMS OF
THESE FIRES AND SO WITH THAT
BEHALF OF THE JOINT AUTHORS
PARTICULARLY SENATOR BLOOM WHO
WERE PRESENTING FOR YOU TODAY
AND SOMEBODY OR MULLIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
HERTZBERG CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE PHONE WE HAVE A
MOTION. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JUST TO CLARIFY
CHAIRED THE AMENDMENTS. WE'RE
NOT SPOKEN TO. OKAY ON THE ON
THE MOTION I MENTIONED THE-
AUTHOR REQUESTED THE AMENDMENTS
SO YOU'RE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AS PART OF THE- WE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. AND MULLIN YES AS
AMENDED YES OKAY THANK YOU.
EIGHTY SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL NOBODY.
WESSON UPLOADING MOORLACH. NO
LUCKNOW BRADFORD. CHIANG CHANGE
NOW HANG THEM. DOLLY ALI NO
TELLING THEM. DOT HI DAD HI
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG I.
HILL. HILL BY MCGUIRE HI
REQUIRED BY RUBIO. NAVALNY
REALLY NOT VOTING SKINNER OUR
SKINNER I. STERN STERN I WIENER.
WIENER HI. M. SEVEN AS M. THREE
KNOWS. MOTION PASSES HER CASE
FOR THE BOOK THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT YEAH
OKAY THE BILLS OUT. OKAY VERY
WELL MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY WILL
NOW. THE GENERAL COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A BY THE WAY BEFORE WE
ADJOURN DO WE HAVE ANY- DID
EVERYBODY GO UP ON THE LAST
BILL. OKAY WELL WE WILL
KNOWLEDGE PERJURED OUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR PARTICIPATION.